HELLO MORNING EVERYONE THANK YOU
ALL FOR SHOWING UP ON TIME
APOLOGIES AND A COUPLE MINUTES
LATE WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT HEARING COMMITTEE.
DUE TO ONGOING COVER NINETEEN
SAFETY CONSIDERATIONS WE ARE
PRACTICING PHYSICAL DISTANCING
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM SO WE
ARE ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WATCHING
PARTICIPATE IN THE HEARING. ROOM
IN PERSON. WE HAVE FIFTEEN.
BILLS ON OUR AGENDA TODAY WE'RE
ASKING AUTHORS TO GIVE SISON
PRESENTATIONS EACH BILL KIND OF
TWO MAIN WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION EACH MY AGE MAIN WHEN
THIS GETS TWO MINUTES EACH AN
IDEA TIME YOU ALSO. WE LIKE
BREVITY WE STRONGLY ENCOURAGE
PRIMARY WITNESSES TO APPEAR IN
PERSON BUT WE'LL MAKE EXCEPTIONS
ON A CASE BY CASE BASIS. PLEASE
BE ADVISED THAT FOR ALL OTHER
WITNESSES CALLING IN TO REGISTER
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION ON BILLS WE
ASK THAT YOU ONLY SAY YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL. IF YOU SAY ANYMORE THE
OPERATOR WILL CUT YOU OFF. IF
YOU ARE UNABLE TO GET THROUGH ON
THE PHONES PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
SUBMIT WRITTEN TESTIMONY THROUGH
THE PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. THIS WILL BECOME PART
OF THE OFFICIAL RECORD OF THE
BILL YOU CAN ALSO SUBMIT AN
EMAIL. TO THE COMMITTEE STAFF.
WE HAVE A FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS
FOR WITNESS TESTIMONY TODAY FOR
THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM. WE CAN
ONLY ACCOMMODATE I'M A NUMBER OF
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO EXIT
THE ROOM IF YOU'RE DONE
TESTIFYING AND NO LONGER NEED TO
REMAIN IN THE HEARING ROOM. FOR
DIALING WITNESSES. WE WILL ALSO
BE USING A MODERATED. TELEPHONE
SERVICE THROUGH WHICH ANY
WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON A BILL.
THE CALL NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING
IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX. NINE
TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE.
ONE FIVE ONE TWO SIX. YOU CAN
ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS
WELL AS ON YOUR TV SCREEN. IF
YOU ARE CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN
TO DO SO. AS THE AUTHOR OF THE
BILL YOUR TESTIFYING ON IS
BEGINNING THEIR BILL
PRESENTATION. THE OPERATOR ON
THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE PLACED
IN THE QUEUE BASED ON WHETHER
YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE THE BILL.
IF YOU'RE CALLING IN PLEASE
ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND NOISE
THIS INCLUDES. OR LIVE STREAM
BROADCAST AS YOUR SMART DEVICE.
AND YOUR SMART DEVICE TO REDUCE
THE SOUND DISTORTION. PLEASE BE
. THAT IF YOU ARE. A MAIN IS
PROVIDING. FOR AGAIN TO BE.
YOU'LL REMAIN. ALIVE WILL NEED
TO MUTE. UNTIL YOU ARE CALLED TO
SPEAK ON. I ALSO WNT TO KNOW WE
ARE ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGH THE POSITION LETTER-
PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. WE MAY NEED TO LIMIT
HOW LONG THE PHONE LINES ARE
OPEN FOR EACH BILL AS WE ARE IN
A TIGHT HEARING SCHEDULE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
UNDERSTANDING AND WITH THAT CAN
YOU PLEASE TAKE ROLE. WE HEAR
HELLO THIS ONE. SORRY WICKS HERE
HERE SEYARTO HERE'S A ARE TWO
YEAR CARILLO CARILLO HERE
GABRIEL. KALRA KALRA HERE KILEY
QUIRK-SILVA QUIRK-SILVA HERE
WARRANT. WE HAVE A GREAT LET'S
GET THE SHOW ON THE ROAD OKAY MR
GRAYSON WHEN YOU'RE READY FOR AB
TWENTY THREE OH FIVE. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT TO YOU
THIS MORNING AB TWENTY THREE
ZERO FIVE WHICH WILL ESTABLISH A
COORDINATED HOUSING FINANCE
COMMITTEE TO ALLOCATE STATE CAN.
ROUTE SOURCE FOR AFFORDABLE
RENTAL HOUSING CALIFORNIA'S
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FINANCE
SYSTEM IS COMPRISED OF FOUR
SEPARATE ENTITIES WHICH
ADMINISTER A VARIETY OF
FINANCIAL RESOURCES INCLUDING
LOANS TAX CREDITS TAX EXEMPT
BONDS TO HOUSING DEVELOPERS WHO
BUILD AND RITA. A FULL. LOWER
INCOME HI. INTRO TWENTY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR FOUND
THAT THE LACK OF COORDINATION
AMONG THESE ENTITIES HAS REDUCE
THE EFFECTIVENESS OF THE STATE'S
RESPONSE TO OUR HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS. DEVELOPERS
THEY WERE INTERVIEWED FOR THE
AUDIT EXPRESS THE NEED FOR A
SYSTEM THAT CONSOLIDATES AND
COORDINATES MULTIPLE HOUSING
RESOURCES INTO ONE CENTRALIZED
PROCESS THE REPORT CONCLUDED
THAT A STANDARD SET OF
REQUIREMENTS. CONSISTENT
DEADLINES AND A SINGLE
APPLICATION PROCESS FOR MULTI
FAMILY HOUSING PROGRAMS WOULD
NOT ONLY REDUCE THE LIKELIHOOD
OF DELAYS FOR APPLICANTS BUT IT
WOULD ALSO BUT IT COULD ALSO
INCREASE THE STATE'S SUPPLY OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. THE FINDINGS
OF THE STATE AUDITOR HAVE SINCE.
BEEN ECHOED IN NUMEROUS
DIFFERENT. JUST THIS VERY MONTH
THE LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION
RELEASED A REPORT ON BARRIERS TO
AFFORDABLE TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PRODUCTION WHICH FOUND THE
CURRENT ARRANGEMENT QUOTE. IS
INEFFICIENT RESULTING IN
CONFUSION OVER RESPONSIBILITIES
SERVICE GAPS AND A DISCONNECT
BETWEEN STATE GOALS AND POLICIES
ACT'S TWENTY TWENTY TWO
STATEWIDE HOUSING PLANNED. THAT
QUOTE THE BACKLOG OF PROJECTS
THAT APPLIED FOR DID NOT RECEIVE
PUBLIC FINANCING ASSISTANCE OVER
THE PAST FEW YEARS SHOWS US THAT
WE MUST CAREFULLY MANAGE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING INVESTMENTS.
AND THAT THERE ARE PROBLEMATIC
AREAS WITHIN HOUSING FINANCES.
LAST FALL I HAVE THE PRIVILEGE
OF EMBARKING HONEST WIDE HOUSING
. OR WITH YEAH OF THE OF THIS
COMMITTEE AS A MATTER OF FACT
THAT ALMOST EVERY STOP ON THE
TOUR WE HEARD FROM AFFORDABLE
DEVELOPERS THAT THE LACK OF
COORDINATION BETWEEN THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT. THE
CALIFORNIA TAX OKAY MAYBE THE
CALIFORNIA DEBT LIMIT ALLOCATION
COMMITTEE AND THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING FINANCE AGENCY WAS A
SERIOUS IMPEDIMENT TO THE
PRODUCTION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. IN TO THE FOR WHAT WAS
ON NEED FOR REFORM I HAVE
INTRODUCED AB TWENTY THREE IS
FIVE. THIS BILL WILL CREATE
ORDER HOUSING FOR COMMITTEE
WHICH WILL ALLOCATE STATE
CONTROLLED RESOURCES FOR THE
FINANCE OF AFFORDABLE RENTAL
HOUSING THROUGH A SINGLE PROCESS
. AND COMPETITION AND WILL ALLOW
AN APPLICANT TO OBTAIN ALL
NECESSARY SYSTEM AT ONE. WITH A
APPLICATION IMPORTANTLY THE
CREATION OF THE COMMITTEE WILL
NOT ALTER OR TRANSFER ANY OF THE
AUTHORITIES CURRENTLY ENJOYED BY
THE FOR AGENCIES AND TO
CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICERS WHO
OVERSEE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
POLICY THAT IS IN THE STATE.
RATHER THE COMMITTEE WILL
PROVIDE A FOCAL POINT FOR
CONVERSATION AND COORDINATION
AMONG THE VARIOUS ACTORS TO
PARAPHRASE THE LATE WHO
COMMISSIONS RATIONALE REFORM MY
GOAL IS NOT TO CRITIQUE THE
RELAY. BUT THE GOVERNOR AND THE
STE TRY. IT SIMPLY WILL PROVE ON
A DRUG BURKE IS CALL. BEST OF
CIRCUMSTANCE. AS THE COME AS
RIGHT. AND I QUOTE NO MATTER HOW
GOOD THE RELATIONSHIP THE
GOVERNOR AND STATE TREASURER.
THE END STATE JR VOTE CHANGE
EITHER BOTH OF THE- FOLDERS AT
THREE EIGHT THIS CALIFORNIA NEED
ALONG TERM SALUTE. CHIEF WE NEED
IT I AM. TRUCKS THAT LONG POLICY
BUT NATION I WILL COME. AND
COMMITTEE TO ENGAGE WITH ALL
STATE. ON THIS MEASURE AS THE
BILL MOVES- THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WITH THE OF
CRAFTING A POLICY THAT
FACILITATES THE MOST IF SO POTS
. AND HERE ME TODAY DISCUSS THE
IMPORTANCE THE BILL WOULD LIKE
TO AND THE BILL SPONSOR THE
HONOR BETTY CAL STATE CONTROLLER
THE CHIP. HEY THANK YOU VERY OF
WOMEN ISN'T MORNING A MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS. OF THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY AND-
THANK YOU A PARTICULAR MADAM
CHAIR FOR REALLY CALLING US TO-
ELEVATE OUR AMBITION. TO MEET
OUR ASPIRATION TO ADDRESS ALL OF
OUR FORD WILL HOUSING NEEDS HERE
IN CALIFORNIA NO ANSWER
CONTROLLER I DO SERVICE BOARD
MEMBER OF THE TAX CREDIT
ALLOCATION COMMITTEE AS WELL AS
THE CALIFORNIA DEBT LIMIT
ALLOCATION COMMITTEE. HAVE SEEN
FIRST HAND HOW WE ARE IN OUR OWN
WAY WHEN IT COMES TO FUNDING AND
BUILDING DESPERATELY NEEDED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN OUR STATE.
WE ARE CURRENTLY REQUIRING THOSE
SEEKING STATE SUPPORT TO HELP
FINANCE CONSTRUCTION OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS TO
WORK THEIR WAY THROUGH A
GAUNTLET OF PROSTHESES AND
REQUIREMENTS FROM NO LESS THAN
FOR STATE DEPARTMENTS. OF THE
SAME PLEASED TO SPONSOR AB
TWENTY THREE OH FIVE WHICH WILL
STREAM AND PROCESS. ONCE BOB.
DOLE MULTI FAMILY HOUSING
DEVELOPER TO OBTAIN EXAM BONDS.
THEY FEDERAL TAX CREDITS AND
STATE SUBSIDY LOANS THERE ARE
THREE BENEFITS THAT I WANT TO
JUST HIGHLIGHT OF WITH RESPECT
TO THIS PROPOSAL. ALIGNING THE
ALLOCATION OF THESE FUNDS WILL
BE FIRST REDUCE THE TIME AND
COST THE STAKEHOLDERS APPLYING
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING FUNDING
FROM THE STATE. CURRENTLY
PROJECTS MUST GO THROUGH A MULTI
YEAR PROCESS TO RECEIVE AWARDS
FROM H. CD SET BLACK ANTI CAC.
IF THE PROJECT IS UNSUCCESSFUL
IN ANYONE COMPETITIONS- THEY
HAVE TO RE APPLY. OFTEN MULTIPLE
TIMES DURING THE TIMELINE
SLOWING THE TIME MY IN SINGLE
COSTS. A LAST YEAR THE USE
BERKELEY TURNER'S FOR PULSE
INNOVATION IT SHOULD BE. ON THE-
OF. HIS TIME. AROUND IN THE
RECOMMENDATION TO. A ONE STOP
SHOP. SO WILL. COULD OF WHAT.
BEING MULTIPLE DEPARTMENTS H. C.
D. COLLEGE OF IS BLACK. ALL
REVIEW APPLICATION- INSURE PRO
COMPLY MAKES AWARD IN THE- OF
ONE ANOTHER. AND AS OF MISTER
GRAYSON OF NOTED THE STATE
AUDITOR IN THE LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION HAVE BOTH IDENTIFY.
THIS DISJOINTED AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FINANCE STRUCTURE AS AN
IMPEDIMENT TO MEETING THE
STATE'S HOUSING SUPPLY GOALS.
AND THIRDLY THIS WILL ALSO ALLOW
FOR MORE EFFICIENT AND TIMELY
DISTRIBUTION OF STATE
ADMINISTERED AND CONTROLLED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FUNDS. AND I
WOULD ALSO DO OR SAY A GREATER
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY.
IN TWENTY. THE SUPPLY PRIVATE
ACTIVITY BOND WERE PROCESS
BECAME OVERSUBSCRIBED. WE BETTER
COORDINATE OUR PROGRAMS TO MAKE
THE MOST OF OUR LIMITED HOUSING
OF SOURCES. MANY PROJECTS THAT
HAVE RECEIVED FUNDING YOU SEE IF
YOU THE FEW SEVEN OPEN OLD. US
ARE STILL WAY ON SOME. AWARDS
FROM SAID LIKE ANTIQUE TO
FINALIZE OUR FINANCES. SO FOR
EXAMPLE THE FLETCHER ELSE IN THE
VOTERS APPROVED THREE BILLION
DOLLARS IN GENERAL OBLIGATION
BONDS IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN. BUT
THE SPONSOR TO LONGER THAN
ANTICIPATED TO BE UTILIZED DUE
TO PROCESS. INEFFICIENCIES MANY
STAKEHOLDERS TO. HAVE BOUNCED
HOW TO BETTER FROM THE CAR
FINANCE STRUCTURE. HOWEVER THE
STRUCK DOES NOT WORK TO FOR
PRODUCE THE AFFORD HOUSING THAT
CALIFORNIA DAYS AND THE NUMBERS
YES YOU'RE OF YOUR PRODUCTION IS
UP. OF THE WINNIPEG TOWARDS THE
DEMANDS OF THAT IS REQUIRED IN
CALIFORNIA TO MEET ALL OF OUR
NEEDS WE ARE WOEFULLY
INADEQUATE- SO. WE HAVE- MAKE
CRITICAL INVESTMENTS IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING OVER THE LAST
FEW YEARS BUT WITHOUT A MORE
EFFICIENT ALLOCATION SYSTEM MUCH
OF THIS THE FUNDING IS WASTED
THREE DELAYS AND UNNECESSARY
BUREAUCRACY. SO THIS IS A FIRST
STEP IN GETTING OUR OWN HOUSE IN
ORDER OF IN WITHIN STATE
GOVERNMENT TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
THE MILLIONS OF IN HOUSE. AND
RENT BURDEN CALIFORNIANS AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS BILL. AND I HAVE
TONY SEARCHES MY DEBIT
CONTROLLER FOR HOUSING POLICY
WITH ME FOR TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU IS WHAT
EVERY OTHER. PARENTS IN SUPPORT
OKAY. LET'S GO TO- WITNESSES IN
THE ROOM IN SUPPORT NAME
ORGANIZATION A POSITION. GOOD
MORNING DEBORAH CARLSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. MICHAEL I WHISPER IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND
SEEING NO OTHER WITNESSES IN THE
ROOM OPERATOR KEY PLEASE OPEN UP
THE PHONE LINES FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY THREE OH
FIVE NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION. WE HAVE ON THE PHONE
MISTER JOHN STOKER MR STROKER-
AND SHOULD. BE TESTIFIED FOR
TWENTY FOUR PROBLEMS OPENING.
BEGINS BUT DISTRAUGHT SO GROUND-
BECAUSE FINE FOR AB EIGHTEEN
FIFTY THANK YOU. SORRY COMMITTEE
OPERATIVE QUEUE SPEAK UP A
LITTLE BIT. YES THE ONLY
WITNESSES ON THE PHONE RIGHT NOW
IS FOR ANOTHER BILL. SO WE DON'T
HAVE A WITNESSES ON THE FALL
THANK YOU WILL BRING IT BACK
HERE TO THE COMMITTEE ROOM-
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION DO WE
HAVE ANY. I ANY OTHER FOLKS IN
THE ROOM. ONE AT ON ANY OF.
OPPOSITION TO. AB TWENTY THREE
OR FIVE. OKAY OPERATOR IF WE CAN
OVER THE PHONE LINES FOR
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY THREE OH
FIVE. HELLO GENTLEMAN TO- BOISE
OPPOSITION TWENTY OH FIVE THREE
FOUR ONE THEN ZERO. AT THIS TIME
. WE'LL GO FIRST TO LINE NUMBER
THIRTY FIVE ONE THIRTY FIVE
LINES OF WORKPLACE. HI MY NAME
IS GINA FROM THE RESTAURANT
UNITED NETWORK CALLING AND
SUPPORT OF. EIGHTY NINE SIXTY
ONE. A I'M SURE WE HAVE NO
ADDITIONAL SPEAKERS AND KEEP.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL
BRING IT BACK HERE THE COMMITTEE
ROOM- TWENTY MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
QUESTIONS FOR MR GRAYSON CONTROL
HE- MISS QUIRK-SILVA. I'M NOT A
QUESTION BUT DONE JUST TO
COMPLEMENT TIME COMIC A CO
AUTHOR ON THIS BUT AND WELCOME
TO OUR STATE TREASURER- BUT THIS
IS WHAT WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
HOW DO WE- TAKE THEIR LIMITED
RESOURCES WE HAVE AND GET THEM
ACT AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE AND
THIS HAS ELUDED US AND I THINK
THIS MONTH HI DEFINITELY
ADDRESSES IT SO. THANK YOU. MR
GABRIEL YOU TO EXTEND MY
COMPLIMENTS AROUND REYES
RESPECTFULLY ASK TO BE ADDED AS
A CO AUTHOR OF THAT'S- FEW
SEARCHES. ANY OTHER. COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. WELL-
MISTER GRAYSON ALSO WANNA-
APPLIED YOUR HARD WORK HERE IN
THIS AYE ECHO THE CONTENT OF THE
SENTIMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUES HERE
IN THE DIS OBVIOUSLY ARE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FINANCE
FINANCING SYSTEM NEEDS TO BE
STREAMLINED I KNOW IT'S NOT
EASY- BUT I APPRECIATE THE GOOD
WORK HERE WOULD ALSO LIKE TO BE
ADDED ON AS A CO AUTHOR AS WELL
APPRECIATE THE CONTROLLER FOR
BEING HERE AS WELL- AND- CLOSE.
S. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
HONORED TO BE ABLE TO ADD ON CO
REQUEST ALSO WHEN THE STATE THAT
IT'S AN HONOR TO BE ABLE TO WORK
WITH THE HONORABLE BETTY ARE
CALIFORNIA STATE CONTROLLER THE
ISSUES RAISED BY THE A STATE
AUDITOR OF THE LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION AND EIGHT CD ARE
REALLY NOT A RESULT OF ACTION OR
EVEN AN ACTION BY ANY INDIVIDUAL
AGENCY OR ADMINISTRATION. THE
CURRENT DYSFUNCTION IN OUR
STATES AFFORDABLE HOUSING
FINANCE SYSTEM IS A SYMPTOM OF A
STRUCTURAL PROBLEM THAT IS
LARGER THAN ANYONE OFFICE SO
WITH THAT WE NEED A SOLUTION
COMMENSURATE WITH THE SCALE OF
THE PROBLEM AND I BELIEVE THAT
THIS BILL WILL HELP SET US ON
THE PATH TO IMPLEMENTING SUCH AS
POLLUTION WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I. CAN
DO WE HAVE SHOWN SOME OF THE- I
WITH MY- SECOND I WITH THAT
PLACE TO THROW. WHAT DO PASSED
TO THE ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN
APPROPRIATIONS WEEKS FIVE I
SEYARTO C. A. R. T. Y. U. I.
GABRIEL I HAVE REALIZED KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY QUIRK-SILVA
QUIRK-SILVA I WARD WART BY. AND
BILL IS OUT REYES YES OKAY THANK
RIGHT OUT OF JAIL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. IF ONLY THEY WERE
ALSO EASY. WE WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO- IT'S GOING TO COMMITTEE RAIN
YEAH- FILE ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN.
SAD FACE- NEXT YEAR- SO LET WITH
THAT LET'S JUST START GOING
THROUGH- AS MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WHO ARE PRESENTING
BILLS WHEN WE GO TO MISTER WOULD
. OKAY MISS QUIRK-SILVA ARE YOU
READY OKAY GREAT- IT. OKAY I
DON'T MIND YES OKAY- WE.
EIGHTEEN FIFTY EIGHT OKAY- IS
QUIRK-SILVA WILL PRESENT- AB
EIGHTEEN FIFTY EIGHT FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE.
SHE WAS IN OPPOSITION WAS YOUR-
RIGHT. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND COLLEAGUES TODAY I PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN FIFTY
EIGHT WHICH EXTENDS EXISTING
EXPECTATIONS AND CODE
ENFORCEMENT TO BUILDING USED FOR
HUMAN HABITATION REGARDLESS OF
ZONING AND IMPROVES TENANT
PROTECTIONS WHEN BUILDINGS ARE
DEEMED UNSAFE. CURRENT LAW
PROVIDES THAT IF ANY DWELLING
NOT UP TO STANDARDS. AND PUTS
THE RESIDENT OR THE PUBLIC IN
HARM'S WAY MUST COMPLY WITH CODE
INSPECTIONS HOWEVER THERE IS
AMBIGUITY IN THE LAW WHETHER
THESE PROTECTIONS APPLY TO
BUILDINGS NOT RESIDENTIALLY
ZONED EVEN IF THEY ARE BEING
INHABITED. AS WE KNOW SADLY
THERE HAVE BEEN SOME DIRE
CONSEQUENCES WITH PEOPLE LIVING
AND BUILDINGS MAYBE NOT LEGALLY
BUT THAT WERE NOT UP TO CODE AND
HAVE ACTUALLY DIED. STE
SUBSTANDARD CONDITIONS AND
ASSOCIATED DANGERS DO NOT CEASE
TO EXIST JUST BECAUSE OF ZONING
FOR THE PAST DECADE CALIFORNIA
HAS AND CONTINUES TO EXPERIENCE
A HOUSING SHORTAGE OF
SIGNIFICANT PROPORTIONS
PARTICULARLY IN THE FOR DOUBLE
HOUSING SECTOR AND THE HOMELESS
POPULATION HAS ALMOST DOUBLED
SINCE THE PANDEMIC. INDIVIDUALS
AND FAMILIES WHO ARE UNABLE TO
FIND AVAILABLE BEDS IN HOMELESS
SHELTERS ARE SEEKING SHELTER
FROM THE STREETS AND TAKING UP
RESIDENCE AND BUILDINGS THAT
HAVE NOT BEEN ZONED RESIDENTIAL
. THIS HAS ENHANCED A PROBLEM
WHERE BOTH WAREHOUSES AND
FACTORY SPACES ARE BEING
CONVERTED TO RESIDENTIAL USE
WITHOUT THE KNOWLEDGE OF LOCAL
OFFICIALS AND WITHOUT THE
BUILDING BEING HABITABLE DESPITE
MANY PAIN THE OWNER RENT MANY
WHO ARE PAYING THE OWNER TO RENT
THE SPACE. MANY OF THESE
WAREHOUSES FACTORIES AND
BUILDINGS ARE NOT IN RESIDENTIAL
ZONES AND THEREFORE HAVE EVADED
MUCH NEEDED INSPECTION. IN
DECEMBER TWENTY SIXTEEN AS I
MENTIONED DEADLY
FIRE IN OAKLAND WHERE HOUSE
KNOWN AS THE GO SHIP THAT KILLED
THIRTY SIX PEOPLE. THE HIGHEST
DEATH TOLL FOR STRUCTURAL FIRE
IN THE UNITED STATES IN OVER A
DECADE. GO SHIP WAS A TWO STORY
WAREHOUSETHAT WAS ILLEGALLY
BEING LEASED TO ARTISTS WHO LIVE
AND WORK IN THE BUILDING AND
PERIODICALLY USING IT FOR EVEN.
ZONED AS A WAREHOUSE NEITHER
RESIDENTIAL NOR ASSEMBLY USES
WERE PERMITTED BY THE CITY AND
THE BUILDING WAS NOT DESIGNED OR
BUILT FOR HUMAN HABITATION.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS TRAGEDY IS
NOT AN ISOLATED INCIDENT
UNHEALTHY HOUSING HAS SERVED AS
AN AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR TOO
MANY CALIFORNIANS FOR TOO LONG.
WHAT I'LL JUST ADD TO THIS IS
THIS IS GOING TO INCREASE AS WE
KNOW THAT THERE ARE MANY MANY
PEOPLE SEEKING HOUSING THERE ARE
MANY. INDIVIDUALS THAT MAY OWN
OR OPERATE THESE BUILDINGS AND
ARE LOOKING FOR CREATIVE WAYS TO
GET PEOPLE HOUSE SO WITH THAT I
HAVE WITH ME MISTER MISTER
MATTHEW SILVA WHO IS THE CHAIR
OF THE LEGISLATIVE COMMUTE BUT-
COMMITTEE OF CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF CODE ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS. AND THE SPONSOR OF AB
EIGHTEEN FIFTY SIX AND MISTER
EDUARDO TORRES CALIFORNIA
REGIONAL COORDINATOR FOR TENANTS
TOGETHER HERE. TO SPEAK IN
BEHALF OF THIS BILL. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS A LOT OF A
TAURUS I AM THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA REGIONAL COORDINATOR
FOR TENANTS TOGETHER A STATEWIDE
COALITION OF MEMBER
ORGANIZATIONS THAT IS DEDICATED
TO DEFENDING AND ADVANCING
RIGHTS OF CALIFORNIA TENANTS TO
SAFE. AND DECENT AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING- TODAY TO GET MY
TESTIMONY ABOUT SOME OF THE
CONDITIONS THAT RENTERS ACROSS
THE STATE FACED WHILE LIVING IN
SLUMBER CONDITIONS. AS A
REGIONAL COORDINATOR I HAVE
WITNESSED SLUMLORDS OPERATE
UNSAFE RENTALS WITHOUT ANY
CONSEQUENCES. I WANT TO SHARE A
QUICK STORY THOUGH ABOUT A
BUILDING WHERE THE SLUM LORD
DESPITE MULTIPLE CODE VIOLATIONS
AND FORCE ACT MIGHT MULTIPLE
CODE VIOLATION FOR SPENCE-
REFUSED TO FIX HABITABILITY
PROBLEMS. IN CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
THE TENANTS AT GLENBROOK GREEN
WERE UNDER THE MERCY OF AN OWNER
WHO WOULD NOT MAKE ANY REPAIRS
THE TENANTS LIVE WITH MOLD BED
BUGS COCKROACHES. HOLES IN THE
ROOF BAD PLUMBING BROKEN HEATERS
HOLES ON THE FLOOR BROKEN
WINDOWS AND BROKEN SMOKE ALARMS
. WHEN TENANTS HAVE REQUESTED
REPAIRS HAVE BEEN MET WITH
THREATS OF DISPLACEMENT.
EVENTUALLY CODE ENFORCEMENT
CITED THE OWNER FROM MULTIPLE
CODE VIOLATIONS BUT AT THE END
NOTHING HAS CHANGED AND TENANTS
ARE STILL FORCED TO LIVE IN
UNSAFE HOMES. STORIES LIKE THESE
UNFORTUNATELY ARE VERY UNCOMMON
IN CALIFORNIA CHILDREN ARE
FORCED TO LIVE WITH BED BUGS
PEOPLE ARE WITH RESPIRATORY
PROBLEMS ARE FORCED TO LIVE WITH
MOLD. FAMILIES ARE FORCED TO
LIVE WITH COCKROACH AND RAT
INFESTATIONS. THIS IS WHY AB
EIGHTEEN FIFTY EIGHT IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR CALIFORNIA
RENTERS. RECEIVERSHIP TAKE AWAY
THESE INHABITABLE BUILDINGS. ARE
FROM A RESPONSIBLE PROPERTY
OWNERS WHO HAVE NOT INVESTCORP
NOT INVESTED INTO RENTALS.
CURRENTLY SLUMLORDS HAVE
BENEFITTED FROM NOT PAYING THEIR
FAIR SHARE OF RELOCATION FEES
THIS BILL IS MAKING SURE THAT
RENTERS SAFETY IS PROTECTED SO
THAT SO THEY DON'T BECOME
HOUSELESS. THE CURRENT LAW IS
INADEQUATE AND PUTS RENTERS
WE'RE AT RISK. THERE'S NOT
ENOUGH MONEY FOR RENTERS IF THEY
ARE FORCED TO MOVE FIFTY SIX
DOLLARS A DAY IS NOT ENOUGH. BUT
NOW WILL HAVE A SOLUTIONS TO GET
TO HELP. THIS BILL GIVES JUDGES
A SOLUTION TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
REMEDY IS ADEQUATE AND FAIR.
THIS BILL ADDRESS A SERIOUS
HEALTH CODE VIOLATIONS WHERE
IT'S NOT SAFE FOR RENTERS TO BE
PRESIDENT. WE DON'T WANT THE
STATE TO SUBSTITUTE UNSAFE
HOUSING FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
THANK YOU. BOARDING MY NAME IS
MATTHEW SILVER IN FIRST OF ALL I
LIKE TO SAY THANK YOU FOR HAVING
US HERE THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
WITH YOU- SECONDLY I AM A
CERTIFIED CODE ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER IN THE CHAIR OF THE
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE FOR THE
TOP FORTIES. TEACHING A CODE
ENFORCER LOBSTERS. VERY BRIEFLY
A CODE ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS-
COULD FORCE OFFICERS ARE THE
FRONT LINE IN ENFORCING A
BUILDING CODES AND HOUSING CODES
IN OUR CALIFORNIA IN OUR
CALIFORNIA A STATE. WE DEAL WITH
A WHOLE LITANY OF QUALITY OF
LIFE ISSUES AND WE ARE OFTEN THE
ONLY ONES IN FORCING THESE. SO
DEALING WITH HOUSING ISSUES IN
PARTICULAR SUB STANDARD HOUSING
IS PART OF OUR EVERYDAY JOB.
ACCORDING TO THE U. THAT U. S.
CENSUS BUREAU OVER TWO MILLION
CALIFORNIANS ARE LIVING IN
SUBSTANDARD HOUSING IN THE
STATE. ALONE THIS INVOLVES
THINGS SOME EXAMPLES WE
TYPICALLY SEE LACK OF HOT WATER.
LACK OF HEAT MOLD BED BUGS I CAN
TELL YOU FROM FIRST PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE. I WAS IN A PROPERTY
IN SANTA BARBARA COUNTY AND I
WALKED IN AND A LITTLE CHILD
STOOD UP COVERED HEAD TO TOE IN
BED BUG. BITES THIS COULD NOT
CONTINUE TO OCCUR IN CALIFORNIA.
FORTUNATELY WE HAVE GOOD HOUSING
LAWS THE PROBLEM IS THAT THERE
ARE LOOPHOLES IN THESE LAWS. AND
WHAT WE'RE SEEING IS THAT
SLUMLORDS OR DRIVING TRUCKS
THROUGH THESE LOOPHOLES TO AVOID
RESPONSIBILITY. TO REFUSE OR OR
DELAYED ABATEMENT OTHER
PROPERTIES AND TO DRIVE UP THE
COST FOR COMPLIANCE. AS A RESULT
OF THAT WE ARE SEEING TRAGEDIES
OCCUR IN PROPERTIES LIKE THE
GHOST SHIP FIRE. I KNOW GO SHIP
OCCURRED A COUPLE YEARS AGO BUT
I AM SAD TO SIT HERE BEFORE YOU
AND TELL YOU WHAT THAT IS NOT AN
ISOLATED INCIDENT. THIS OCCURS
AND I SEE IT ALL THE TIME IN
CALIFORNIA. AS YOU THE THOUSANDS
OF OUR CODE ENFORCEMENT OFFICER
MEMBERS. THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
WE CANNOT ALLOW SUB STANDARD
HOUSING- TO BE EXCUSE FOR A
HOUSING CRISIS. THIS BILL DOES
THREE THINGS THESE THREE THINGS
ARE REALLY IMPORTANT TO MAKE OUR
LAWS MORE EFFECTIVE. EFFICIENT
AND FAIR FROM THOSE SUFFERING
AND SUBGENERA HOUSING. ONE IS A
CLOSES A LOOPHOLE THAT MAKES
CLEAR NOW WITH THIS BILL. THAT
THIS LAW APPLIES TO ANY PROPERTY
OCCUPIED REGARDLESS OF ZONING.
MOLD BED BUGS FIRE HAZARDS
ELECTRICAL HAZARDS THE DOES
THESE ITEMS DON'T KNOW. A ZONING
DISTRICTS THEY DON'T KNOW
PROPERTY LINES. SO THEY DON'T
CARE SO IS LIVING IN A WAREHOUSE
OR NOT THEY'LL KILL THEM OR HURT
THEM JUST THE SAME. SECONDLY IT
GIVES A JUDGE DISCRETION. TO
GIVE TENANT RELOCATION BENEFITS
THAT ACTUALLY ARE EFFECTIVE I'VE
SEEN CASES WHERE BECAUSE OF THE
STRICT FORMULA IN THE LAW. THE
RELOCATION BENEFITS ARE SO SMALL
NO WE CAN ACTUALLY LIVE ANYWHERE
WITH THAT THAT'S A REAL. CLEAR
HERE. CURRENT LAW AND THIS LAW
DOES NOT CHANGE THIS IS BILL NOT
IT CURRENT LAW SAYS THE ONLY
LAWFUL TENANTS ARE ENTITLED TO
RELOCATION BENEFITS. THIS DOES
NOT COVER AND WE DO NOT CHANGE
THIS THIS DOES NOT COVER
SQUATTERS OR TRUST PASSERS THIS
IS ONLY PAYING TENANTS. WHO HAVE
BEEN PAYING FOR THE INDIGNITY OF
LIVING IN SUBSTANDARD HOUSING IN
IF A COURT DETERMINES THAT THAT
UNITIS SUB STANDARD AND NEEDS
TO BE FIXED UP. THERE IS FOR
SOMEONE TO LIVE IN IT WHILE THE
OLDER OPEN WHILE LOGICAL ISSUES
ARE BEING REPAIRED AWHILE KISSED
BY HEAT IS NOT EVEN BEING
PROVIDED THEY HAVE TO LIVE
SOMEWHERE. ONLY IN THAT
CIRCUMSTANCE DOES THIS TENANT
RELOCATION BENEFITS KICK IN AND
THE ONLY THING THE BILL DOES. IS
GIVE THE JUDGE DISCRETION TO SET
OF VALUE THAT ACTUALLY WORKS
FINALLY. THIS MAKES CLEAR THAT
IF A SLUM LORD APPEALS THE ORDER
WHICH IS THEIR RIGHT THIS IS NOT
CHANGE THAT DUE PROCESS RIGHT.
THAT THE MUST OBTAIN IN ORDER
FROM THE COURT OF APPEAL TO STOP
THE PROPERTY FOR BEING FIXED UP
IN OTHER WORDS IF THEY USE A TWO
OR THREE YEAR- PROCESS TO DRAG
OUT A PEEL. IT CANNOT RESULT IN
PEOPLE BEING FORCED FROM THAT
PROPERTY WHILE THAT CONTINUES SO
DOES NOT DIMINISH DUE PROCESS
RIGHTS WHICH IS SACROSANCT. BUT
IT DOES ENSURE THAT THE PROPERTY
CAN BE FIXED UP WHILE SOMEONE
DOES EXERCISE HIS DUE PROCESS
RIGHTS. FINALLY A NOTE CODE
ENFORCEMENT IS ONLY ABOUT
COMPLIANCE THAT'S ALL WE'RE
SEEKING THIS IS NOT A PROFESSION
THAT ENGAGES IN PUNITIVE
MEASURES WE'RE NOT GOING TO
PUNISH ANYBODY ALL WE DO IS SEEK
COMPLIANCE WITH EXISTING LAWS
PASSED BY THIS LEGISLATURE AND
BAR LOCAL OFFICIALS WHO ARE ALSO
ELECTED SO I WOULD LIKE TO BE
CLEAR THAT WE'RE NOT LOOKING TO
TARGET PROPERTY OWNERS WERE
SIMPLY LOOKING TO HOLD SLUMLORDS
RESPONSIBLE IN ALL FINISHED WITH
THIS. BEFORE WE EVEN GET TO THIS
PROCESS IS LANDLORDS HAD BY MY
COUNT AT LEAST SIX DIFFERENT
NOTICES AND OPPORTUNITIES TO
COMPLY EACH ONE OF THOSE WITH AN
APPEAL WITHOUT I THINK YOU I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL GO
NOW TO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT IN THE ROOM FOUR AB
EIGHTEEN FIFTY EIGHT ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT NAME AN
ORGANIZATION. SHARE MEMBERS
BREGER NON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING OFFICIALS IN
STRONG SUPPORT. ANYONE ELSE IN
THE ROOM. OPERATOR WILL TAKE IT
TO THE PHONE LINES OF WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY
EIGHT. IF YOU VALUE AS A WITNESS
IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTEEN FIFTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN UNION
YOU CAN BEGIN.
I WOULD HAVE ONE WITNESS STYLE
THEM BUT APPARENTLY THERE FOR
DIFFERENT BILL. YOU HAVE NOT
RESPONDED. OKAY NOW WE'LL TAKE
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ROOM
FOR WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION A
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN AB EIGHTEEN
FIFTY EIGHT. BUT ONLY BE WITH A
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
FIRST OFF LIKE TO APOLOGIZE FOR
THE LATE- LETTER THAT WAS MADE
BUT WE HAVE BEEN IN CONTACT WITH
THE OTHERS OFFICE- WHAT WE
UNDERSTAND THE INTENT. OF THE
BILL- FOR US WE AGREE THAT ANY
BUILDING USED FOR HUMAN LIVING
MUST MEET THE STANDARDS OF THE
HOUSING. UP ENFORCEMENT ON THE
PANDEMIC SOME PORTIONS OF MIXED
USE BUILDINGS WERE SHUT DOWN AS
RETAIL OF COURSE WASN'T ABLE TO
SURVIVE- WHILE OWNERS OF THESE
GO TO SECURE THE SPACE IT WAS
NOT UNCOMMON FOR INDIVIDUALS
SEEKING COOLEY BREAK IN. AT
SPACES WHAT THE OWNERS
PERMISSION OR ASKING FOR IS A
DEFINITION IN THE BILL THAT
SAYS- THAT WOULD INCLUDE
REFERENCE TO THE OWNER'S
KNOWLEDGE- AND CONCERN- WITH ALL
THAT SAID WE HAVE BEEN IN
COMMUNICATION WITH THE AUTHOR'S
OFFICE WE THANK- HER FOR THOSE
MEETINGS. AND WE ACTUALLY HAVE
MEETING NEXT WEEK TOO SO WE LOOK
FOR TO WORKING THIS OUT THANK
YOU. THANKS VERY MUCH THE OTHER
PRIMARY WHAT IS IN OPPOSITION.
YOU WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION WHO
LIKE TO ADD THEIR NAME. OPERATOR
WILL TAKE IT TO THE PHONE LINES
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION FOR A.
B. EIGHTEEN FIFTY EIGHT.
REGARDING THE WITNESS OPPOSITION
OF EIGHTEEN FIFTY ACRE LOT OPEN
AND YOU CAN BEGIN.
AND YOUR MANAGER WITH A NO
RESPONSE FOR THE WITNESS OF THE
DIAL THEM THANK YOU WILL TAKE IT
BACK TO THE ROOM HERE MR CALLER. THANK YOU. THANK I JUST WANT
TO SHOW MY APPRECIATION TO THE
AUTHOR FOR THIS BILL- I'VE
WORKED I'VE REPRESENTED TENANTS
IN LANDLORD TENANT COURT
WASHINGTON DC AGAINST LANDLORDS
AND I'VE SEEN SOME OF THE
SITUATIONS THAT- ARE JUST RIFIC
TO MORE CURRENT- DAYS- BUT
CERTAINLY YOU SEE PURPORTEDLY
BECAUSE THE PANDEMIC BUT I THINK
YOU'RE SEEING A LOT OF AS I HAVE
FAMILIES LIVING TWO TO THREE IN
A GARAGE OR AND WHAT WAS
FORMALLY X. SOME COMMERCIAL
OFFICE SPACE WHATEVER THEY CAN
DO TO SRVIVE AND A
DISPROPORTIONATE BROWN
DOCUMENTED. SO THEY DON'T FEEL
EMPOWERED TO SPEAK UP AGAINST
ABOUT IT AND SO- I REALLY
APPRECIATE- YOU BRING THIS BILL
FOR WOULD LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A
CO AUTHOR AND THANK YOU. FOR
YOUR WORK. THANK YOU MR CALLER
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. WELL I TO
WANNA- APPLAUD THE AUTHOR FOR
THIS BILL- I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT CRITICAL AND
APPRECIATE YOU WORKING WITH THE
OPPOSITION AS WELL AND I KNOW
YOU'RE ALWAYS THOUGHTFUL WITH
WORKING WITH OPPOSITION THANK
YOU FOR THAT- AND I OBVIOUSLY
WANT TO SEE THIS BILL OUT OF OUR
COMMITTEE- WITHOUT A LET YOU
CLOSE AND I WILL NEED A MOTION
THE SECOND AS WELL. SO MOVING TO
HAVE A SECOND SECOND. I YES JUST
THAT AS YOU COULD HEAR FROM THE
A POWERFUL TESTIMONY IS THIS
COULD SEEM IN CONFLICT FROM
TRYING TO HOUSE PEOPLE BUT
HOUSING AT WHAT COST I THINK
THAT'S WHAT'S IMPORTANT LAST
YEAR I DID A SHELTER BILL- FOR
OUR SAFETY STANDARDS IN THIS
FOLLOWS THAT WHICH IS YES WE
WANT TO HOUSE PEOPLE BUT NOT- IN
DANGEROUS SITUATIONS THAT CAN
LITERALLY CAUGHT. LIVE AND WITH
THAT I REACHED OUT FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU AND THE- MOTIONS
TO PASS THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. WICKS I WEEKS I
SAY ARGUE CARILLO. AYE GABRIEL I
COULD FEEL I KALRA. KALRA AYE
KILEY QUIRK-SILVA. HI
QUIRK-SILVA HAI WARD. WARD I.
YEP THAT BILLS OUT THANK YOU AND
THE- YOUR NEXT BILL. ARE YOU YOU
UNDERSTAND NOW. OKAY AB. TWENTY
TWO THIRTY THREE. THANK YOU WITH
A QUICK DISCLOSURES WITH THIS
ONE.
ONE THOUSAND.
ALL RIGHT AGAIN- GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M HERE
TO PRESENT AB TWENTY TWO THIRTY
THREE- A. L. OUR STATE SURPLUS
PROPERTIES BILL AB TWENTY TWO
THIRTY THREE SIX THE SEEKS TO
CODIFY AN EXECUTIVE ORDER. AND
IMPLEMENT THE STATE AUDITOR'S
RECOMMENDATIONS ON STATE SURPLUS
PROPERTIES IN ORDER TO ADD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WHICH ARE
STATE IS DESPERATELY LACKING.
AND TWENTY NINETEEN GOVERNOR
NEWSOM ISSUED AN EXECUTIVE ORDER
N. ZERO SIX NINETEEN AND WHICH
HE ORDERED THE DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT AND THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING FINANCE
AGENCY TO IDENTIFY AND PRIOR
PRIORITIZE STATE SURPLUS
PROPERTIES FOR COST EFFECTIVE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS. MANY OF US
WERE HERE WHEN THAT EXECUTIVE
ORDER CAME FORWARD AND WERE VERY
I THINK EXCITED THAT THEIR WORST
POSSIBLE HOUSING AHEAD. BUT LO
AND BEHOLD- WE FOUND THAT WELL
THE DEPARTMENTS WERE ABLE TO
IDENTIFY OVER FORTY FOUR.
THOUSAND PARCELS I BELIEVE THAT
WAS FOUR THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED
NOT FORTY FOUR THOUSAND SO I
WANT TO MAKE CLEAR ONLY A FEW OF
THE PARCELS WERE DEEMED SUITABLE
FOR HOUSING AND IT WAS UNCLEAR
WHAT THE PLANS WERE FOR MANY OF
THEM HIGHLIGHTING THE NEED FOR
AN AUDIT. THE STATE'S NEED FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS
SIGNIFICANTLY OUTPACING ITS
PRODUCTION WHICH IS NEXT
NEGATIVELY AFFECTING
CALIFORNIANS ACCORDING TO TWENTY
TWENTY ONE REPORT BY THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP
ONE POINT FOUR MILLION LOW
INCOME. HOUSEHOLDS LACK TEST
AFFORDABLE. DESPITE THE NEED FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THE STATE HAS
FALLEN A HUNDRED THOUSAND UNITS
SHORT ANNUALLY ON ITS GOAL FOR
CREATING AFFORDABLE HOUSING. THE
RAPID CREATION OF FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IS CRITICAL AND THE
REAPERS PURPOSING OF STATE
PROPERTIES IS JUST ONE OF THE
MANY STEPS NECESSARY TO REACH
THIS GOAL. AND AGAIN I WANT TO
JUST ADD PERSONALLY I ASKED FOR
THE SURPLUS OUT OF OUR AUDIT
KNOWING THAT WE HAVE PARCELS OF
LAND. THAT WE HAVE ACTUALLY
MOVED FORWARD WITH SELLING OFF.
TO OTHER INDIVIDUALS. DEV WE
SHOULD BE. REAL FOLK. ON THESE.
OF AS PART OUR PA TO COME THIS.
WITH ME TODAY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IS MARK
STIVERS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP CORPORATION
AND- TONY BE WAY WITH THAT PART
IN ASSOCIATION WE HAVE A
DIFFERENT NAME SO THAT'S OKAY.
AND HE WAS JUST UP THERE.
WORKING WITH US ON THE FIRST
BILL AND NOW HE'S GOING TO WORK
WITH US ON THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HERE WE GO. GOOD MORNING MARC
STIVERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP AT THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER
MAKING ACCESS STATE SITES
AVAILABLE FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
HAS BEEN A RESOUNDING SUCCESS.
AT TO DATE THE STATE IS OFFERED
NINETEEN PROPERTIES. ALREADY
IDENTIFIED SITES OF THE
PROGRAM'S POTENTIAL TO CREATE
THIRTY TWO THOUSAND ADDITIONAL
HOMES TO ADDRESS CALIFORNIA'S
UNPRECEDENTED HOUSING
CHALLENGES. THE MAKING THE
PROGRAM PERMANENT AND BY
CODIFYING THE STATUTE AND
INSTITUTIONALIZING THE STATE'S
PROCEDURES ONLY MAGNIFY THE
PROGRAM'S IMPACT. AB TWENTY TWO
THIRTY THREE INSURERS AT THIS
IMPORTANT PROGRAM WILL EXTEND
BEYOND OUR CURRENT GOVERNOR. AND
FURTHER PAN PERIODIC REVIEWS
WILL INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
SITES AND HOMES THAT CAN BE
BUILT. MEETING CALIFORNIA'S
AFFORDABLE HOUSING NEEDS DEMANDS
A LONG TERM COMMITMENT
CONTINUALLY REASSESSING IN
OFFERING EXISTE PROPERTIES FOR
THIS PURPOSE IS AN INTEGRAL PART
OF THAT EFFORT WE ARE. STONE BUT
WITH THE A CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
. OF COURSE HERE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL- AB TWENTY TWO THIRDS
OF PROVIDES A COMMONSENSE
APPROACH- WE BELIEVE. IN
ADDRESSING OUR HOUSING CRISIS IN
THE STATE AS THE AUTHOR
MENTIONED- THIS IS ALSO A
PAINSTAKING PROCESS FOR HER
GOING THROUGH THE AUDIT AND NOW
THE BILL- AFTER THAT- WE DO
BELIEVE IT'S A CLEVER WAY- AND
ANOTHER TOOLIN THE TOOLBOX. TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE IN OUR STATE
AND WE RESPECT LAST RIVAL. THANK
YOU AND I'LL GO TO ANY OTHER TO
SHOW WITNESSES IN THE ROOM WOULD
LIKE TO REGISTER SUPPORT.
OPERATOR IF YOU COULD PLEASE GO
TO THE PHONE LINES- SUPPORT FOR
AB TWENTY TWO. THIRTY THREE. THE
PEOPLE OF THE WITNESS IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY THIRTY FOR YOUR
LINES OPEN AND YOU CAN BEGIN. WE
ARE NOT RESPONSIBLE TO THE
PUBLIC. GENERAL PUBLIC IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO VOTE IN SUPPORT.
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. HI PROBABLY SAY. THE
MANAGER WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q.
GREAT THANK YOU NOW WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE ROOM- WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY TWO
THIRTY THREE ANY PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. ANYONE
ELSE IN THE ROOM IN OPPOSITION
TO AB TWENTY TWO THIRTY THREE.
WE'LL GO TO THE PHONE LINES
OPERATOR ANY- FOLKS WOULD LIKE
TO REGISTER OPPOSITION FOR AB
TWENTY TWO THIRTY THREE.
NEGATIVE ELEVEN AS A WITNESS TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY OPPOSITION THE
TWENTY THIRD FOR YOUR LINE IS
ALREADY OPEN TO BEGIN. MOST LOSE
SOME OF IF YOU LOVE TO REGISTER
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. SEVEN BILLION
MANAGER LOCATED NOBODY IN Q.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL
BRING IT BACK HERE TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES FROM HIS QUIRK-SILVA
. AB TWENTY TWO THIRTY THREE. WE
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND BY
MISS KOREA- I'LL JUST CLOSE BY
SAYING APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
WORK IN THE SPACE I THINK IT'S
ANOTHER- INNOVATIVE APPROACH
THAT YOU'RE BRINGING TO THE
TABLE HURT MISS QUIRK-SILVA-
WITH THAT I WOULD LOVE TO SEE
THIS BILL THAT A COMMITTEE AND
WE HAVE A MOTION A SECOND WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. YES I'M JUST
A ARE YOU PASSIONATE ABOUT
ISSUES IN EVERY OPPORTUNITY WE
CAN TO HELP PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA
AND WHEN WE SAY SURPLUS THAT
MEANS EXTRA IN WE SAY EXTRA THIS
MEANS AN OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD
WHERE WE HAVEN'T BUILT BEFORE SO
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU. I'M SORRY
OUR MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN ACCOUNTABILITY
AND ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW WICKS
HI I SEYARTO. CORREO KOREA I
GABRIEL HI APRIL I KALRA. KILEY
QUIRK-SILVA HI QUIRK-SILVA NIGHT
WAR DIE. THANK YOU. YEAH ARE WE
YEAH OKAY THAT BILLS OUT AND-
LET'S SEE WILL DO MISTER WARD
NOW. AB. EIGHTEEN FIFTY. WHEN
YOU'RE READY. WHEN I GOT. FOR
THE FIRST. OKAY GREAT- THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS LET ME START THINKING THE CHAIR SUGGESTED
IS AN AMENDMENTS AND NOT THAT IS
TO SAY THE ANGLE FOR HER WORK ON
THE BILL AS WELL- WHILE PUBLIC
ACQUISITION OF HOUSING CAN BE A
BENEFICIAL TOOL TO INCREASE THE
SUPPLY OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING THE
CURRENT USE OF THIS MODEL BY
JOINT POWERS AUTHORITIES AND FOR
PROFIT PARTNERS FAILS TO GEARING
TEEN PUBLIC BENEFIT COMMENSURATE
WITH THE PUBLIC SUBSIDY. THE
DOZENS OF TRANSACTIONS THAT
OCCURRED TO DATE ARE NOT SUBJECT
TO FIRM AFFORDABILITY
REQUIREMENTS OPERANDS THAT
REMAIN ABOVE THE MARKET AVERAGE
PAY OUT EXORBITANT FEES THAT ARE
NOT ADEQUATELY MONITORED BY A
PUBLIC ENTITY AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY
WOULD SET MINIMUM STANDARDS OF
OWNERSHIP FOR WHEN PUBLIC
ENTITIES ACQUIRE MIDDLE INCOME
HELPING TO ENSURE THAT FUTURE
TRANSACTIONS ARE EQUITABLE FOR
TENANTS THE LOCAL JURISDICTION
IN OTHER LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WHO
LOSE PROPERTY TAX REVENUES THIS
WILL CONTINUE TO ALLOW GPAS AND
FOR PRIVATE FOR PROFIT INTEREST.
TO ENTER INTO MUTUALLY
BENEFICIAL AGREEMENTS THAT WILL
SECURE AFFORDABLE AND MIDDLE
INCOME HOUSING FOR THEIR
RESPECTIVE CAN THIS NOT LIKE TO
PRESENT MY WIN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL MARK STIVERS REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
PARTNERSHIP AND EVEN DÍAS-
REPRESENTING THE NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. THE MORNING OF MARCH
DIVERS AGAIN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP WE ALL SHARE
AN INTEREST IN MEETING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING NEEDS AT ALL
INCOME LEVELS OF THIS BILL IS
NOT ABOUT MIDDLE. LOW INCOME
ABOUT ENSURING SORT OF ADEQUATE
PUBLIC BENEFIT WHEN PUBLIC
RESOURCES ARE USED. OPPONENTS OF
THE BILL SO THAT THEY ARE
PROVIDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING TO
MIDDLE INCOME HOUSEHOLDS WITH NO
PUBLIC SUBSIDY. UNFORTUNATELY
NEITHER OF THOSE IS TRUE. FIRST
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE SUBSIDY. BY
DINT OF THE JOINT POWERS AGENCY
OWNERSHIP THESE DEVELOPMENTS
RECEIVE PROPERTY TAX BREAKS IN
THE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS PER
YEAR. IN ADDITION THE BUYERS OF
THE BONDS FINANCING THESE
PURCHASES ARE NOT PAYING TAXES
ON INTEREST. EARNINGS
AFFORDABILITY OF THE LARGE
MAJORITY OF CASES OF RENTS-
THESE DEVELOPMENTS CHARGE REMAIN%
WELL ABOVE HOW DETERMINED FAIR
MARKET RENTS FOR THE PUBLIC
BILLS IF CODE. KNOWN AS SMALL
AREA FAIR MARKET RENTS. WHICH
CONSIDERS ALL RENTAL UNITS OF
THE TWENTY ONE GPA DEVELOPMENTS
FOR WHICH WE HAVE RENT DATA THE
80% OF AREA MEDIAN INCOME RENTS
WERE BELOW THE HUD BENCHMARK IN
ONLY EIGHT DEVELOPMENTS. THE
1100% A MY RENTS WERE BELOW THE
HEAD BENCHMARKING ONLY FIVE
CASES AND ONLY THREE CASES WITH
A HUNDRED AND 20% AM I RENTS
BELOW THE BENCHMARK. THE RENT
CALCULATION SHOULD I HANDED OUT
TO ILLUSTRATE THIS OF
UNAFFORDABILITY FOR PARTICULAR
DEVELOPMENT IN SANTA ROSA. THE
RENT SAVINGS OPPONENTS CLAIM ARE
IN COMPARISON ONLY TO CLASS A
LUXURY APARTMENTS A VERY SMALL
SUBSET OF THE OVERALL MARKET.
THESE UNITS ARE NOT PARTICULAR
AFFORDABLE IN THE GENERAL
MARKET. WHEREAS WORKING FAMILIES
NEED A SOLID CAMERA TO GET TO
WORK- THESE DEVELOPMENTS ARE
OFFERING DISCOUNTS ON A FERRARI
. FOR PROFIT ADMINISTRATOR THE
FOR PROFIT PROJECT
ADMINISTRATORS ARE RECEIVING
EXCESSIVE COMPENSATION
ESPECIALLY WHEN ONE CONSIDERS
THAT THEY ARE MERELY BUYING AND
MANAGING EXISTING DEVELOPMENT.
DEVELOPING SORELY NEEDED NEW
HOUSING. THEY'RE RECEIVING UP
FRONT FEES OF AS MUCH AS TWO
MILLION DOLLARS OR MORE. THEY
ARE ALSO GETTING AN ANNUAL
ADMINISTRATIVE FEE IN THE SEVEN
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLAR RANGE.
AND BY WAY OF COMPARISON EIGHTY
LIMITS ASSET MANAGER FEES AND
TRUE AFFORDABLE HOUSING TO
THIRTY SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER YEAR. LASTLY THERE HAD BEEN
THEIR BENEFICIARIES OF A WHAT'S
CALLED A B. BOND. A DEBT TO THE
PROPERTY OFTEN A FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS ACCRUING INTEREST AT 10%
PER YEAR. THE SECOND DOCUMENT I
HANDED OUT SHOWS THESE TO.
SAMPLES OF THESE FEES. IN OUR
VIEW OF THE PUBLIC IS GOING TO.
PROVIDE A SUBSIDY THE PUBLIC
SHOULD RECEIVE A COMMENSURATE
PUBLIC BENEFIT. AB EIGHTEEN
FIFTY ENSURES AN APPROPRIATE
BALANCE AND ALSO ENSURES THE
LONG TERM FEASIBILITY. ELEMENTS
TECH BEGINS FEW. PLAINTIFFS L.
SUPPORTS. OF MIDDLE. HOUSING
WITH APPROPRIATE GUARDRAILS TO
ENSURE THE TENANTS NOT JUST THE
PROGRAM ADMINISTRATORS RECEIVE
ADEQUATE BENEFIT. THAT WE ARE
WORKING WITH STAKEHOLDERS
INCLUDING ONE OF THE POINTS
WHICH WAS LIKELY TO TESTIFY
TODAY. AND AMENABLE TO FURTHER
OPENING UP THESE CONVERSATIONS
TO ANY WHO ARE COMMITTED TO
CONSTRUCTIVE SOLUTIONS. THERE'S
GENERAL AGREEMENT THE GUARDRAILS
ARE NEEDED FOR THE CURRENT FREE
FOR ALL AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY WILL
HELP US GET TO THAT. BALANCE
SOLUTION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I AM PLEASED
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN FIFTY ON
BEHALF OF THE NONPROFIT HOUSING
ASSOCIATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. AB EIGHTEEN FIFTEEN
CREWS RESPONSIBLE GUARDRAILS
THAT ARE STANDARD IN THE
AFFORDABLE HOUING WORLD AND
APPROPRIATE AT ALL INCOME
LEVELS. THE BILL REQUIRES THAT
REGULATORY AGREEMENTS ENSURE
AFFORDABILITY FOR FIFTY FIVE
YEARS. OKAY AGREEMENT SIMPLY ARE
THE PROJECT ADMINISTRATORS TO
MAKE BEST EFFORTS TO ACHIEVE THE
DESIRED AFFORDABILITY AND ALLOW
THE PROJECT TO CONVERT TO MARKET
RATE AT ANY TIME THE PUBLIC
ENTITY WISHES TO SELL. THIS IS
NOT AN ADEQUATE GUARANTEED
PUBLIC BENEFIT AND PUTS TENANTS
OUR FUTURE RISK OF DISPLACEMENT.
AS AMENDED THE BILL REQUIRES A
CITY OR COUNTY ITSELF OR ITS
CONTRACTORS TO MONITOR THE
DEVELOPMENT FOR ON GOING
COMPLIANCE USING T. TAX
STANDARDS. IS A CONFLICT OF
INTEREST FOR THE JPA TO MONITOR
DEVELOPMENT IT OWNS AND DILIGENT
MONITORING AS NECESSARY TO
ENSURE THE PUBLIC BENEFIT FORCE
TO TAX ABATEMENT IS GIVEN IS
ACTUALLY ACHIEVED. LASTLY THE
BILL ENSURES LONG TERM
FEASIBILITY BY REQUIRING THE USE
OF RESPONSIBLE UNDERWRITING
STANDARDS THESE DEVELOPMENTS ARE
CURRENTLY FUNDED WITH VERY RISKY
FINANCING INCLUDING LOWER LOAN
AMOUNTS HIGHLY EXCEEDING THE
VALUE OF THE PROPERTY AND
INTEREST ONLY LOANS. OF GREATEST
CONCERN IS THE FACT THAT
DEVELOPMENTS ARE CREATING HUGE
RESERVES JUST TO ME THEIR
INTEREST OBLIGATIONS OVER THE
FIRST FEW YEARS. COUNTY ON.
THANK ROTH TO HIS OBLIGATIONS
AND FUTURE AND HOPE IN THE
RESERVES LAST LONG ENOUGH.
BECAUSE A FOR CLOSURE VOIGTS ALL
AFFORDABILITY REQUIREMENTS IT IS
CRITICAL THAT WE SET THESE
DEVELOPMENTS OUT FOR LONG TERM
SUCCESS. AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY PUTS
IN PLACE REASONABLE AND
APPROPRIATE GUARDRAILS TO ENSURE
THEIR TAX DOLLARS ARE USED
WISELY. THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERATION IN YOUR TO AYE
VOTE ON THIS BILL TODAY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH YOU OTHER-
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN THE ROOM
WHO'D LIKE TO REGISTER THEIR
SUPPORT PLEASE COME UP TO THE
MIKE NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION PLEASE. IN SHOW REPORT
WITH CORPORATE FOR SUPPORT OF
HOW AND- NUMBER LET WITH HELLO
OF. GREAT NOT WILL GO TO THE
LINES AM PLEASED FOLKS IN
SUPPORT OF AB SORRY. A EIGHTEEN
FOR- AND I THINK YOU NEED TO THE
LINE IS OPEN RIGHT I THINK
ROAMING SOME PROBLEMS WITH THE
PHONE SO YOU COULD PLEASE KEY UP
AND TELL THEM LINE OPEN FIRST.
OF A EIGHTY FIFTY. THANK MADAM
CHAIR YOU FOLLOW WITNESS OF THE
LIGHT CUSTOMER FOR. FIFTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN THE TO BEGIN WITH.
BOB WOULD OF WITH MEMBERS OF THE
- IF YOU LISTENING. ONLY PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME TO
REGISTER SUPPORT FOR EIGHTEEN
FIFTY. AND WE WILL GO TO LINE
NUMBER FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN GO AHEAD PLEASE. ONE FORTY
NINE YOUR LINES OPEN GO AHEAD
PLEASE. ONE FORTY NINE WE CAN
HEAR YOU GLOBAL TO COMMENT. BACK
IN THE ORDER RAINY. AND I WOULD
RESIDENT UNITED NETWORK. AND I'M
IN FAVOR OF SUPPORT OF AB.
EIGHTEEN FIFTY. THANK YOU ARE
ONCE AGAIN FOR SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHTEEN FIFTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I'M SURE
THERE ARE NO ADDITIONAL CALLS IN
QUEUE FOR SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WILL TAKE ABOUT CARE TO THE
ROOM- PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY.
PLEASE COME UP.
MOTIONS THIS IS THIS MORNING OR
THIS IS THE AMERICA ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU- MY NAME IS JORDAN
LOS. I DON'T. THANK YOU AMERICA-
THE ADDAMS MAYBE BRING A LITTLE
CLOSER. I THINK IT'S ON OKAY AS
A GOOD OKAY- GOOD MORNING. MY
NAME IS JORDAN LAWSON THE
FOUNDER OF CATALYST HOUSING
GROUP. THANK YOU TO THIS
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY AND FOR
YOUR STEADFAST COMMITMENT TO
TACKLING OUR STATE'S HOUSING
CRISIS. CATALYST IS EQUALLY
COMMITTED TO DEVELOPING TANGIBLE
HOUSING SOLUTIONS OUR PRIMARY
FOCUS AREA HAS BEEN CALIFORNIA'S
ESSENTIAL MIDDLE INCOME
WORKFORCE. WHOSE PAYCHECKS ARE
INCREASINGLY CONSUMED BY RUNAWAY
HOUSING COSTS. OVER THE PAST
THREE YEARS OUR FIRM'S
INNOVATIONS HAVE EMPOWERED THE
PRESERVATION. OF NEARLY FOURTEEN
THOUSAND GOVERNMENTALLY OWNED
RENT RESTRICTED HOUSING UNITS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. EACH
TRANSACTION WAS APPROVED TO
ENSURE THE DELIVERY OF IMPACTFUL
PUBLIC BENEFITS. IN ADDITION TO
IMMEDIATE RENT REDUCTIONS AND
CAPS ON ANNUAL INCREASES ALL
LONG TERM CONTROLS AN ECONOMICS
HAVE BEEN GRANTED TO CALIFORNIA
CITIES AND COUNTIES. ALL OF
WHICH IS DOCUMENTED AND RECORDED
MONITORED LEGAL AGREEMENTS. THIS
IMPACTFUL MODEL HAS BECOME
WIDELY RECOGNIZED AS ESSENTIAL
HOUSING. CATALYST CURRENTLY
OVERSEES NEARLY FORTY TWO
HUNDRED GOVERNMENTALLY OWNED
ESSENTIAL HOUSING UNITS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THIS
PORTFOLIO ALREADY PROVIDE 16%
DISCOUNTS THE MARKET RATE
COMPETITORS AMOUNTED TO TWENTY
TWO MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR OF
RENTAL SUBSIDIES. THOUSANDS OF
OUR STATE'S ESSENTIAL WORKERS
ARE FOR THE FIRST TIME FINDING
PATHWAYS TO LIVE WORK AND THRIVE
DIRECTLY WITHIN THE COMMUNITIES
THEY SERVE. I APPEAR BEFORE YOU
TODAY IN OPPOSITION OF AB
EIGHTEEN FIFTY. WHILE WE APPLAUD
THE AUTHOR AND SPONSORS FOR
THEIR COMMITMENT TO ADDRESSING
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING WOES THIS
BILL FAILS TO CAPTURE THE NUANCE
OF WHAT IT SEEKS TO LEGISLATE.
IT INTRODUCES ARBITRARY
REQUIREMENTS THAT WILL SLAM THE
DOOR ON A PROVEN PRESERVATION
TOOL A TIME WHEN SUCH CRITICAL
SCALABLE SOLUTIONS ARE NEEDED
MOST. WE ARE INCREDIBLY PROUD OF
THE UNDENIABLE IMPACT ESSENTIAL
HOUSING COMMUNITIES HAVE
DELIVERED TO DATE. BUT ABOVE ALL
WE PRIDE OURSELVES ON BEING
MISSION DRIVEN HOUSING
ADVOCATES. IF THIS COMMITTEE
BELIEVES CHANGES TO THE BASELINE
ESSENTIAL HOUSING MODELER CHOIR
WE WILL HAPPILY RAISE OUR HAND
TO ASSIST IN CRAFTING MORE
THOUGHTFUL LEGISLATION. THAT
SAID WE BELIEVE THAT SUCH
PROPOSED GUARDRAIL SHOULD BE
GROUNDED IN FACTS REALITY IN ALL
OF THE REQUIRED NEW WANTS TO
UNDERSTAND EXACTLY WHAT I
CENTRAL HOUSING IS AND AS
IMPORTANT. IT IS NOT. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME I'LL BE HAPPY TO
ADDRESS ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
ARE THERE OTHER WITNESSES IN THE
ROOM IN OPPOSITION. THEY WOULD
LIKE TO ADD ON. OKAY WE'LL GO
WE'LL GO TO THE PHONE LINES-
OPERATOR AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. IT
COULD DOUBLE AS A WITNESS TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY OPPOSITION OF
EIGHTEEN FIFTY YOUR LINE IS
ALREADY OPEN YOU KNOW AND YOU
CAN BEGIN. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M JOHN STOKER
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL FINANCE AUTHORITY MORE
COMMONLY KNOWN AS THE SALMON
FILET. THE SAME AFFAIRS A JOINT
EXERCISE OF POWERS AUTHORITY
MADE UP OF OVER THREE HUNDRED
PLUS CITIES COUNTIES AND SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ACROSS THE STATE. THE
SAME APPLIES BEEN WORKING ON
ALLEVIATING THE HOUSING CRISIS
FOR YEARS. CURRENTLY ACTIVELY
WORKING TO FINANCE OVER A
HUNDRED BEFORE THE HOUSING
PROJECT. YOUR RECENT COMMITMENT
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE SAME
APPLIES SUBMITTED MORE
APPLICATIONS SAID LACK. IN ALL
OF THE OTHER ISSUES IN THE
STATE'S COMBINED. HOWEVER WE'RE
STILL LIMITED BY APPLAUDED
CAPPED SAUTEED MORE PROJECT. GOV
OUR INCOME RESIDENTS AFFORD
MARKET RATE WITH OPTION THE
LOWER INCOME RESIDENTS OF
SUBSIDIZED AFFORDABLE RENTAL
HOUSING FOR FOLKS IN THE MIDDLE
ARE LEFT OUT IN COLD. THOSE
HOUSEHOLDS ARE OFTEN REFERRED TO
THE MISSING MIDDLE. THE MISSING
MIDDLE INCLUDES WORKERS ARE
CRITICAL TO THE STATE'S ECONOMY
AND CRITICAL TO THE COMMUNITIES
WE WORK. MISSING MIDDLE WORKERS
PROVIDER EDUCATION OR HEALTH
CARE PUBLIC SAFETY AND SERVICES
. THIS FOR MIDDLE HOUSING
PROGRAMS CAN PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED
AFFORDABLE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
FOR THESE RESIDENTS AT A MUCH
LOWER COST TO TAXPAYERS COMPARED
TO PROGRAMS USING TAX CREDITS.
WHICH PROVIDES HUGE SUBSIDIES OF
3270% OF THE PROJECT COST THE
ONLY SUBSIDIES THAT W HAVE USED
ONE COME PROGRAM OUR PROPERTY
TAX EXEMPTION. AND WE DO THIS
PURPOSELY SO AS NOT TO COMPETE
AGAINST OTHER AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROGRAMS. THE PROPOSED
LEGISLATION COMPLEX TAX CREDITS
WITH OTHER FINANCING
UNNECESSARILY STIFLE FOR KILL
THE ABILITY TO PROVIDE MUCH
NEEDED. ESSENTIAL HOUSING THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES. CAROL
SWEEPER GRANTORS THEY'RE
DESPERATELY WAITING TO LIVE
WHERE THEY WORK AT A MORE
REASONABLE COST AND IMPROVE
THEIR QUALITY OF LIFE. BY
AVOIDING LONG COMMUTES THE
DAMAGE ON BARBARA. BECAUSE OF
THESE AND OTHER REASONS SANTA FE
MUST. REGRETFULLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL. RIGHT OR ANY OTHER
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY
WANT TO REGISTER THEIR
OPPOSITION WITH NAME
ORGANIZATION A POSITION. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC REGISTRY OPPOSITION FOR
EIGHTEEN FIFTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AT THIS TIME. AND
WE'RE GOING TO GO FIRST TO LINE
NUMBER THIRTY ONE THIRTY ARE
OPEN GO AHEAD PLEASE. THIRTY WE
CAN HEAR YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD
WITH YOUR COMMENT. FINE THIRTY
NOT RESPONDING LINE FORTY ONE
ONE FORTY ONE NORTH WILL HAVE
PLEASE. NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION. FOR EIGHTEEN FIFTY ONE
FORTY ONE. FORTY ONE SELECT A
STEP AWAY FROM THE PHONE FOR A
MOMENT OKAY LINE SIXTY FIVE ONE
SIXTY FIVE YEAR OLD LOW HAVE.
I'M SIXTY FIVE PUT PLEASE WITH
THE GOVERNMENT. AND I'M SURE
LINE FORTY EIGHT LINE FORTY
EIGHT GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN
. BY KEVIN SCHMIDT ON THE APPLE
WATCH PROPERTY.
THE MANAGER OF ACCUSE QUICKER.
THANK YOU POLICIES FOR THE
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES THERE- WE
WILL BRING IT BACK TO. THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE BILL. MR
GABRIEL. YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM CHAIR IN MY- MY
COMPLIMENTS TO THE AUTHOR WHO I
KNOW TO BE A REAL LEADER ON
THESE ISSUES AND I THINK YOU OF-
BROUGHT TO OUR ATTENTION A VERY
IMPORTANT ONE- SOMEONE A
COMPLIMENT YOU FOR THAT- THE I
ALSO YOUR I'VE DISCUSSED THIS A
LITTLE BIT AND I'VE HAD SOME HAD
THE PLEASURE OF HAVING SOME
CONVERSATIONS OFFLINE WITH MR
STIVERS AS WELL I THINK IS ONE
OF THE SHARPEST MINDS AROUND THE
CAPITAL ON HOUSING ISSUES. I DID
JUST WANT TO- SHARE YOUR
THOUGHTS AND THEN ASK A FEW
QUESTIONS- YOU KNOW I AM A BIG
BELIEVER THAT WE NEED TO BE
DOING MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
I'M ALSO A BIG BELIEVER THAT WE
NEED TO BE DOING ONE WORK FORCE
HOUSING AND I KNOW THAT THAT'S
NOT AN OPINION THAT IS SHARED BY
EVERYBODY- INSIDE. BY YOU KNOW I
SEE THIS IN MY DISTRICT AND I.
THAT I YOU KNOW I WANT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR NURSES AND
FIREFIGHTERS AND TEACHERS AND
OTHER FOLKS ARE BEING PRICED OUT
OF SAN FERNANDO VALLEY. TO LIVE
IN MY COMMUNITY AND MANY OF
THOSE FOLKS DON'T QUALIFY FOR.
LOW INCOME. I DID RESTRICTED
AFFORDABLE. THEY ARE BEING
THEY'RE BEING PRICED OUT OF. BIG
PARTS OF MY DISTRICT AT A VERY
RAPID RATE SO I THINK THERE IS.
A REAL PUBLIC POLICY CASE TO
SUPPORT MISSING THAT'LL WORK FOR
HOUSING. IT'S A GOOD USE OF
TAXPAYER FUNDS TO DO THAT- AND
SO TO ME I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT IS WORK MOVING THIS
PROPOSAL FOR DOING SO- WITH A
LOT OF NEW WANTS BECAUSE WE HAVE
TWO OBJECTIVES HERE I THINK
IT'S- EXCEPTIONALLY IMPORTANT WE
ARE GOOD STEWARDS OF PUBLIC
RESOURCES. AND I UNDERSTAND THAT
TO BE THE THRUST OF YOUR BILL-
BUT AT THE SAME TIME I DON'T
WANT TO DO ANYTHING THAT'S GOING
TO. INADVERTENTLY MAKE IT MAKE
IT MORE DIFFICULT. OR
CHALLENGING OR- A BALL TO
DEVELOP MISSING THAT'LL WORK FOR
HOUSING SO I THINK THE TRICK
HERE IS TO. CRAFT THE GUARDRAILS
IN A WAY THAT THEY ARE. NOT
PROVIDING ADEQUATE PROTECTIONS
BUT NOT MAKING IT IMPOSSIBLE. TO
DEVELOP THIS HOUSING AND SO. ON
YOU KNOW I KNOW THAT YOU'RE
HAVING CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
OPPOSITION. YOU KNOW LOOKING AT
THE MATERIALS THAT PER. THAT
WERE PROVIDED THIS IS A-
COMPLICATED TECHNICAL SUBJECT
AND SO. THE CONVERSATIONS THAT
YOU'RE HOT. YOU HAVE THEM. BUT
BUT IT IS REALLY IMPORTANT TO
ME. YOU KNOW THE- HAD A BILL
LAST YEAR ON MISSING MIDDLE WORK
FORCE HOUSING THAT. THE GOVERNOR
SIGNED INTO LAW THAT PASSED THE
ASSEMBLY BY A VOTE OF SEVENTY
NINE TWO ZERO SO I THINK THERE
IS BROAD CONSENSUS HERE. IN THE
LEGISLATURE THAT WORK FORCE
HOUSING IS IMPORTANT SO I WANNA
MAKE SURE AS WERE MOVING THIS
AFTER FORWARD. WE'RE NOT
CREATING. ADDITIONAL BARRIERS TO
WORK FORCE HOUSING WHERE THEY
WHERE THEY SHOULD BE PLACE BUT I
KNOW THE AUTHOR TO BE. SUPER
SHARP I KNOW THE PROPONENT TO
BE. SUPER SHARP ON BOTH OF THE
WITNESSES HERE. SOME CONFIDENT
THAT IN YOUR CONVERSATIONS YOU
GUYS ARE GONNA. FIND A WAY-
THREAD THAT NEEDLE. I GUESS THE
OTHER QUESTION I HAD HERE WAS.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT WERE
RELATIVELY NEW. TERMS OF THE USE
OF THESE J. P. AS- IN DO WE FEEL
LIKE WE HAVE ENOUGH DATA YET. TO
BE ESTABLISHING. THESE
GUARDRAILS AND REALLY YOU KNOW
PUTTING SOMETHING INTO STATURE
DO WE FIGHT WE NEED TO BE
COLLECTING A LITTLE BIT MORE
DATA BEFORE WE- START TO SET THE
PARAMETERS OF THIS PROGRAM.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENT IN
YOUR QUESTION- YOU KNOW WHAT
THIS IS ABOUT. HELPING TO INSURE
THAT WE ARE DELIVERING ON THE
WORK FORCE HOUSING THAT THE
MIDDLE INCOME- BRANDS THAT WE
ARE- TELLING BOTH LOCAL
OFFICIALS AND THE- WOULD BE
TENANTS THAT WE ARE GOING TO
DELIVER ON- ACTUALLY I'M TRYING
TO AND IN THE DEVELOPMENT
PARTNERSHIP THAT IS GOING
FORWARD- THERE ARE GOOD EXAMPLES
I WANT THIS MODEL TO BE
SUCCESSFUL BUT IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE ARE ACTUALLY DELIVERING
ON WHAT WE SAY. WE'RE GOING TO
DO AND WHEN THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN
AND YES THE DATA. ALAS MARC TO-
COMMENTED THAT IN THE SECOND
QUESTION- IS SHOWING SOME
EXCEPTIONS TO THAT THAT'S WHY IT
WAS NECESSARY TO COME IN AND SAY
OKAY THERE'S PLENTY OF OTHER
CASES WERE YOU'RE USING PUBLIC
SUBSIDY. AND IN THIS CASE FOR
YOU ARE NOT ACQUIRING ANY- TAX
AND PROPERTY TAX. BECAUSE USING
PROPERTY TAX EXEMPT TEAM TAXES
THAT BONDS. DOT IS IMPORTANT
THEN FOR US TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
SURE THESE GUARANTEES ARE THERE
. ONLY DELIVER TO ALTERNATELY
PURDUE AND RENT OUT- THESE UNITS
THAT NEED TO BE THERE FOR THE
ONE HUNDRED THE ONE TWENTY IN MY
CATEGORY- I KNOW THAT YOU PASSED
OUT SOME DATA BUT MAYBE WANT TO
ELABORATE ON THAT AS WELL AGAIN
IT UNDERSCORES THE NEED FOR THIS
BILL. HIS PRIVILEGE THERE ARE AT
LEAST FORTY TWO OF THESE
DEVELOPMENTS THAT I THINK THAT
OCCURRED DURING. MR MAS MAY BE
ABLE TO CONFIRM THAT BUT- WE'VE
LOOKED AT DATA FOR TWENTY ONE OF
THEM I THINK WE HAVE GOT. IT ON
THE RENTS I THINK WE HAVE GOOD
DATA ON WHAT THE FEES ARE THAT
ARE BEING CHARGED. AND I THINK
THAT'S WHAT WE'VE SORT OF DONE
THE BAY AND WE HAD A NUMBER OF
CONVERSATIONS WITH STAKEHOLDERS
TO. SAY YOU KNOW THE PROPERTY
TAX ABATEMENTS GENTLY WORTH
ABOUT. 10% AND IT SAVES ABOUT
10% OF YOUR EXPENSES. AND THAT'S
WHERE WE GET TO THIS FOR A 10%
RATE SAVINGS IN THE BILL THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO. ACHIEVE AND SO
THAT'S- THAT'S- WE HAVE
SIGNIFICANT DATA THERE COULD
ALWAYS BE MORE BUT I THINK
THAT'S A GOOD. START TO. GET
INTO THIS FIELD BEFORE TO GET
AWAY FROM US AND GUESTS TO BE-
YOU KNOW. BUT A POTENTIAL.
PURCHASE IT'S SOMETHING. IN ALL
A HUGE AMOUNT. PROPERTY COULD BE
TAKEN OFF THE PROPERTY TAX ROLLS
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THEY WERE
DOING THAT RIGHT. FROM THE GET
GO. IT JUST M. E. AWAY AS YOU
LOOKED AT THOSE TWENTY ONE
PROPERTIES I MEAN WAS THERE ARE.
AND TRY TO THINK WHAT THE
DISTRIBUTION OF RENTING WHERE
THY PRETTY CLUSTERED AND- YOU
KNOW. SORT OF SIMILAR MODELS AND
ALL OF THEM OR WAS THERE. A
VARIETY OF WAYS THAT. APPROACH
THIS. I DO THINK THE VERY. A
BIT- MISS. MAS MAY. L. S. B. TO
THAT AS- BUT- THERE ARE USUALLY.
UNITS AT EIGHTY PER. OF A- AGAIN
THEY CAN. 84% IN AMERICA VERY
DIFFERENT. WE DO IN THE
TRADITIONAL AFFORDABLE HOUSING
WORLD. WE THINK OF AFFORDABILITY
AS- THIRTY PERCENT. OF THE
TARGET FAMILIES INCOME. THEY
OFTEN USING 35% OF FAMILIES
TARGET INCOME. BUT NONE THE LESS
THEY ARE HAVING UNITS AT. ONE
HUNDRED AND- TWENTY. THE ISSUE
THOUGH IS THAT. THE AS A MAN IN
A REMARKS THE HUNDRED AND 120%
IN MY RENTS ARE OFTEN WAY ABOVE.
JUST THE NORMAL MARKET. AND SO
IT'S NOT. ME IT'S ONLY SORT F.
AFFORDABLE IF YOU'RE COMPARING
IT TO CLASSE LUXURY. PROPERTIES
KNOCKED IT. IN THE MARKET- YEAH
I GUESS I YOU KNOW I HESITATE TO
USE THE WORD. I SO I. TEACH
WHERE ABOUT. PRETTY GOOD ACTORS
BUT OUR THEIR- EXAM.
DON'T KNOW IF THE OPPOSITION.
HAS ANYTHING TO ADD TO IT TO THE
QUESTIONS I HAD ASKED. FOR I'D
BE HAPPY TO THANK YOU. JUST GET
THAT. UNIT COUNTER THE
TRANSACTION COUNT. WE DID AN
AUDIT OF THE ENTIRE. ESSENTIAL
HOUSING SPACE- ALL OF THESE ARE
. ALL THESE BONDS ARE PUBLICLY
OFFERED ALL OF THE INFORMATION
IS FREE TO ANYONE WHO'S
INTERESTED ON THE INTERNET- OUR
ACCOUNT IS THAT THERE'S BEEN
FORTY SIX TRANSACTIONS THOSE
WOULD BE. BOND FINANCINGS SOME
OF THOSE WERE SMALL PORTFOLIO SO
THERE'S MORE THAN FIFTY ASSETS
TOTAL. THAT'S ABOUT FOURTEEN
THOUSAND UNITS ACROSS THE STATE-
THERE'S A WIDE RANGE OF PRODUCTS
OF NOT EVERYTHING IS. SUPER HIGH
END LUXURY BRAND NEW PRODUCT- WE
PERSONALLY A CATALYST OVERSEE
WHAT WE CALL VALUE ADDED. THE
INDUSTRY OR NATURALLY OCCURRING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING MUCH OLDER
ASSETS WERE A LOT OF MONEY. IT'S
CHUNK OF THE BOND PROCEEDS ARE
ACTUALLY BE SPENT BEING SPENT ON
UPGRADING SUBSTANTIALLY. THOSE
THOSE PROPERTIES- I DO THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF COMMON GROUND
HERE 10% IF YOU WERE TO PICK A
NUMBER AS TO. WHAT TYPE OF RENT
REDUCTION- SHOULD BE HAD FOR A
PRETTY TAX EXEMPTION TO PROVE
THE PUBLIC BENEFITS BEEN CREATED
10% SEEMS TO BE A FAIR NUMBER-
ALL I CAN SPEAK TO IS CATALYST
UNDERWRITING PRACTICES I CAN.
SPEAK TO THE GRANULAR DETAIL
ACROSS THE FOURTEEN ASSETS THAT
WE CURRENTLY OVERSEE WHICH IS
ABOUT FORTY TWO HUNDRED UNITS
TOTAL WERE ABOUT A THIRD OF THIS
TOTALLY CO SYSTEM- WE HAD A
THIRD PARTY. MARKET STUDY DONE
WE THOUGHT THAT THERE WOULD BE A
BETTER EVALUATION OF WHAT
CURRENT MARKET RENTS ARE. WITHIN
ALL OF THE COMMUNITIES WHERE
CATALYST OVERSEAS ASSETS ON
BEHALF OF TWO DIFFERENT J. P.
AS- IN COMPARISON TO OUR IN
PLACE RENTS A WE SHIPPED OFF.
THE RENT ROLLS AS OF A CERTAIN
DATE. TO THIS THIRD PARTY MARKET
PROVIDER SO THEY COULD SEE THE-
THAT WERE BEING PAID THAT CAME
UP WITH THEIR OWN CONCLUSION.
THEY LANDED AT A 16% DISCOUNT IT
RIGHT TODAY. AS MARKET RENTS ARE
DETERMINED TODAY RENTS HAVE
OBVIOUSLY BEEN CLIMBING
SUBSTANTIALLY ESPECIALLY ON THE
BACK OF CODE AND SOME OF THE
TENANT PROTECTIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN PEELED OFF. THAT AMOUNTS TO
TWENTY TWO MILLION DOLLAR. BILL
SUBSIDY JUST AT ALL PROPERTIES
AGAIN WE'RE ABOUT A THIRD OF
THIS TOTALLY COOL SYSTEM. WE DO
SHOOT WHEN WE UNDERWRITE THESE
ASSETS FOR AT LEAST A 10%
DISCOUNT TO MARKET RENTS. I
THINK THE NEW WANTS TO USE THE
WORDTHAT HAS COME UP A COUPLE
TIMES HERE. IS IN HOW YOU
CALCULATE MARKET RENTS- WE-
CALCULATE RENTS YOU KNOW IT WAS
REFERENCE THE THIRTY FIRST.
PERCENT INCOME RATIO. BUT THE
QUESTION AS TO WHAT YOU'RE
MULTIPLYING THAT BY WE
MULTIPLIED BY. COUNTY Y. T. CAC
FIGURES THAT ARE USED IN
TRADITIONAL CAPITAL A AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. A LOT OF OUR PROPERTIES
ARE ACTUALLY AT 30% A VERY
MEDIAN INCOME. WERE AWARE OF THE
FACT THAT SOME OTHERS OF USE 35%
SOME OF OUR TRANSACTIONS WITH
THIRTY FIVE PERCENT- BUT I DON'T
THINK THAT THE METHODOLOGY
THAT'S BEING USED IS
NONSTANDARD. WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF A 10% MINIMUM DISCOUNT.
THERE'S JUST A LOT OF NEW WANTS
AROUND HOW YOU CALCULATE THAT.
WHEN A PROPERTY IS HAD RAPIDLY
ESCALATING RENTS AND I THINK
WHAT WE'RE SEEING IN THE THIRD
PARTY VALIDATED DATA THAT WE CAN
PROVIDE TODAY. THAT WITH THE
ROCK. RIGHT GROWTH THAT WE ARE
SEEING AND UNFORTUNATELY EXPECT
TO CONTINUE SEEING GIVEN HOW
DIFFICULT IT IS TO BUILD NEW
SUPPLY IN THE STATE. THAT THIS
IS GOING TO CONTINUE TO BE A
MASSIVELY VALUABLE PRESERVATION-TOOL AND OUR PRIMARY CONCERN. IS
THAT WE QUICKLY LEGISLATE AWAY
THE ONLY PRESERVATION TOOL THAT
EXISTS TODAY FOR MIDDLE. EAST
YEAH THANK YOU FOR THAT I
APPRECIATE THAT AND I THINK- YOU
KNOW BY. PROBABLY SPOKEN AND I
THINK EVERYBODY IT SOUNDS LIKE
THAT WHAT I'M HEARING AT LEAST
IS THERE SOME THERE'S SOME BROAD
PARAMETERS OF AGREEMENT HERE
THERE'S SOME DETAILS THAT NEED
TO BE WORKED OUT- I THINK WE'RE
ALL GOING TO TRY TO AIM FOR THAT
SWEET SPOT MY CONFIDENCE HE GUYS
ARE GONNA DO IT SO I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY WITH
THAT. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
COLLEAGUES. AND IS THERE A
MOTION SOME OF THEM IN A SECOND. MISS QUIRK-SILVA OR SECOND THE
BILL- SOUL AND ALL L. A. CLOSER
TO SECOND BUT YOU KNOW THAT I
KNOW THIS BILL DOES TRY TO SET
SOME OF THOSE- PARAMETERS ON HOW
GPAS AND THEIR PARTNERS CAN USE
PUBLIC DOLLARS. AND THE FORMER
PROPERTY TAXES AND TAX EXEMPT
BONDS TO PURCHASE A MARKET
HOUSING I THINK ALSO CRITICALLY
THE BILL DOES THIS BY REQUIRING
INITIAL AND SUBSEQUENT RENTS TO
BE MORE DEEPLY AFFORDABLE WHICH
I THINK IS SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
ALL TRYING TO GET OUT HERE AND I
KNOW MY OFFICE WORKED WITH THE
SPONSORS- TO CRAFT AMENDMENTS TO
CREATE SOME ADDITIONAL
FLEXIBILITY. AFTER THE GPAS AT
USE THIS MODEL WALK WHILE
CREATING MORE PUBLIC BENEFIT
THROUGH LOWER RENTS I WOULD JUST
ASK THAT THE- OPPOSITION REALLY
COME TO THE TABLE TO TRY TO
REALLY NEGOTIATED DEAL HERE THAT
I THINK HOPEFULLY WE CAN LAND IN
THAT SWEET SPOT AND- AS WELL TO
GET YOU TO WORK WITH THE OFFICE-
TOWARDS THAT END WHICH I KNOW
MISTER BOARD YOU WILL DO. I'M
CITIES YOU WANT TO GET IN PLACE
FOR THIS CAN BE I THINK
NECESSARY GUARDRAILS BUT DOES SO
IN A WAY THAT STILL MABEL'S
THESE TYPES OF PROJECTS TO MOVE
FORWARD SO WITH THAT I'M HAPPY
TO. HELP MOVE THE BILL OUT OF
THE COMMITTEES TODAY- AND WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
ALL YOUR COMMENTS AND OFFER
COMMITTEE COMMENTS AS WELL WE
COVER OUR STATE. THE TELL THE.
EGGMAN ARE WE WILL. AND ALL THAT
WILL BE IT DON'T WANT TO PASS
OUT OF THE LEGISLATURE ARE LAW
THAT ARE ACTUALLY GOING TO KILL-
WHAT WHAT ARE OTHERWISE WOULD BE
VERY DEALS TO PRODUCE UP WORK
HOUSING SO WITHOUT RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. A THANK YOU.
MOTION IS TO AS A- WICKS I
SEYARTO. NINE MAUREEN CARILLO-
GABRIEL HI GABRIEL I KALRA KALRA
AYE KILEY QUIRK-SILVA
QUIRK-SILVA I WARD WAR DIE.
FIFTY FOUR AND THAT BILLS OUT
THANK YOU. WE WILL MOVE ON NOW
TO- MR LEE HAS A MINOR TECHNICAL
BILL. YOU KNOW ME WELL YEAH.
READY WHEN YOU ARE MISTER LEE.
THEN YOU KNOW HOW YOU GO AND
THEN WE'LL HAVE YOU. YEAH. NO
PROBLEM SIR. BUT. PAGE.
I THINK THAT'S PRESENTING
INFORMS. RIGHT YEAH MAYBE THAT'S
IT. THIS IS INCREDIBLY. THE
SECOND. LARA TWO ANALYSTS WHAT
FUTURE. VETERANS. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEAVE WHEN YOU'RE READY
OKAY. SO I BROUGHT SOME PROPS
FOR YOU TO VISUALIZE SUCCESS OF
VISUALIZE WHAT WE ARE AIMING FOR
I HAVE GREAT PLEASURE IN
PRESENTING TODAY AB TWENTY FIFTY
THREE THE SOCIAL HOUSING ACT
FIRST I WANT TO THANK THE-
COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING WITH
MY STAFF AND ALL THE PROPONENTS
ON CRAFTING THIS BILL AS WELL AS
A CHAIR- BUFFY WICKS FOR-
CHANGES LET COMMITTEE ON SOCIAL
HOUSING THE SOCIAL HOUSING ACT
WILL PRODUCE A PRESERVE FOR THE
HOUSING AND ALL OF CALIFORNIA.
THROUGHOUT THROUGH THIS MODEL
HOUSING WILL BE AFFORDABLE FOR
ALL INCOME LEVELS BECAUSE LIKE
DELEON UNION BELTS AND
FINANCIALLY SELF SUSTAINING
HOUSING FOR PEOPLE WITH HIGHER
INCOMES WILL CROSS SUBSIDIZE
LOWER INCOME UNITS THE RENT
SOLIDARITY AND ALLOW HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS TO BE REVENUE
NEUTRAL THIS MODEL SOCIAL
HOUSING HAS BEEN SUCCESSFUL BOTH
INTERNATIONALLY AND OTHER PARTS
OF THE COUNTRY. SO HERE WE HAVE
. ALTERA IN VIENNA WHICH IS.
VIENNA WHICH IS THE POSTER CHILD
OF SOCIAL HOUSING HAS HAD THEIR
PROGRAM FOR WELL OVER A HUNDRED
YEARS NOW. AND THIS IS THE MOST
CITED EXAMPLE OF SOCIAL HOUSING
IS NOT TYPICAL OF ALL SOCIAL
HOUSING EVEN IN AUSTRIA. BUT 60%
OF ALL VIENNESE RESIDENTS LIVE
IN SOCIAL HOUSING AND MOST PAY
THREE HUNDRED TO EIGHT HUNDRED
DOLLARS PER MONTH AND RENTS. ARE
SOCIAL HOUSING. DEVELOPMENTS
NEIGHBORHOODS LIKE THIS ARE
OBVIOUSLY VERY HIGH DEMAND EVEN
IN AUSTRIA. AND THE US. IN
MONTGOMERY COUNTY RIGHT HERE
BEHIND ME. DO YOU THE MONTGOMERY
COUNTY HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES
COMMISSION IN MARYLAND HAS BEEN
SUCCESSFULLY BUILDING HOUSING
INSPIRED BY SOCIAL HOUSING IN
VIENNA. AND ELSEWHERE. THEY PLAN
TO BUILD OVER FIVE THOUSAND
UNITS USING A SIMILAR APPROACH
pTO WHAT IS PROPOSED IN THIS BILL
IN CALIFORNIA OVER 97% OF CITIES
AND COUNTIES HAVE NOT PRODUCED
ENOUGH AFFORDABLE HOUSING. AND
MANY CALIFORNIANS ARE BURDENED
BY HOUSING COSTS WITH ONE IN
FIVE HOUSEHOLDS SPENDING OVER
HALF. OF THEIR INCOME ON HOUSING
SO IT'S CLEAR THAT CALIFORNIA
NEEDS ADDITIONAL TOOLS TO HELP
SOLVE THE HOUSING SHORTAGE AND
SOCIAL HOUSING IS A CRITICAL
PIECE OF THAT. SOCIAL HOUSING
GIVES US IN THE PUBLIC AS A
STATE OF CALIFORNIA DIRECT TOOLS
TO BUILD HOUSING THAT IS BADLY
NEEDED WE HAVE A LOT OF
INCENTIVES AND SIX IN CARE.
THERE BUT WE DO NOT HAVE THE
DIRECT TOOLS TO BUILD HOUSING
OURSELVES AND IF WE ARE TO MEET
THE MOMENT AND DEMAND THAT
CALIFORNIA'S LEAD WE HAVE TO
HAVE ALL THE TOOLS POSSIBLE. SO
I LIKE TO CONCLUDE BY THANKING
OUR SPONSORS THE BUILDING
TRADES- CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION EAST BAY FOR EVERYONE
CAN BE ACTION THE SJSU HUMAN
RIGHTS INSTITUTE FOR THEIR
SUPPORT AND ALL THE IN. CREDIBLE
SUPPORTERS ON HERE. AND TODAY I
AM JOINED HERE LIVE IN PERSON BY
ALLIE SACRAMENT THE HOUSING
ACTION COALITION. AND CAROL KIM
THE CEO OF THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY
BUILDING TRADES COUNCIL FAMILY
HOUSING CORPORATION AND THE
BUSINESS MANAGER FOR THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY BUILDING TRADES
COUNCIL AS WELL. SO I'LL HAVE
YOUR FIRST. THANK YOU GO AHEAD
INDIA. HI MY NAME IS ALLEY SAY
BERMAN AND I'M SPEAKING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
FIFTY THREE I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE HOUSING ACTION COALITION
A MEMBER SUPPORTED NONPROFIT
THAT ADVOCATES FOR CREATING MORE
HOUSING FOR RESIDENTS OF ALL
INCOME LEVELS TO HELP ALLEVIATE
THE BAY AREA ON CALIFORNIA'S HOW
TO HOUSING SHORTAGE DISPLACEMENT
AND AFFORDABILITY CRISIS I'M
ALSO HERE AS SOMEONE WHO HAS
BEEN DIRECT IMPACT THEIR STATE'S
HOUSING CRISIS. I MOVED TO THE
BAY AREA FROM FLORIDA WHEN I WAS
EIGHTEEN YEARS OLD TO PURSUE THE
FANTASTIC EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES THAT CALIFORNIA
HAS TO OFFER AND ALSO TO ESCAPE
THE CONSERVATIVE A FLORIDA.
CONSERVATISM OF FLORIDA. I
QUICKLY LEARNED THAT THE BAY
AREA HOUSING OPTIONS WERE
DESIGNED FOR STUDENTS LIKE ME.
IN ORDER TO BARELY AFFORD TO BE
A STUDENT HERE I HAD TO WORK
THREE JOBS AT A TIME TOTAL OF
EIGHTY HOURS A WEEK. IN ADDITION
TO MY SCHOOL COURSEWORK EVEN
JUGGLING THREE JOBS MY RENTAL
COSTS CONSUMED MORE THAN 75% OF
MY INCOME. AND MADE IT
IMPOSSIBLE TO PAY FOR OTHER
NECESSITIES LIKE HEALTHCARE. AND
THE SCANT HOUSING OPTIONS I
COULD AFFORD WERE LIMITED TO
RENTING OUT A LIVING ROOM OR
SHARING A TWO BEDROOM ONE BATH
WITH SIX PEOPLE. DUE TO MY
LIMITED HOUSING OPTIONS I FACE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE HOMOPHOBIA AND
TRANSPHOBIA IN MY HOME. AS A
RESULT I MOVED TEN TIMES IN FOUR
YEARS TO TRY TO FIND BETTER
ALTERNATIVES. MEANWHILE WHILE
STRUGGLING TO FIND ADEQUATE AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING I WAS DEALING
WITH SEXUAL HARASSMENT IN MY
WORKPLACE. AND I UNDERSTAND THAT
TOXIC WORKPLACE FOR OVER A YEAR
DO NOT HAVE A LAPSE OF INCOME.
WHICH WITHOUT AN INCOME CUSHION
WHAT RESULTED IN HOMELESSNESS.
THIS IS FLAT OUT UNACCEPTABLE.
MY STORY IS NOT UNUSUAL. IN FACT
IT IS THE NORM FOR LOW AND
MIDDLE INCOME FOLKS IN THE BAY
AREA. WE NEED EVERY TOOL TO BE
BUILDING HOUSING FOR EVERYONE
AND SOCIAL HOUSING IS ANOTHER
TOOL WE MUST SERIOUSLY EXPLORE.
WE HAVE A SERIOUS HOUSING
SHORTAGE IN CALIFORNIA OVER
NINETY PERCENT. 90% OF CITIES
AND- SEVEN UNABLE TO PRODUCE
ENOUGH AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
SOCIAL HOUSING MAKES IT EASIER
TO COMBAT THE HOUSING SHORTAGE
AND AFFORDABILITY CRISIS PLEASE
SUPPORT EIGHTY TWENTY FIFTY
THREE SO PEOPLE LIKE ME HAVE THE
SAME OPPORTUNITY TO LIVE IN
STRIVE. IN THE STATE WE ALL KNOW
AND LOVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. GOOD MORNING CHAIR
LEGS AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS CAROL CAN AND I'M THE
BUSINESS MANAGER OF THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL AS
WELL AS THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER OF THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY
BUILDING TRADES COUNCIL FAMILY
HOUSING CORPORATION WE BUILD OWN
AND OPERATE ONE OF THE LARGEST
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROPERTIES IN
SAN DIEGO COUNTY WITH FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY SIX UNITS ON
TWENTY TWO ACRES. AS PART OF OUR
FAMILY HOUSING CORPORATION'S
MISSION WE REGULARLY ADVOCATE
FOR MORE SAFE QUALITY AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND AS IT BUILDING
TRADES COUNCIL WE DO IT WITH AN
EYE TO CONSTRUCTING IN A MANNER
THAT INCLUDES STRONG JOB QUALITY
STANDARDS CREATING THE
CONDITIONS THAT ALLOW THE
WORKERS TO BUILD OUR HOMES TO
DRIVE THEMSELVES. OVER AND OVER
AGAIN WE'RE TOLD BY DEVELOPERS
WHO ARE SOMETIMES ECHOED BY
POLICY MAKERS. THAT PROJECTS
WITH THE STRONGEST AND HIGHEST
JOB QUALITY STANDARDS JUST QUOTE
DO NOT PENCIL. WHICH BY THE WAY
IS CODE FOR. DOES NOT PRODUCE
ENOUGH PROFIT. AB TWENTY FIFTY
THREE CONCEIVES OF A MODEL OF
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT THAT
PRODUCES MIXED FAMILIES MIXED
INCOME FAMILY HOUSING WITH
RELATIVE EASE. SOMETHING THAT
EVEN THE BEST INTENTIONS
NONPROFIT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPER STRUGGLE TO DO BECAUSE
OF THE COMPLEXITIES OF OUR
CURRENT SYSTEMS WERE FINANCING
HOUSING. IT INCORPORATES
CRITICAL WORKER PROTECTIONS
GUARANTEED THE USE OF CHILDREN
TRAINED WORKFORCE AND PAYMENT OF
PREVAILING WAGE TO CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS ON THE PROJECTS
CONTEMPLATED BY THE BILL. IT
APPLIES A PROVEN SELF SUSTAINING
MODEL FOR MAINTENANCE AND CAN
YOU DEVELOPMENT IF THE SILICATES
THE EMPOWERMENT AND SELF
DETERMINATION OF THOSE RESIDING
IN SOCIAL HOUSING COMMUNITIES
ONCE BUILT. AND IT NEVER WORRIES
WHETHER THERE'S ENOUGH PROFIT TO
MAKE THE PROJECT PENCIL. IT
ALMOST SOUNDS LIKE MAGIC A
FAIRYTALE STORY THAT CAN'T
POSSIBLY BE REAL THERE ARE MANY
WITH STRONG PERSONAL MOTIVES
THAT WILL WORK VERY HARD TO
CONVINCE YOU THAT IT IS. BUT THE
TRUTH IS IT'S A MODEL THAT HAS
BEEN SUCCESSFULLY PRODUCING
HOUSING WITH THOSE POSITIVE
CHARACTERISTICS AROUD THE WORLD
FOR MORE THAN A CENTURY. HOUSING
IS A FUNDAMENTAL HUMAN RIGHT IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE NEXT UNITED
NATIONS STATED RATHER THAN
TREATING HOUSING AS A COMMODITY
VALUE PRIMARILY AS AN ASSET FOR
THE ACCUMULATION OF WEALTH.
GOVERNMENTS MUST RECLAIM HOUSING
AS A SOCIAL GOOD AND THOUSAND
SURE THE HUMAN RIGHT TO A PLACE
TO LIVE IN SECURITY AND DIGNITY.
TAKE A MOMENT TO IMAGINE WHAT WE
COULD ACCOMPLISH TOGETHER IF WE
ALL AGREED THAT HOUSING IS A
HUMAN RIGHT. THAT GOVERNMENT
EXISTS TO PROTECT AND PROVIDE
HUMAN RIGHTS THAT NO SHOULD
PROFIT FROMPROVIDING WITH
HOLDING A HUMAN RIGHT THAT THE
PROVISION OF BASIC RIGHTS SHOULD
NEVER DEPRIVE THOSE WHO GIVE
THEIR LABOR TO PROVIDE AND
PROTECT OUR ESSENTIAL DIGNITY
AND HUMANITY. THESE THINGS MIGHT
SOUND IDEALISTIC HOW CAN ANY OF
US A BY ALLOWING THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE TO BECOME THE PLACE
WHERE HUMAN RIGHTS COME TO BE
SOLD OFF FOR. AB TWENTY FIFTY
THREE WILL CREATE SELF
SUSTAINING HOUSING THAT WILL BE
PERMANENTLY AFFORDABLE TO
WORKING CALIFORNIANS OF ALL
INCOME LEVELS IT WILL
SIGNIFICANTLY ADDRESS OUR
HOUSING CRISIS BY DEVELOPING
HOMES FOR THE SOCIAL BENEFIT OF
ALL CALIFORNIANS. RATHER THAN
FOR THE PROFIT OF A FEW AND IT
IS FOR THESE REASONS THAT WE
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT. IT THE
FIFTY EIGHT. DO YOU TO DO THE
SAME TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- OTHER WITNESSES IN
THE ROOM WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR. AB TWENTY FIFTY
THREE PLEASE NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION. HI I'M YEMEN ROW WITH
EAST BAY FOR EVERYONE WE'RE A
SPONSOR AND- IN STRONG SUPPORT.
HI GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
JOSHUA HAN WITH COMMON GROUND
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF SOCIAL
HOUSING ACT THANK YOU. HELLO
DAVID KING FROM- ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT TWENTY EIGHT IN UNION
CITY IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
FIFTY THREE. GOOD MORNING I'M
BILL MONROE FROM CHICO
CALIFORNIA WHERE WE ALSO NEED
THIS KIND OF SOCIAL HOUSING I'VE
PRETTY MUCH SUPPORTED THANK YOU. I AM SURE MEMBERS JAMES
DIRECTOR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE COUNCIL LABORS WENT STRONG
SUPPORT THANKS. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS ME JEREMY SMITH
YOUR BEHALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL CO SPONSOR HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THANK YOU. SURE MEMBERS
ARE. THAT CALLING EASTBAY IN B.
BUT ALSO REPRESENTING OUR
PARTNER ORGANIZATIONS YOU BE
ACTION MOUNTAIN V. IN THE
PENINSULA FOR EVERYONE. SAN
FRANCISCO YOU'LL BE SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY. ESSEL COUNTY IN B. AND
SOUTH BAY IN BE REGISTERING OUR
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
THANK YOU. MANAGE MAN CHAIR
MEMBERS COULD DURING ANIC COMBO
ON BABCOCK FREE IN BE IN SUPPORT. TONY BLAIR WITHA CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION HERE
SUPPORT AS WELL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. I WILL BRING IT BACK HE- A
SORRY OPERATOR- THE PHONE LINES
PLEASE- IF FOLKS WANT TO
REGISTER FOLKS FROM THE PUBLIC
REGISTRY SUPPORT US SUPPORT FOR-
AB TWENTY FIFTY THREE. NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MOVED TO THE
PUBLIC IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
REGISTER YOUR SUPPORT FOR A BI
TWENTY FIFTY THREE. PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE
MOMENT OF GERALD Q. WE DO HAVE
QUITE A FEW QUEUING UP IS A
POPULAR TOPIC WE'RE GONNA GO
FIRST TO LINE NUMBER TWENTY ONE
ONE TWENTY ONE LINES OPEN GO
AHEAD PLEASE. WHEN WE CAME HERE
YOU GO AGAIN. ONE TWENTY ONE NOT
RESPONDING WE ARE GOING TO LINE
NUMBER EIGHTY LINE AT YOUR LINES
OPEN WILL HAVE CONSIDERED
COMMENT. I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
EDUARDO MARTINEZ WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION A
PROUD TO BE HERE AT CO SPONSOR
FOR YOUR DESKTOP THANK YOU. LINE
EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD THE
MORE REALIZATION AND POSITION.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS ON A
RESCUE THAT WAS VERIFIED ALAMEDA
COUNTY ASK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT
FOR AB TWENTY FIFTY THREE. THANK
YOU. ONE NUMBER TWENTY FOUR
LINES OPEN GO AHEAD PLEASE. HEY
THIS IS CAROL KELLY FROM- SANTA
CRUZ HUMBOLDT CITY AND COUNTY-
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT. ONE
FIFTY SIX YOUR LINES OPEN GO
AHEAD PLEASE. THE PUBLIC MORE
CALIFORNIAN BEING STRONG SUPPORT. THE LINE EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS- MY NAME IS RUN GO
OKAY YOUNG YOUNG I SERVE AS
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR TO THE
PROCEDURES THAT WORK WORKING
WITH FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MONICA YAMADA AND FROM ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT FOURTEEN DOUBLE LAYOUT
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU. THANKS FOR YOUR LINE
NUMBER EIGHTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING SHOW NUMBERS
STARTING DROWNED ON BEHALF OF
THE PENINSULA YOUNG DEMOCRATS
FUNDAMENTAL FOR EVERYONE CAN
EIGHTY TWENTY ONE AN EIGHTY
TWENTY FOUR IN STRONG SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MAX'S LINE NUMBER EIGHTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS RYAN COMPTON AND LONG BEACH
WITH CA COMMON GROUND CALLING IN
SUPPORT. WITH ONE ADELINE EIGHTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS ROBERT STRUGGLING WITH
SAN FRANCISCO AGAIN BE INCOME
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AN EXTRA LINE
SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BARDWELL SPRINTER BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THE NEXT STEP IS ONE NUMBER
FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. ABOUT THE
ROUTINE CALIFORNIA YIMBY ARE
SUPPORT. ONE NUMBER NINETY
EARNERS BECAUSE I DON'T. HELLO
THIS IS JOHN BRADY WITH LIVED
EXPERIENCE ADVISORS AND SAN
DIEGO AND STRONG SUPPORT. NEXUS
LINE NUMBER EIGHTY FIVE GO AHEAD
PLEASE. HELLO MY NAME IS CONNOR
ANYTHING I'M A VOLUNTEER WITH A
CALIFORNIA COMMON GROUND AND I
AM CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. THE NEXT OF THE LINE
EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH
KILLED IN GERRY CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER IN SUPPORT. THEN WE HAVE
ONE NUMBER TWELVE MOMENT PLEASE
. GOOD MORNING EVERYONE WITH
YOUR CALL CALIFORNIA SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY EIGHT THANK YOU. WE
HAVE ONE NUMBER THIRTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE THIRTY TWO
LINES OPEN WE CAN HEAR YOU
GLOBAL ECONOMY. IDENTIFIER
POLICY NEED FOR STUFF BABY
PRODUCTS FOR AB TWO ZERO FIVE
THREE THANK YOU. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR THE KEY WAS NOT CLEAR.
THANK YOU WE WILL NOW BRING IT
BACK TO THE ROOM FOR WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION AND I BELIEVE WE
HAVE A WITNESS BY PHONE IN
OPPOSITION. JENNIFER STACK I
BELIEVE YOU'RE JOINING BY PHONE
OPPOSITION IS THAT RIGHT.
OPERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE SEE IF.
MISRAQ IS AVAILABLE.
RESPECTFULLY EXPRESS BUS STARTS
ZERO IF YOU'RE ON THE PHONE WE
DON'T SEE YOU LISTED. WE'LL GO
THERE NEXT YEAR. OKAY ONE MOMENT
YOU'RE- IN THE. IN A PREVIOUS
AND THEN. THE CROCKETT. WE DO
FIND EVIDENCE TWO LINES KEEPING
UP IS TO FIGURE OUT WHICH ONE
SERVICE WE CAN OPEN UP THAT SHE
CAME IN AS A MODEL MOST SO WE
DON'T HAVE THE SHOULD NOT
LABELED. IT'S A THAT'S REALLY.
INVESTORS HOP SKIP AND A JUMP.
THE HOUSE RIGHT THERE.
WE'VE HAD THREE Q. ACCORDING TO
BE JENNIFER SPECTRUM
DISINTEGRATE NOW WHICH ONE OF
WHICH ONE OF THE SUSPECTS
BECAUSE- YOU JUST A MOMENT
PLEASE.
OKAY WE HAVE A WE HAVE FOUND
THAT WOULD APOLOGIZE FOR THAT
THE LADY- JENNIFER SPECULAR
LINES IS NOW OPEN LET ME GO
AHEAD AND PROCEED. BUT I'M SURE
CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES WE CAN HEAR
YOU. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
JENNIFER'S. ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS WE ARE CURRENTLY
OPPOSED AB TWENTY FIFTY THREE WE
DO HAVE SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS
ABOUT ITS IMPACT TO OUR STATE
HOUSING SUPPLY AS CURRENTLY
DRAFTED THE AUTHORITY DOES NOT
HAVE TO CONSTRUCT A SINGLE NEW
UNIT TO ACCOMPLISH ITS MISSION I
COULD FURTHER EXACERBATE OUR
STATE'S HOUSING AFFORDABILITY
CRISIS. BY PREVENTING
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES WE
KEEPING HOMEOWNERSHIP
FURTHERMORE THE AUTHORITY
APPROACH DOES NOT CONTAIN
APPROPRIATE SAFEGUARDS AND IN
FACT CAN TRANSFER OUT THAT THE
OTHER CORPORATION TO SIMPLY HAVE
A MISSION TO PROVIDE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. AT ANY TIME AND AT NO
COST TO THAT CORPORATION.
ADDITIONALLY MANAGER I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO QUICKLY NOTE MY
COLLEAGUE EXPERIENCED TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES EARLIER DURING THE
TESTIMONY FOR A BI EIGHTEEN
FIFTY EIGHT ITEM NUMBER
QUIRK-SILVA. AND WAS UNABLE TO
EXPRESS BUT WELL WE HAVE AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
ON THAT MEASURE WE DO LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND SPONSORS TO ADDRESS
OUR CONCERNS. WE APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY
THIS MORNING AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WELL WITH MANY IN THE
AUTHOR ON ON FUTURE
OPPORTUNITIES TO IMPROVE HOW
THE- LINES THAT CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU AND SORRY ABOUT THIS
TECHNICAL DIFFERENT TO. YOUR
OPPOSITION IS THAT REGISTERED
HERE ON THE OTHER BILLS WELL- DO
WE HAVE ANY OTHER PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IN THE
ROOM. OR PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONES. OKAY
ANY PRIMARY SORRY ANY OTHER
ADDITIONAL FOLKS IN THE ROOM
WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER THEIR
OPPOSITION. MADAM CHAIR WERE A
TWEENER I'M BOB NAYLOR I
REPRESENT FEELS DEAD AND COMPANY
THAT'S HOWARD AHMANSON JUNIOR
WHO'S A PRO HOUSING
PHILANTHROPISTS IS ALSO
CONCERNED ABOUT EMINENT DOMAIN
ABUSE WE ARE IN PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHOR
ABOUT. CLARIFYING THAT THERE
WILL NOT BE EMINENT DOMAIN
AUTHORITY IN THIS. THE THIRTY
OKAY THANK YOU TRAINERS HAVE
BEEN REGISTERED OKAY- AN
OPERATOR ANY- FOLKS IN UP IN A
FROM THE PUBLIC IN OPPOSITION ON
THE PHONE NAME ORGANIZATION
IMPOSITION PLEASE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR OF THE GENERAL
PUBLIC IF THE LEGISLATURE
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND ONE MORE U.
TWO Q. LOADED UP. HELLO ONE
MOMENT. OKAY. WE'RE GOING TO GO
TO ALIGN NUMBER EIGHTEEN ONE
MOMENT LISTENS TO GET PERFECTION.
THEY WERE GONNA LINE NUMBER
NINETY SEVEN LINE NINETY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN WILL HAVE
CONSIDERED COMMON NAME POSITION
AND ORGANIZATION THANKS YES I
WAS IN QUEUE FOR SUPPORTING THIS
BELL. I WAS NEVER GIVEN A
NUMBER. I WANT TO ISSUE SUPPORT
MY NAME IS FRANCESCA WANDER I AM
A MEMBER OF INDIVISIBLE SAN
FRANCISCO INDIVISIBLE SACRAMENTO
INDIVISIBLE GALLO CALIFORNIA
STATE STRONG INDIVISIBLE CALLING
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF. TWO OH
FIVE THREE THANK YOU YOUR
SUPPORT HAS BEEN REGISTERED.
THANK YOU HELLO NECKLINE NUMBER
EIGHTEEN LINE EIGHTEEN RUNS
OAKLAND POLICE. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS KATE
BELL ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
RENTAL HOUSING ASSOCIATION AN
APARTMENT THE GREATER LA IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. NEXT IN
LINE NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINETY FIVE WE CAN HEAR YOU
PLEASE WORK WITH YOUR COMMENT
NAME ORGANIZATIONAL POSITION
PLEASE. NINETY FIVE NOT
RESPONDING ONE MOMENT MADAM
CHAIR WE HAVE ONE MORE KEEP
COMING UP. BUT NINE NINETY THANK
. NINETY FIVE RELIABLE WE CAN
HEAR YOU SIR PLEASE GOING TO
COMING UP YEP SORRY THANK YOU
SIR I DO NOT NINETY FIVE
APOLOGIZE- THIS IS COMFORTING
ANTHONY I AM THE VICE MAYOR OF
THE CITY OF BURBANK AND I AM THE
CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOCRATIC PARTY'S DISABILITIES
CAUCUS I ALSO WAS IN QUEUE IN
LINE FOR SUPPORT OF TWO ZERO
FIVE THREE ONCE AGAIN I'M IN
SUPPORT OF TWO ZERO. FIVE THREE
THANK YOU SO MUCH. MAX'S WINE
NINETY FOUR IS GONNA. HI CAN YOU
HEAR ME WE CAN HEAR YOU PLEASE
WILL HAVE A COMMENT. HI SORRY
ABOUT THAT I ALSO HAD SOME
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES MY NAME
IS ANA EAGLE- DO SHALL I AM
CURRENTLY A MEMBER OF COMMON
GROUND CALIFORNIA. ON THE SOME
OF MY COLLEAGUES ALSO VOICED
THEIR SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY
THREE AND I AM ALSO JUST CALLING
AND TO VOICE MY SUPPORT FOR
ASSEMBLY BILL- TWENTY FIFTY
THREE. THANK YOU. MELCHER ONCE
AGAIN THE KEY WAS CLEAR. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WILL NOT BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ROOM AND
MISTER KALRA FELL BY MR WARD'S.
YEAH NUMBER- I'MVERY EXCITED
ABOUT THIS BILL LOOK FORWARD TO
BE TENDED TO JOIN AND- ON THE
BILL ITSELF BUT- IT'S GREAT TO
SEE A COALITION COMING TOGETHER-
CREATING CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
HOUSING CREATING GREAT JOBS- AND
CREATING AN OPPORTUNITY- FOR
WHEN. AT TIMES I SALAS A LOT
WHEN I WAS IN THE COUNCIL SAN
JOSE AT TIMES WHEN IT CAN BE
CHALLENGING TO FIND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS TO GET THEIR
FINANCING ONLINE AND MAKE IT
PENCIL OUT WHAT HAVE YOU THAT-
THAT- PUBLIC- JURISDICTIONS CAN
ON THEIR OWN. FIND A WAY TO MAKE
IT HAPPEN- AND- WITHOUT RUNNING
BUT THE PROFIT MOTIVE WORRYING
ABOUT THE HOUSING- AND CREATING
GREAT JOBS WHILE WE'RE AT IT SO-
I THINK THIS IS- AN EXCELLENT
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL OF US. TO
GET BEHIND- AND I FIND IT YOU
KNOW. RESPECTIVAS BUT I THINK
PART OF THE ARGUMENT AS LITTLE.
PECULIAR PARTICULARLY THE- LAW
ON THE- PRODUCTION OF PROPERTY
TAX LEVY IS WHEN I. THOUGHT THE
VILLAGERS REALLY LIKED WHEN
PROPERTY TO. A REDUCE MAYBE IF
THEY CAN'T BENEFIT MAYBE THEY'LL
SUPPORT AS MUCH BUT- AT THE END
OF THE DAY IT'S A COST BENEFIT
ANALYSIS THE REALITY IS. B.
BENEFIT A LOT MORE BY MAYBE
REDUCING SOME OF THOSE LOCAL
PROPERTY TAX REVENUES BUT WHAT
WE GAIN ADDED CREATING.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING STOCK IN SUCH
A MEANINGFUL WAY SO I REALLY
PREFER- AND- IT HAS BEEN
REMOVED. AND HAPPY WITH BILL.
GREAT WE HAVE A MOTION SECOND
AND MISTER WARD. THANK YOU I
REALLY WANT TO COMMEND THE
AUTHOR FOR A LOT OF WORK YOU PUT
INTO THIS ALL OF LAST YEAR-
THROUGHOUT THE FALL RESEARCH
PERIOD AND THEN OF COURSE. TO
BRING THIS FORWARD AND SUCH AN
AMAZING FORM HERE TODAY PROUD TO
BE A CO AUTHOR OF THIS I THINK
IT REALLY. HELPS- WHAT EXISTS
IN. PATRICK FORM ACROSS THE
STATE BUT DEFINITELY NOT ACROSS
THE ENTIRE STATE ALL IN ALL OF
OUR COMMUNITIES TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE THIS MODEL- REALLY THANKFUL
THAT YOU'RE BRINGING SUCH A
WIDE. COALITION OF- OF GROUPS-
INTO THIS PROCESS AND- I KNOW
ONE THING I JUST WANT IT- LEE ON
THE RECORD TO THAT WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT- BECAUSE- THERE ARE
FUNDING STREAMS TO EXISTING FOR
SOME OF THE LOCAL NEWS FOR
EXAMPLE. OUR HOUSING COMMISSION
OR HOUSING AUTHORITY- IS ABLE TO
ITS HOUSING DEVELOPERS. ARE ABLE
TO DO THIS DIRECTLY- KITA- HERE
IN SACRAMENTO ANOTHER KIND OF
EXAMPLE WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT ANYTHING THAT THE STATE IS
DOING ISN'T GOING TO IMPEDE. ON
THE ABILITY FOR DIRECT PASSWORD
DIRECT FLOW TO SOME OF THOSE
LOCAL ENTITIES THAT ARE ALREADY
ABLE TO PRODUCE- EXACTLY WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO HERE
STATEWIDE SO THANK YOU FOR THIS.
REALLY HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY. QUIRK-SILVA. GOOD
AFTERNOON BILL I THINK FOR A
CLOSED UP NEWS- OKAY IT FEELS
LIKE IT'S- I DO APPLAUD THE
AUTHOR FOR THIS VISION AND THE
GRAPHICS ARE INTERESTING TO ME-
EXCEPT FOR THE FACT THAT WE'RE
DID YOU SEE THESE GRAPHICS ARE
FROM VIENNA THIS ONE IS VIENNA
THIS ONE IS IN MARYLAND. OKAY
MARYLAND YEAH. ZERO TWO TO ME
IT'S DEFINITELY SOMETHING THAT
I'M INTERESTED IN MY MAJOR
CONCERN ARE ALL FIRST OF ALL
SETTING UP A NEW AUTHORITY AS
I'VE ALREADY TALKED TO YOU ABOUT
WE HAVE MULTIPLE AUTHORITIES
UNDER THE HOUSING UMBRELLA AND
WITH THOSE MULTIPLE AUTHORITIES
WE STILL SEEM TO HAVE. AN ISSUE
WITH BRINGING FORWARD MORE AND
MORE LEGISLATION TO STREAMLINE
TO REDUCE ALL OF THESE THINGS
AND WE'RE KIND OF STUCK SO TO
ADD YET ANOTHER AUTHORITY- BY
THE WAY WE HAVE SO MANY
AUTHORITIES IN CALIFORNIA I
CAN'T EVEN COUNT A MALL UNDER
MANY UMBRELLAS AND THIS CAUSES A
LOT OF THIS BUREAUCRATIC ISSUE I
MEAN RIGHT IT CHAIR. OF
COMMUNICATION AND CONVEYANCING
PULLING BROADBAND ACROSS THE
STATE SOUNDS GREAT BROADBAND FOR
ALL AND NOW WE'RE WORKING WITH
MULTIPLE AUTHORITIES AND FINDING
THAT IT'S NOT SO EASY WHEN YOU
HAVE VARIOUS JURISDICTIONS SO
THAT THAT'S AN ISSUE FOR ME-
JUST SETTING UP A NEW BOARD IN
YOUR BILL THE FINANCING AND
START UP COSTS THIS IS ANOTHER
ISSUE THAT I THINK NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED. IT SAYS THE BILL
STATES THAT THE C. HA HE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING AUTHORITY NEW
AUTHORITY. SO NOT. WORKING WITH
THE OTHER AUTHORITIES BUT THE
NEW AUTHORITY OPERATE ACCORDING
TO PRINCIPLES OF REVENUE
NEUTRALITY THOUGH IT DOES NOT
SPECIFY THE TIME PERIOD OVER
WHICH REVENUE NEUTRALITY WOULD
BE ACHIEVED- AND THAT OF COURSE
YOU WOULD HAVE TO HAVE START UP
CAPITAL. SO THE START UP CAPITAL
MEANS WHERE YOU GET GETTING THE
FUNDS TO START THIS NEW
AUTHORITY AND IN THE BILL IT
SAYS OBLIGATION BY. SO IN-
GETTING THIS THEN YOU WOULD HAVE
TO HAVE ANOTHER PIECE OF
LEGISLATION FOR THESE OBLIGATION
BONDS THAT WOULD REQUIRE A TWO
THIRDS. VOTE SO AGAIN I'M JUST
POINTING THIS OUT BECAUSE AS
ATTRACTIVE AS THE SET THIS SEEMS
AN AS MUCH OF A COALITION AS YOU
HAVE ON BOARD CERTAINLY NOT
SOMEBODY WHO'S TRYING TO GET IN
THE WAY. OF THE- BUT WE HAVE TO
BE ABLE TO PEEL THE ONION
BECAUSE- THE TIME THAT I'VE BEEN
HERE IN THE TIME THAT I'VE BEEN
ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT WE KEEP
MAKING THESE BROAD ATTEMPTS. AND
THEN WE HAVE YET ANOTHER
AUTHORITY TO FUND. AND WHEN WE
HAVE TO FUNDED AUTHORITY WITH
THE NINE MEMBER PANEL PLUS THE
EMPLOYEES AND ALL OF THE- ARTS
THAT IT WOULD TAKE ONCE THE
UNITS ARE BUILT THEY'RE NOT JUST
BUILT THEY HAVE TO BE SUSTAINED.
SO YOU'VE ADDRESSED THE WORK
FORCE TO BUILD THEM BUT THEN
THERE'S ALSO THE SUSTAINABILITY
AND ALL TOO OFTEN AND PUBLIC
HOUSING THAT WE'VE SEN ACROSS
THE STATE OF CRIME CALIFORNIA.
THERE ARE SOME DIRE IMAGES OF
WHAT WE CALL PROJECTS. AND WHAT
HAPPENED AND HE'S COUNTIES WHEN
THEY WEREN'T SUSTAINED. SO THAT
THAT'S MY CONCERN IS THAT I
CERTAINLY WANT TO SEE
OPPORTUNITIES AND YOU'VE HEARD
MAYBE A BROKEN RECORD UP HERE I
MEAN WE NEED MORE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WE NEED MORE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING BUT- WHEN WE ADD
ADDITIONAL AUTHORITIES I MEAN I
YEAH I THINK IN THIS AGENDA WE
HAVE THREE TYPES OF AUTHORITIES
THAT WE COULD BE APPROVING SO
I'M JUST MAKING THOSE COMMENTS-
BECAUSE I DO THINK THAT AS THIS
MOVES FORWARD THOSE THINGS ARE
SERIOUS. ISSUES THE FINANCING OF
THE AUTHORITY THE BONDING OF THE
STORY AND THE SUSTAINABILITY OF
THESE UNITS- IF AND WHEN THEY
GET BILLED BECAUSE HOPEFULLY
THAT IS THE END RESULT THAT
THERE ARE. MANY MANY HUNDREDS OF
AFFORDABLE UNITS BUT LIKE WE
TALKED ABOUT ANOTHER WE DON'T
WANT TO JUST BUILD SOMETHING IF
WE CAN'T SUSTAIN IT. BECAUSE WE
DON'T SUSTAIN IT THEN WE HAVE-
YOU KNOW EVERYTHING WAS PERFECT
THE FIRST YEAR IT'S BUILT BUT
TEN YEARS DOWN TWENTY YEARS DOWN
THIRTY YEARS WHAT IS THAT GOING
TO LOOK LIKE SO THAT'S MY
QUESTION THAT IS NOT REALLY
QUESTION IT'S MOSTLY A COMMENT-
BUT I DO APPLAUD YOU FOR YOUR-
VISION I KNOW EVEN. IN
TIRELESSLY ON THIS AND I KNOW
THAT THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE.
THAT ARE HOPING THAT THIS WILL
MOVE FORWARD. MISS KOREA THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND I DON'T
THINK. THE AUTHOR CAN NOT A LACK
OF I THANK THE AUTHOR FOR ALL
THE WORK THAT HE'S DONE ON ON
THIS BILL I LOOK AT THE GRAPHICS
AND BY THE WAY BIG FAN BIG FAN
OF PRESENTATION GRAPHICS WE GET
TO WE GET TO SEE WHAT IT LOOKS
LIKE- TO KNOW THAT THERE ARE
PLACES LIKE VIENNA IN WHICH THIS
HAS BEEN A REALITY OR EVEN THE
STATE OF MARYLAND OR THIS IS A
REALITY- YOU KNOW I REPRESENT
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES AND-
VERY UNIQUE NEIGHBORHOODS THAT
SURROUND. IN THE URBAN CORE
VALET THAT'S AROUND DOWNTOWN LOS
ANGELES PERCENT HISTORIC
COMMUNITIES AND SADLY WE HAVE
RUN OUT OF SPACE- THAT'S A BIG
CONCERN- THAT WE JUST HAVE IN
THE CITY AND NEIGHBORHOODS THAT
I REPRESENT HOWEVER THAT DOESN'T
MEAN THAT WITHIN L. A. COUNTY
AND WITHIN OTHER PARTS OF LOS
ANGELES THIS CAN BE A REALITY-
YOU KNOW I THINK ABOUT ALL THE
WORK THAT'S BEING DONE AROUND
TRANSPORTATION OPERADORES
EXTENSION OF TRAINS AND TRANSIT
SYSTEMS THE CONNECTIVITY OF OUR
CITY THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES AND
IN THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES.
HOW INCREDIBLY EXPENSIVE IT'S
BECOME TO LIVE IN MY OWN
COMMUNITY I JUST HAD A HOMES A
TWO BEDROOM SMALL LITTLE IT'S
YOU KNOW HALF THE SIZE OF THIS
COMMITTEE ROOM SELL FOR ONE
POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
COMMUNITY OF EL SERENO RIGHT
NEXT TO WHERE I LIVE YOU KNOW
I'M A STATE LEGISLATOR BUT CAN'T
AFFORD A IN THE COMMUNITY THAT I
REPRESENT MUCH MANY OF US
BECAUSE IT'S JUST GOTTEN SO
INCREDIBLY- EXPENSIVE IN THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM OF
HOMEOWNERSHIP JUST SEEMS
INCREDIBLY OUT OF REACH. AND SO
WHILE YOU KNOW I DO I CALL MY
COLLEAGUES A CONCERN IN TERMS OF
WILL HAVE THIS DONE HOW DO WE
CREATE AN AGENCY HOW DO WE FIND
IT HARD WHAT IS IT WHAT DOES IT
LOOK LIKE THAT'S OUR JOB OUR JOB
IS TO FIGURE THAT OUT- AND
HAVING THESE CONVERSATIONS I
THINK IS PART OF THE SOLUTION I
THINK INVOLVING VARIOUS
DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDERS NOT ONLY
IN HOUSING COMMITTEE- BUT ALSO
AND BUDGET. TO INSURE THAT WE'RE
DOING WHAT WE NEED TO DO TO
CREE. THE NEW OPERA. THAT WE
NEED TO SEE ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SOCIAL HOUSING IS AN
ANSWER TO THAT- I ENVY OTHER
CITIES THAT HAVE MORE SPACE.
BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S THAT'S
PART OF THE CONVERSATION I GETS
TO HAPPEN IN TERMS OF WHERE ARE
THE POTENTIAL AND OPPORTUNITIES
TO. MEET THIS- AND SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO TWO ONE BEING OF A
PRINCIPAL JOINT AUTHORS TO THIS
BILL- BUT ALSO SEEN THE
CONVERSATIONS MOVE FORWARD IN
COMMITTEE- NOT ONLY IN OUR HOUSE
BUT IN THE SENATE AS WELL AND
ENSURING THAT. HE KNOWS CLEARLY
AS WE THINK ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE
CLIMATE JUSTICE TRANSPORTATION.
TRANSIT CORRIDORS HOUSING
HOMELESSNESS. THE CONVERSATION
AROUND REDUCING HOUSING PRICES
YOU KNOW WHAT ACTUALLY DOES THAT
WHEN YOU SEE BLIGHT IN OUR
COMMUNITY. WHEN YOU SEE
ENCAMPMENTS AND OUR COMMUNITY
WHEN YOU SEE INDIVIDUALS THAT
CLEARLY NEEDS. SERVICE IS NOT
RECEIVE THEM- IN OUR COMMUNITY I
KNOW IS THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE
ACROSS OUR STATE. REGARDLESS OF
INCOME REGARDLESS WHERE YOU COME
FROM REGARDLESS OF WHAT YOUR
NEIGHBORHOOD LOOKS LIKE. WE AS A
SOCIETY NEED TO FIGURE OUT A
VERY REAL SOLUTION TO HOUSING
HOMELESSNESS MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES CLIMATE CHANGE TRANSIT
AND IT'S ALL CONNECTED. BECAUSE
PEOPLE FAMILY WORKING FAMILIES
CAN NO LONGER AFFORD TO LIVE IN
MY DISTRICT THE ONLY FURTHER
OUT. THEY DRIVE FURTHER IN. IT
ONLY INCREASES IN OUR CARBON
EMISSIONS AND SO IT'S ALL
CONNECTED AND I THINK IT'S A
MATTER OF JUST FIGURING OUT WHAT
THAT SOLUTION IS SO AGAIN THANK
YOU FOR THE HARD WORK THAT ALL
OF YOU HAVE DONE. ON THIS BILL
FOR INCLUDING OF THE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AROUND. EVERYTHING
ALL OF THOSE WORKERS OR ANYTHING
SHE SAID THAT MIKE DOWN- AND-
AND ENSURING THAT WE'RE ALL
WORKING COLLABORATIVELY TO
SECURE SOLUTIONS FOR. IT'S
ACROSS AND WELCOME TO FROM SAN
DIEGO WELCOME TO THE SACRAMENTO
I SAW YOUR TWEET THIS MORNING.
CARS AND AN OPERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE- MUTE THE PHONE LINES
WHEN WORD SPEAKING IN COMMITTEE
THAT BE GREAT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISCREANTS ROBBED. OF ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
FOLKS IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM. AND
DO WE HAVE- YEAH. MY NAME IS
FRANKLIN ANDRADE ALONG BRANDON'S
RETURNED WORK ON ONE HIT CAN YOU
PLEASE QUITE THE PHONE LINES.
BUFFALO'S QUIET FRANCINE JUST
POPPING UP IN THE GROUP AS A
FULLY YOU'LL HAVE TO TURN ON THE
MOMENT. WITH OUR PHONE OKAY
THANK YOU- DID WAS STARTED WE
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND. OKAY
MISTER COLOR MOVE THE BILL
MISCREANT- SECONDED THAT FINE
OKAY. OKAY IT'S LIKE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES TECHNOLOGY MEETS
TWENTY TWENTY TWO TECHNOLOGY-
WELL I JUST WANNA- REALLY
APPLAUD THE AUTHOR FOR PUTTING
OUT THIS- VISION OF A BILL AND
HE AND I HAVE WORKED IN THE
SPACE TOGETHER SINCE HE GOT
HERE- IN THE ASSEMBLY AND- I
THINK REALLY EXPLAIN THE CONCEPT
OF SOCIAL HOUSING IS CRITICAL WE
NEED NEW OR DIFFERENT BOLDER
IDEAS- TO ADDRESS OUR HOUSING
CRISIS- I WELCOME THIS IDEA I'M
EXCITED TO MOVE THIS BILL
FORWARD. OUT OF COMMITTEE AND
BUT PLEDGE TO WORK WITH YOU AS
IT GOES THROUGH THE PROCESS- AND
YOU KNOW I THINK THERE ARE AYE
AYE HERE I MISS QUIRK-SILVA AS
CONCERNS AROUND THIS WHICH I
THINK WE DO NEED TO ADDRESS IN
TERMS OF IMPLEMENTATION HOW THIS
CAN LOOK BUT CERTAINLY WANT TO
MOVE IT OUT OF COMMITTEE TODAY
SO THAT WE CAN KEEP HAVING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AND SO WITH THAT A
LET YOU CLOSE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
I APPRECIATE THE ROBUST
CONVERSATION ABOUT THIS YOU KNOW
I THINK. THIS SUMMER QUIRK-SILVA
DOES BRING ABOUT CONCERNS ABOUT
IT. AND THIS IS KIND OF THE
GRAND VISION AND I THINK THE
FIRST STEP IN ACHIEVING SOCIAL
HOUSING IS WE HAVE TO CREATE THE
FRAMEWORK FIRST. AND THEN IN THE
LARGER STRATEGY DESCRIBING.
ITSELF TO GO OUT FOR BOND AND
HOPEFULLY GO OUT FOR ALL THESE
OTHER MEASURES TO IT BECAUSE I
THINK THIS IS THE FIRST
COMPREHENSIVE SEVEN I'VE ALWAYS
BEEN VERY TRANSPARENT THERE ONE
THAT I THINK THIS IS THE FIRST.
IN A SERIES OF ORDER OF
OPERATIONS. AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE REPLICATE. NOT
JUST SO WE SEE THE POSTER CHILD
IN VIENNA AND IN EUROPE BUT ALSO
LOOK AT ASIA WHICH WE DO
INCORPORATE SOME OF THESE IN
SINGAPORE AS WELL- BECAUSE THESE
MODELS HAVE EXISTED- JUST AS
LONG AS THE AMERICAN EXPERIMENT
US PUBLIC HOUSING HAS EXISTED IF
NOT LONGER. AND THERE IS A
REASON PARTICULAR REASONS WHY WE
IN THIS COUNTRY FAILED. AND HOW
THAT'S RACISM. AND APART AND WHY
YOU KNOW OTHER PLACES THEY
SUCCEEDED WHICH IS JUST AS LONG.
AND IF WE LEARN FROM OUR
MISTAKES THIS COUNTRY TO MAKE A
SUSTAINABLE TO MAKE THEM
BEAUTIFUL MAKE THE MIXING COMING
NOT CONCENTRATION POVERTY AND
MAKE THEM AS- OPPORTUNITIES FOR
MY FOLKS. AND WE CAN BUILD MORE
HOUSING THAT'S NOT JUST FOR
PROFIT BECAUSE RIGHT NOW. IN OUR
BEST INTENTIONS WE ONLY HAVE TO
RELY ON THE PRIVATE MARKET AS
THE MAJORITY WERE HOUSING AND
THEY ALWAYS DO IT. WITH A PROFIT
MARGIN AND THAT'S JUST THAT'S
JUST NATURE OF THE GAME RIGHT.
BUT IF WE CAN BUILD HOUSING IS A
PUBLIC COULD. AND THAT MONEY
GETS RECYCLED BACK INTO THE
COMMUNITY TO OUR WORKERS ARE
RESIDENTS. THAT'S HOW WE'RE
GONNA CHIEF THIS. AND YOU KNOW
I'VE I THANK YOU FOR INDULGING
ME BRING THESE POSTERS BUT I
ALWAYS LIKE I SAID AT THE
BEGINNING AS I DON'T. LIKE TO
VISUALIZE SUCCESS. WHEN IT COMES
TO HOUSING YOU KNOW SOMETIMES
THINGS CAN LOOK SCARY SEEMS
SCARY AND WE HAVE IDEAS ABOUT
WHAT PROJECTS ARE. BUT THEY'RE
CLEARLY EXAMPLES THAT IN THIS
COUNTRY UNITED STATES OR IN
EUROPE. THEY DO A FINE AGE OF
BEAUTIFUL AND YOU TRAVEL
THOUSANDS OF MILES GO LOOK AT
THEM. AND YOU WANT TO LIVE IN
THEM AND THERE'S NO REASON WE
CAN'T THIS COUNTRY SO. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
TODAY AND THANK THE CHAIR FOR
YOUR WORK ON THE SELECT
COMMITTEE AS WELL. WITHOUT THE
MOTIONS TO PASS THROUGH SOME
LOOKED INTO PREPARATIONS. WICKS
I WEEKS I'D SAY OCTOBER NOTES
HERE TO KNOW CARILLO. I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I KALRA. KALRA AYE KILEY
QUIRKS SILVA. QUIRK-SILVA WARD.
WART BY. THANK YOU. AND THAT
BILL IS OUT.
NEXT WE WILL HAVE MISTER
GALLAGHER COME JOIN US PLEASE.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. YEAH YEAH
WE NEED TO DO MY- THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIRMAN CHAIRWOMAN SARAH
. AND MEMBERS- TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY ONE THIRTY NINE. AND I
WANT TO START OFF BY THINKING-
THE CHAIRWOMAN AND HER STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH ME ON THE
AMENDMENTS TO THIS BILL. AND I
AM ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS. AB TWENTY ONE THIRTY
NINE WOULD HELP STREAMLINE THE
REBUILD PROCESS IN AREAS THAT
HAVE BEEN DEVASTATED BY
DISASTERS LIKE WILDFIRES- THAT
WE'VE EXPERIENCE TOO MUCH HERE
LATELY IN CALIFORNIA- THE
CAMPFIRE AS YOU KNOW IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN DISPLAYS FIFTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE AND DESTROYED ALMOST
TWENTY THOUSAND STRUCTURES. IN
AN EFFORT TO REBUILD THEIR
pCOMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS LIKE
REBUILD PARADISE HAVE CREATED A
RESIDENTIAL FLOOR PLAN LIBRARY
THAT CONTAINS TEMPLATE FLOOR
PLANS THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN
APPROVED BY THE TOWN OF PARADISE
AND BUTTE COUNTY. AND THE
INCORPORATE THE MOST UPDATED
BUILDING CODES- YOU KNOW ADDS
THAT AT THE TIME AND I THINK
THAT'S ONE THING IS REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR PEOPLE TO
UNDERSTAND ABOUT THIS BILL AS
YOU KNOW AS WERE AS WERE
REBUILDING AND AN ENTIRE TOWN-
BECAUSE PARADISE. YOU KNOW THE
ENTIRE COMMUNITY. WHAT I LIKED
OUT WE ARE WE ARE REBUILDING
HEALTHCARE. UP TO THE YOU KNOW
MOST. IN INCLUDING MOVIES
STANDARDS- AND THESE TEMPLATES
HELP ME THAT BUT THE THING IS
THEY ACTUALLY REALLY HAVING
THESE TEMPLATE FLOOR PLANS HELP
SAVE PEOPLE WHO ARE REBUILDING
ANYWHERE FROM 500-021-0000
DOLLARS- IN AN AVERAGE OF SIX
MONTHS OF BUILDING TIME- SO FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE DESPERATE TO GET
BACK INTO A HOME. AND WHO NEED
BEYOND WHO MEN HAVE LIMITED
RESOURCES- YOU KNOW MANY PEOPLE
ARE REALLY STRUGGLING TO PUT
TOGETHER- THE RESOURCES TO
REBUILD AND YOU'VE HEARD SOME OF
THOSE STORIES AS WELL THIS IS
JUST YOU KNOW SOMETHING THAT CAN
REALLY HELP AND IT WAS AN
INNOVATIVE IDEA THAT WAS THAT
WAS BROUGHT FORWARD- BY REBUILD
PARADISE IN YOU'RE GOING TO HEAR
FROM THEM- DURING THIS.
TESTIMONY TODAY- BUT THAT IS BUT
THAT'S BEEN REALLY HELPFUL AND
SO WE WANTED TO JUST PUT THAT IN
THE CODE THAT WE CAN. BE ABLE TO
UTILIZE THESE PLANS- AND THAT WE
KNOW THE BUILDING CODE ALWAYS
GETS UPDATED- AND THE PROBLEM IS
WHEN THAT GETS UPDATED IN THESE
THESE. THESE PLANS WILL BE
OBSOLETE WELL WE'RE GOING TO BE
BUILDING OVER THE NEXT TEN TO
TWENTY YEARS- AND SO HAVING
THESE YOU KNOW AVAILABLE TO
PEOPLE. FOR A LONGER. PERIOD OF
TIME WILL BE REALLY HELPFUL AND
I'D ALSO NOTE THAT. PART OF WHAT
IS BUILT INTO THE INTO THE- THE
BILL WITH THE AMENDMENTS. IS IT
NOW THAT- YOU KNOW LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WOULD HAVE TO. CREATE
A FINDING SAYING THAT THESE ARE
CONSISTENT WITH. SAFETY
STANDARDS AND WOULD NOT IMPACT.
THE SAFETY YOU ABOVE BUT PROVING
THESE PLANTS SO- I'D- REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL OF YOUR HELP IN
MAKING THIS. A GREAT BILL AND I
THINK IT'S GOING TO BE A REALLY
GREAT HELP- TO COMMUNITIES LIKE
PARADISE AND OTHERS THAT HAVE
BEEN DEVASTATED BY WILDFIRE. AND
OTHER NATURAL DISASTERS SO I'D
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. ON AB TWENTY
ONE THIRTY NINE. THANK YOU I'M
CHEN GOOD LINE WITH THE REBUILD
PARADISE FOUNDATION AND GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE- HOPE IS BEING
ABLE TO SEE THAT THERE IS LIGHT
DESPITE ALL OF THE DARKNESS. I
LIVE IN A TRAILER WITH MY FOUR
CHILDREN AND HUSBAND AND PUPPY
IN PARADISE CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE
NO WASHING MACHINE WE HAVE
EXPERIENCED POWER OUTAGES HAVE
HAD MANY COLD NIGHTS TAKEN THREE
MINUTE SHOWERS AND WE HOME
SCHOOL OUR KIDS DURING CODED
JUST LIKE THE REST OF YOU EXCEPT
FOR IN A TRAILER. WE ARE WORRIED
ABOUT THE SAFETY OF OUR WATER IF
WE CAN GET INSURANCE WHO'S GOING
TO BUILD OUR HOUSE AND HOW THE
HECK ARE WE GOING TO PAY FOR IT.
WE'VE SPENT YEARS CLEANING DEAD
TREES AND WEEDS FROM OUR
PROPERTY. WE HAVE EXPERIENCED
EVERY POSSIBLE HURDLE TO
REBUILD. WE ARE NOT ALONE NOW.
THIS IS THE STORY FOR MANY IN
OUR COMMUNITY THOSE WHO LOST
EVERYTHING WORKING TO REBUILD
AND NOT GIVING UP. MY JOB IS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
REBUILD PARADISE FOUNDATION IS
TO ELIMINATE SOME OF THE HURDLES
AND EXPENSES PEOPLE ARE FACING
WHILE ALSO KEEPING OUR COMMUNITY
SAFE. WE HAVE DEVELOPED TWELVE
MASTER FLOOR PLANS AND TO HELP
REDUCE BOTH COST AND TIME FOR
RESIDENTS. OUR PROGRAM HAS BEEN
SO SUCCESSFUL THAT TO NONPROFITS
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY AND HOPE
CRISIS RESPONSE NETWORK ARE
USING THESE PLANS. OVER HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE PERMITS HAVE BEEN
ISSUED FROM THESE MASTER PLANS
WITH MANY OF THOSE HOMES BUILT
TO COMPLETION. ON AVERAGE THIS
IS SAVING PEOPLE FROM SEVEN TO
TWELVE THOUSAND DOLLARS AND SIX
MONTHS OF TIME. CAN YOU IMAGINE
SIX MONTHS LESS LIVING IN A
TRAILER. THE UPCOMING BILLING
CODE WILL BE ANOTHER STRAIN ON
OUR COMMUNITY CAUSING EACH
MASTER PLAN WE HAVE TO BE
UPDATED BY THE DESIGN
PROFESSIONALS THE TOWN OF
PARADISE AND YOU COUNTY. THIS
UPDATE WILL HAVE A RIPPLE EFFECT
NOT ONLY WILL IT TAKE TIME MONEY
AND THE USE OF OUR ALREADY
DEPLETED RESOURCES. BUT THE
UPDATE UPDATES ARE GOING TO ADD
AN ADDITIONAL COSTS FOR THOSE
WHO ARE ALREADY SCRAPING PENNIES
TOGETHER TO REBUILD. I DO VALUE
BUILDING CODE UPDATES AND
KEEPING UP WITH INDUSTRY
STANDARDS BUT THERE IS NOTHING
IN THIS UPCOMING COULD CYCLE TO
SAY THAT A HOUSE BILL THIS YEAR
WILL BE ANY LESS SAFE AND ONE
NEXT YEAR. IT WILL JUST BE MORE
EXPENSIVE. STUDIES ALSO SHOW
THAT MEDITATION AROUND HOME
PLATE THE BIGGEST. IMPACT ON THE
SURVIVAL IN A FIRE. AND IF
SAFETY WAS TRULY CONCERNED. THEN
MANUFACTURED HOMES WHICH MAKE UP
ABOUT A THIRD OF OUR REBUILDS
SHOULD HAVE TO LIVE UP TO THE
SAME SAFETY STANDARDS. WE HAVE
HAD THE STATE'S LARGEST AND MOST
DESTRUCTIVE WILDFIRE. FOLLOWED
BY COVE IN NINETEEN AND SOARING
BUILDING CRISIS. THIS IS NOT
JUST ABOUT OUR COMMUNITY OR
KEEPING OUR FOUNDATIONS PLANTS
THIS ISN'T EVEN JUST ABOUT
PARADISE. THIS IS ABOUT OUR
COUNTY AND STATE HAVING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. WINDY YOU
STATED THAT YOU DON'T HAVE A
LAND WHERE YOU LIVE GUESS WHERE
THERE'S LOTS OF LAND TO BUILD IN
PARADISE. SO MUCH OPPORTUNITY
THERE. ONE LESS HURDLE ONE AT
LESS EXPENSE IS ALL THAT PEOPLE
NEED TO COME HOME PLEASE SUPPORT
AB TWO ONE. THREE NINE THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. A GOOD
MORNING MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I AM
AMY ROAR IN THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AT VALLEY CONTRACTORS
EXCHANGE I AM ALSO ONE OF THE CO
CHAIRS AT THE CAMPFIRE LONG TERM
RECOVERY GROUPS HOUSING
COMMITTEE. I ALSO SIT ON THE
NORTH COMPLEX FIRE CONSTRUCTION
TASK FORCE- ON IN ADDITION TO
ALL THAT MY HUSBAND AND I OWN.
RESIDENTIAL CONSTRUCTION COMPANY
WE LOST OUR HOME THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN CAMPFIRE AND WE'RE
CURRENTLY GETTING SET TO BREAK
GROUND ON OUR FIFTH CAN'T THEIR
REBUILD- FOURTEEN THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED AND FORTY THREE HOMES
WERE LOST IN THE CAMPFIRE.
FIFTEEN HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE
ADDITIONAL WERE LOST TWENTY TWO
NORTH COMPLEX FIRES THAT'S
NEARLY SIXTEEN THOUSAND HOMES IN
TWO YEARS. THREE AND A HALF
YEARS LATER HAVE TO THE CAMPFIRE
BETWEEN BOTH BUYERS TWO THOUSAND
NINE HUNDRED NINETY THREE
BUILDING PERMITS HAVE BEEN
ISSUED WITH NINETEEN HUNDRED AND
NINE OF THOSE HOMES COMPLETED
IT'S BEEN WELL OVER THREE AND A
HALF YEARS AND ONLY 12% OF OUR
HOMES HAVE BEEN REBUILT. IN
CALIFORNIA WE LIKE TO USE THE
TERM AFFORDABLE HOUSING THE
REALITY IS NEW CONSTRUCTION
CALIFORNIA ISN'T AFFORDABLE. LET
ME GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE. HIGHLIFE
HIGHLAND HOMES IS A NATIONAL
HOMEBUILDER SPECIALIZING IN
STICK BUILT CONSTRUCTION IN THE
NORTHWEST. ONE OF THE FOURTH
PLANS THEY OFFER IS A MODEST
TWELVE HUNDRED FORTY EIGHT
SQUARE FOOT HOME. THE WASHINGTON
IT WILL COST YOU A HUNDRED FORTY
NINE DOLLARS PER SQUARE FOOT TO
CONSTRUCT BACK HOME. IN IDAHO
THE COST IS A HUNDRED AND SIXTY
FOUR PER SQUARE FOOT. AN OREGON
UNDER THE SEVENTY NINE AND
CALIFORNIA THAT SAME HOME COST
TWO HUNDRED TWENTY ONE DOLLARS A
SQUARE FOOT TO CONSTRUCT. IT
COSTS AT LEAST NINETY ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS MORE TO BUILD A
MODEST SIZE HOME WITH THE SAME
ENTRY LEVEL FINISHES IN
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE OF OUR
BUILDING CODES. WE LIKE TO USE
THE TERM ELECTRIFICATION
CALIFORNIA'S WELL IN IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY TO ENERGY CODES
ARE CERTAINLY PUSHING TOWARDS
THAT. AND YOU COUNTY
PARTICULARLY WHEN YOUR
REBUILDING A HOME FOR CAMPFIRE
SURVIVOR. YOU CAN IMAGINE HOW
TOTAL DEPENDENCY ON THE GRID IN
PG&E HAS RECEIVED. MANY WANTING
TO REBUILD THE SAME OR VERY
SIMILAR TO WHAT THEY HAD BEFORE
THE FIRE. MANY PREFERRED. PER
FOR GAS APPLIANCES. TO DO THIS
UNDER THE TWENTY TWENTY TWO
CODES THEY WOULD NEED TO BUILD
AS IF THEY WERE INSTALLING
ELECTRIC APPLIANCES. IT'S MEANS
NOT ONLY PULLING THE WIRE AND
INSTALLING TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
FOUR. A TWO HUNDRED TWENTY WILL
CONDUCT. CONDUCT CIRCUIT SORRY.
BUT ALSO UPGRADING A HUNDRED AMP
PANEL TO A TWO HUNDRED AMP PANEL
WHICH ADDS SIGNIFICANT COSTS.
REBUILDING A RULE AFFECTED
COMMUNITIES. ALREADY HAS MANY
COST BARRIERS INCLUDING REMOVAL
OF BURNT TREES REPLACEMENT OF
WELLS AND SEPTIC SYSTEMS. AND
ENGINEERED FOUNDATIONS BEFORE WE
CAN EVEN GET OUT OF THE GROUND.
FOR MANY PRE APPROVED MASTER
PLAN SO THE ONLY WAY THEY CAN
AFFORD TO REBUILD. THE TOWN OF
PARADISE HAS SIXTY FIVE APPROVED
MASTER PLANS WITH NINE MORE
CURRENTLY IN PLAN REVIEW. IT'S
NOT ONLY THE COST TO UPDATE. AND
CALIFORNIA'S BUILDING CODES ARE
ALREADY THE SAFEST MOST ENERGY
CONSCIOUS IN THE UNITED STATES
BY FAR. PLEASE ALLOW AB TWENTY
ONE THIRTY NINE TO MOVE FORWARD
AND BECOME LAW. FOR MANY THESE
EXCEPTIONS WILL BE THE ONLY WAY
THEY CAN AFFORD TO REBUILD AND
RETURN HOME. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHER FOLKS IN THE ROOM WOULD
LIKE TO REGISTER. SUPPORT FOR.
A. B. TWENTY ONE THIRTY NINE.
OPERATOR ON THE PHONE ARE THERE
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO
WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER SUPPORT
FOR A BI TWENTY ONE THIRTY NINE
AGAIN NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION PLEASE. HURNEY
WITNESSES FOR THAT. YOU CAN
SPEAK UP AT THIS TIME. OKAY. MY
NAME KERN FOR NUMBER EIGHT. AND
NINE OUNCE OF PORK. NINETEEN
SIXTY ONE FORMER OUR RESIDENTS
CAN MANAGE NETWORK. OF FISHING
THANK YOU. I THINK THAT THAT'S
THE WRONG WORD CURRENTLY WHAT DO
YOU NINE. OKAY IT'S PRETTY
PEOPLE OUT ON THE PHONES IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO UP PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND AGAIN
THIS IS FOR AB TWENTY ONE THIRTY
NINE. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
WE'RE LINE ONE TEN. GOOD MORNING
I'M CHAIR AND MEMBERS MEGAN ALL
RIGHT ON BEHALF OF THE
SACRAMENTO REGIONAL BUILDERS
EXCHANGE IN CALIFORNIA BUILDERS
LANES IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU WILL
GO TO LINE ONE FIFTEEN. GRAYSON
SHOWING ONE FIFTEEN NOW PACKAGE
BUT REMEMBER ENOUGH NINE ONE
FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IT
WILL BE HARDER TO OUR- ALREADY
BELIEVE AMOUNTS FOR. AND SUPPORT. THE REQUESTED PART NOT. WHAT
WILL THE MARKET WHERE. BRAND
THERE ARE NO IN KEY. THANK YOU
WE WILL NOW BE IT BACK TO THE
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
IN THE ROOM ARE THERE ANY
IN THE ROOM. ANYONE IN THERE
WOULD LIKE TO ADD ON IN
OPPOSITION. AND OPERATORS THERE
ANY ARE THERE ANY FOLKS ON THE
CALL FROM THE PUBLIC WHO WOULD
LIKE TO REGISTER OPPOSITION. TO
AB TWENTY ONE THIRTY NINE. AND
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AGAIN Q.
FOR THAT. THERE'S NO ONE IN
QUEUE FOR THAT AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU WE WILL BRING IT BACK
NOW TO THE ROOM ANY QUESTIONS
FROM COLLEAGUES MISTER SEYARTO.
ESCHER'S IS COMMENT THANK YOU-
MR GALLAGHER FOR HELPING. FOLKS
RECOVER. FROM A DISASTER THERE'S
NOTHING WORSE THAN. HAVING A
HOUSE BURNED DOWN OR YOUR ENTIRE
TOWN BURNED DOWN AND- THEN
HAVING YOU WANNA REBUILD. BUT
YOU GET STUCK IN THE MORASS OF
REGULATORY THINGS THAT WE'VE
CREATED THAT IS CAUSING ARE
HOMELESS ARE NOT ARE HOMELESS
BUT OUR- AFFORDABLE HOUSING
CRISIS BECAUSE IT'S A SUPPLY AND
DEMAND PROBLEM AND WE ARE
WOEFULLY INADEQUATE IN THE
SUPPLY SIDE AND NOW WE'VE TAKEN
PEOPLE WHO HAD SUPPLY TAKING
THEM OUT AND WE'RE GONNA MAKE
THEM GO THROUGH THAT SAME
PROCESS THAT HAS CREATED. THE
DISASTER THAT IS CALIFORNIA
HOUSING AND- ASIDE FROM ENSURING
THAT. MAYBE WHEN IT THINGS A
REBUILT- THAT. IT HAS MORE
PROTECTIONS FROM BURNING DOWN
AGAIN- YOU KNOW PEOPLE NEED TO
BE ABLE DATE TO GET BACK INTO
WHAT THEY HAD AND IT'S NOT FAIR
FOR US IN A YOU KNOW THE
GOVERNMENT TO IMPOSE REGULATIONS
ON PEOPLE. WHEN THE WHEN THEY
ALREADY HAD A HOUSE WHEN THEY
WERE ALREADY LIVING THE WAY THEY
WERE GOING TO LIVE AND- AND- IT
YOU KNOW LIKE I SAID ASIDE FROM
HAVING A FIRE COME THROUGH
AGAIN- MAYBE YOU KNOW SOME HOME
HARDENING IN AND CLEARANCE-
BEING ADDED IN THE REST OF THE
REGULATIONS NEED TO BE SET
ASIDE- SO THAT PEOPLE CAN REGAIN
WHAT THEY HAD BEFORE THEY
STARTED. AND SO I APPLAUD THE
EFFORTS ON YOUR PART TO HELP
PEOPLE GET THROUGH THAT SO ARE
THERE NOT MORE CONTRIBUTORS TO
THIS. HOUSING CRISIS THAT WE
HAVE IN CALIFORNIA. THANK THANK
YOU MISTER SERTOMA ESTHER WARD
THE COMBINATION ON ON THIS WORK-
PARTICULARLY AS IT- YOU KNOW
HAS- SO- HORRIBLY AFFECTED YOUR
COMMUNITIES AND YOUR DISTRICT-
BIG FAN GENERALLY OF USING
TEMPLATE OPPORTUNITIES FOR A
VARIETY OF HOUSING SOLUTIONS SO-
IT MAKES ALL THE SENSE IN THE
WORLD THAT IT COULD BE APPLIED
HERE- AND- I WOULD ALSO- HOPE
THAT YOU'RE GIVEN THE STATE OF
WHAT. IS GOING THROUGH WITH
REBUILDING RIGHT NOW IF THERE'S
AN OPPORTUNITY THAT URGENCY
COULD BE OUT OF HERE SO MAYBE
YOU CAN EVEN GET IT GOING A
LITTLE BIT AHEAD OF JANUARY ONE-
CERTAINLY CAN BE VERY SUPPORTIVE
OF THAT HAPPY TO LET MY NAME IS
A CO AUTHOR IF IT HELPS IN
ANYWAY- BUT JUST THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR THE WORK. IT IS A MEMBER. OF
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. WELL I ALSO
WANT TO APPLAUD THE AUTHOR FOR
THIS BILL I KNOW YOU'VE DONE A
LOT OF WORK IN THE SPACE AND-
ARE A FIERCE ADVOCATE FOR
REPAIRING PARADISE IN AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE- YOU KNOW I COME FROM A
SMALL TOWN IN THE MOUNTAINS AND
THERE'S ONE ROAD IN AND ONE ROAD
OUT AND- IT'S IN THE MIDDLE OF A
PRETTY HIGH- DANGERS ON FOR
FIRES- AND SO IN PARADISE
HAPPENS YOU KNOW I THINK A LOT
OF US FROM SMALL COMMUNITIES
THOUGHT THAT COULD HAVE BEEN US-
SO. SHOULD YOU WORK IN THE SPACE
MORE BROADLY I'D ALSO LOVE TO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR AND WOULD
WANT TO BE HELPFUL IN ANY WAY
SHAPE I CAN TO MOVE THE BILL
FORWARD THROUGHOUT THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS AND I'M
HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL OUT OF
COMMITTEE TODAY. AND WE HAVE A
MOTION. OKAY AND SECOND GRADE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE- YEAH
THANK YOU AND THAT WOULD
ABSOLUTELY LOVE TO ADD YOU GUYS
IS SAYS CO AUTHORS- WHOEVER
WOULD. WOULD WANT TO BE- TEN
YEAH I THINK THIS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT AND- I ALSO WANTED TO
POINT OUT THAT IS A MEMBER
CARILLO- WAS ONE THAT CAME UP TO
PARADISE YOU KNOW. AFTERWARDS
AND SAW. THE YOU KNOW THE
DESTRUCTION AND IT'S AMAZING
WHAT WE'RE SEEING NOW TODAY IS
LIKE IS PEOPLE REBUILDING IN.
AND COMING BACK BECAUSE I THINK
IT WAS SAID WERE. WERE SOMEWHERE
AROUND THE NINETEEN HUNDRED
HOMES NOW- YEAH. THAT HAVE NOW
BEEN REBUILT- SO THERE'S A LOT
OF HOPE GOING ON A PARADISE AND
THAT'S YOU KNOW AND I THINK. I'M
HOPEFUL THIS IS SOMETHING WE CAN
EVEN EXPAND AND TAKE OUT
EVENTUALLY TO WHERE WE CAN
PROVIDE THIS BECAUSE AGAIN IT'S
- WE WANT TO MAKE SURE AND I
WANT TO REITERATE THAT WE ARE.
THIS IS BUILT UP TO THE LATEST
WILL BE CODES. AND ENSURING
PROTECTION FOR THOSE THOSE
COMMUNITIES- BUT I THINK
PROVIDING THIS TEMPLATE JUST
GIVE IT IT STREAMLINES A LOT OF
COST AND TIME. AND THAT'S REALLY
HELPFUL AS WE'RE TRYING TO SOLVE
THE HOUSING CRISIS AND TRYING TO
HELP COMMUNITIES LIKE PARADISE
RECOVER SO THANK YOU FOR ALL OF
YOUR HELP MADAM CHAIR AND WILL
CONTINUE TO. TO WORK ON THIS AND
MANY OTHER ITEMS THANK YOU THANK
YOU RANDY AND MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED. WICKS HI WICKS I
SEYARTO C. R. DI KOREA. KOREA I
GABRIEL. HI GABRIEL I KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY. QUIRK-SILVA
WARD. I AND THAT BILL IS OUT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NOW WE HAVE
MISTER BLOOM WHO HAS TWO BILLS
IN FRONT OF US WHEN WE START
WITH AB TWENTY TWO NINETY FIVE
IS THAT RIGHT. YES. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS AND- OF
COURSE MANAGER WANT TO THANK-
YOUR STAFF FOR- THE- TYPICAL
HIGH QUALITY OF THEIR WORK ON
THE BILL AND- I WILL BE
ACCEPTING ALL OF THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS THIS MORNING.
CALIFORNIA'S AFFORDABLE HOUSING
CRISIS IS EXACERBATING ANOTHER
URGENT CRISIS TEACHER SHORTAGES
RECENT DATA SHOWS THAT ONE IN
TEN SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE LOSING-
A QUARTER OF THEIR TEACHERS.
SKYROCKETING HOUSING PRICES AND
STAGNANT SALARIES OF MADE IT
MORE DIFFICULT FOR TEACHERS TO
LIVE IN THE COMMUNITIES IN WHICH
THEY TEACH FURTHERMORE TEACHER
SALARIES OFTEN HOVER ABOVE THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR LOW INCOME
HOUSING MAKING THEM UNQUALIFIED
FOR SUBSIDIZED HOUSING BUT- AT
THE SAME TIME UNABLE TO COMPETE
FOR MARKET RATE APARTMENTS. WE
CAN DO BETTER. FORTY SIX OF THE
LARGEST SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE EXPRESSED
INTEREST IN BUILDING EDUCATIONAL
WORKFORCE HOUSING TO ADDRESS
TEACHER SHORTAGES AND RETAIN
STAFF AND I BELIEVE YOU'RE GOING
TO HEAR AN ARM AND A MOMENT THAT
THAT NUMBER IS ACTUALLY GROWN
SIGNIFICANTLY UNFORTUNATELY
LOCAL RESISTANCE COMPLICATED
BUREAUCRATIC PROCESSES AND
RESTRICTIVE ZONING HAVE ADDED
CHALLENGES TO HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION ON DISTRICT OWNED
PROPERTIES THAT ARE OTHERWISE
GOING UNUTILIZED. ONLY ARE UNDER
UTILIZED AND ONLY TWO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS SANTA CLARA UNIFIED IN
LA UNIFIED HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
SUCCESSFULLY BUILD HOUSING
PROJECTS ON PROPERTIES THAT THEY
OWN IN SPITE OF THIS INTENSE
INTEREST IN DOING SO. BOTH
DISTRICTS REPORTED STRONG
INTEREST IN THESE UNITS BY BOTH
TEACHERS AND STAFF BUT ALSO
REPORTED CHALLENGES AND DELAYS
IN GETTING THEIR PROJECTS OFF
THE GROUND AB TWENTY TWO NINETY
FIVE WILL MOVE THE BARRIERS THAT
HAVE HINDERED HOUSING PRODUCTION
FOR TEACHERS. AND I AM THE ON
THE SITES THE MEASURE WOULD MAKE
HOUSING AND ALLOW- USED
ALLOWABLE USE ON PROPERTIES
SCHOOL DISTRICTS OWN IF THE
PROJECTS MEET CERTAIN OBJECTIVE
STANDARDS. AB TWENTY TWO NINETY
FIVE REQUIRE SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
PRIORITIZE TEACHERS AND SCHOOL
STAFF FOR THESE UNITS AND
ENSURES THAT THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WILL RETAIN THE
PROPERTY. BY EASING THE
ADMINISTRATIVE AND BUREAUCRATIC
HURDLES AB TWENTY TWO NINETY
FIVE WILL HELP SCHOOL DISTRICTS
CONSTRUCT ENOUGH HOUSING TO MEET
THE CURRENT DEMAND ADDRESS
TEACHING SHORTAGES AND HELP KEEP
QUALITY TEACHERS AND STAFF IN
THE CLASSROOM. IT'S A TRUE
TRIPLE WIN WITH ME TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT TODAY IS DANA CUFF WHO
IS THE DIRECTOR OF CITY LAB AT
UCLA GO BRUINS. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY IN BLOOM- AND THANK YOU
TO THE COMMITTEE AND YOUR STAFFS
FOR ALL THE HELP THEY'VE GIVEN
US AS WE SHAPE THIS BILL. I'M
I'M A PROFESSOR OF ARCHITECTURE
AND URBAN PLANNING AT UCLA AND
I'M ALSO THE DIRECTOR OF THE
DESIGN RESEARCH CENTER CALLED
CITY LAB. IT'S IN COLLABORATION
WITH OUR COLLEAGUES UP AT
BERKELEY AND THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL BOARDS ASSOCIATION WITH
ITS ONE THOUSAND DISTRICTS THAT
WE HAVE. BEEN STUDYING THE NEED
FOR EDUCATION WORKFORCE HOUSING
FOR THE LAST THREE YEARS. ON A
PERSONAL NOTE I JUST WANT TO SAY
I'M A PRODUCT OF CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC SCHOOLS FROM KINDERGARTEN
THROUGH MY PHD. AND I FEEL REAL
COMMITMENT TO TRYING TO MAKE
SURE OUR TEACHERS AND CAFETERIA
WORKERS JANITORS ARE WELL HOUSE
WHEN THEY'RE SERVING THE FUTURE
OF THE STATE. I AM SURE ALL DAY
YOU HEAR. MORE AND MORE
STATISTICS ABOUT THE HOUSING
CRISIS BUT LET ME ADD ONE MORE.
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PRICES WENT UP TWELVE
POINT THREE PERCENT. ALMOST
DOUBLE THAT RIGHT HERE IN
SACRAMENTO WHICH IS SIMILAR TO
OTHER SMALL METRO AREAS. BUT
TEACHERS SALARIES BY CONTRAST
WENT UP ONE POINT SIX PERCENT.
THIS MEANS THAT THEY ARE
INCREASINGLY UNABLE TO AFFORD
THE HOUSING THEY NEED TO SERVE
THEIR DISTRICTS AND TO LIVE NEAR
THEIR STUDENTS AND FAMILIES AND
JOBS- THE RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION THEN IS AN
INCREASINGLY SERIOUS PROBLEM
WITH 75% OF CALIFORNIA DISTRICTS
REPORTING PROBLEMS WITH
RECRUITMENT. ONE OF THE MOST
COMMON REASONS THAT CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS- GIVE FOR LEAVING OUR
STATE IS THE HIGH COST OF
HOUSING AND THIS IS PARTICULARLY
TRUE FOR ENTRY LEVEL TEACHERS
AND IF IT'S TRUE FOR ENTRY LEVEL
TEACHERS. YOU CAN IMAGINE HOW
UNATTAINABLE HOUSING IS FOR THE
CLASSIFIED STAFF WHO KEEP OUR
SCHOOLS RUNNING JANITORS AIDES
SECRETARIES AND CAFETERIA
WORKERS. IN OUR RESEARCH WE
FOUND THAT THERE ARE ELEVEN
THOUSAND ALMOST DISTRICT OWNED
PROPERTIES. THAT'S UP A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND ACRES AND
EIGHTY THOUSAND OF THOSE ARE
ACTUALLY POTENTIALLY DEVELOPER
WILL LANDS- THAT'S TE SIZE OF
SIX MANHATTAN'S AND WHEN WE LOOK
FOR SPACE FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. THAT'S THE IMPORTANT
RESOURCE THAT WE SHOULD BE
TAKING INTO CONSIDERATION. AS
ASSEMBLYMAN BLOOM SAID WILL BE
TO DISTRICTS HAVE MANAGED TO DO
THIS THUS FAR THEY BUILT FOR
DEVELOPMENTS ALL TOGETHER THREE
IN LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND ONE IN SANTA CLARA.
AND ALL OF THOSE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS HAVE WAITING LISTS
THERE TWO MORE UNDER WAY AT
BERKELEY AND SAN JOSE. JUST THIS
PAST WEEK AS WE'VE BEEN
ORGANIZING OUT OF OUR BERKELEY
AND UCLA CENTERS. OF THE
WORKSHOPS TO TRAIN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS HOW TO BUILD THESE WE
RECEIVED. FIFTY ENQUIRIES WHEN
WE WERE HOPING FOR FIVE SO
THERE'S NEW DEMAND FOR THIS
THAT'S REALLY OVERWHELMING AND-
A LOT OF THIS COMES FROM THE
FACT. THAT IT TAKES SEVEN TO
NINE YEARS TO MOVE THROUGH THE
DEVELOPMENT PROCESS THAT'S UP
THREE SEPARATE SCHOOL BOARDS
GIVEN THE TERMS THAT THEY SERVE.
I'M FORTY SIX DISTRICTS HAVE
TRIED TO BUILD THIS KIND OF
HOUSING. OKAY I'M AND HAVE NOT
YET BEEN SUCCESSFUL- AND SO THE
AB TWENTY TWO NINETY FIVE WILL
REMOVE THE BARRIERS WHILE
KEEPING LOCAL OBJECTIVE PLANNING
REVIEW AND TO COULD CUT THE TIME
LINE VIRTUALLY IN HALF- UP
WE'VE- WILL ALLOW BY PERMITS
HOUSING ON ALL SCHOOL OWNED
PROPERTY. AND OTHER TIME
CONSUMING AND COMPLICATED
PROCESS SEES WILL BE REMOVED 20%
OF THE HOUSING WOULD BE
AFFORDABLE AT MODERATE LEVELS
30% AT LOW INCOME LEVELS- AND IT
COULD EXCEED THAT AS DISTRICTS
CHOOSE WITH FIFTY FIVE YEARS
GUARANTEED AFFORDABILITY. WITH
THIS HOUSING CALIFORNIA'S
EDUCATION STAFF AND CALIFORNIA'S
CHILDREN BASICALLY OUR FUTURE
WILL BE STABILIZE AND QUALITY
EDUCATION BETTER IN CHURCH THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
OTHER WITNESSES PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. OKAY LET'S
COME TO THE ROOM HERE- IF YOU'D
LIKE TO ADD ON IN SUPPORT NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION PLEASE.
ALI SAPER MEN HOUSING ACTION
COALITION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. MICHELENA SPRINT
STRONG SUPPORT. BOB MILLER
FIELDS SAID COMPANY STRONG
SUPPORT. ALLEN J. CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL HOUSING
FINANCE AGENCY SUPPORT. SUCH A
**** WHICH LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AND NOW- OF OPERATOR
ANY FOLKS LIKE TO ADD ON ON THE
PHONE LINES FROM THE PUBLIC IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY TWO NINETY
FIVE. NAME ORGANIZATION POSITION
PLEASE. IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THIS LEGISLATION
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO. BUT
IS UNSURE AT THIS TIME. I'M
SORRY ONE MOMENT PLEASE SURE.
ONCE YOU KNOW ONCE. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS CHRIS
REFORM BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL BOARDS ASSOCIATION WITH A
LIBERAL BETWEEN HER WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE AMENDED- HAVE BEEN
WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE AUTHOR
AND THE SPONSORS HAVE MADE QUITE
A PROGRESS AND OUR LOVE THE
TRAJECTORY OF THE BILL- AND LOOK
FOR TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR- AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
KNOW OTHER THAN Q. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE ROOM A PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. ANY PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. OKAY I
ANYONE ELSE LIKE TO ADD ON IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU JUST A
MOMENT I'M SORRY I WASN'T QUITE
SURE WHEN THEY COME UP HERE-
JEREMY SMITH YOUR BEHALF OF THE
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL- WITH THE
DESCRIPTION OF THE AMENDMENTS IN
THE ANALYSIS THAT THE ASSEMBLY
MEN TOOK TODAY- WE LOOK WE LOOK
FORWARD TO TAKING A LOOK AT
THOSE WHEN THEY'RE PRINT AND
HOPEFULLY REMOVING OPPOSITION
WILL TAKE A LOOK AT AFTER THAT
THOUGH. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
FOLKS IN THE ROOM IN OPPOSITION
. AN OPERATOR ANY MEMBERS FROM
THE PUBLIC WOULD LIKE TO
REGISTER OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY
TWO NINETY FIVE JUST NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION PLEASE
. I'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. NO ORDERS IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME PLEASE
CONTINUE THANK YOU AND WE WILL
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COLLEAGUES MISS CARILLO. THANK
YOU- AS A FELLOW TROJAN I WILL
BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY.
MR GABRIEL THAT BERKELEY IS THE
BEST- THEY AND I KNOW THAT THE
AUTHOR AGREES WITH THAT- I JUST
WANT TO THANK YOU SOME A MEMBER
BLOOM I THINK AS WE HAD
DISCUSSED I HAD A BONUS IN
TWENTY TWENTY AB THIRTY THREE OH
EIGHT- WANTED TO HAVE ONE
CONVERSATION WITH YOU MAYBE AS
THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD ABOUT
SOME OF THE PROVISIONS BUT IN
GENERAL I THINK IT'S- YOU KNOW
SUCH AN IMPORTANT EFFORT RIGHT
IN THAT WE YOU KNOW GIVE. GIVE
THIS OPPORTUNITY FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION TO USE THEIR LAND IN A
WAY THAT IS PRODUCTIVE AND
HELPFUL- YOU KNOW IT WE HAVE
TALKED A LOT ABOUT HOW WE NEED
AND ALL OF THE ABOVE SOLUTION
AND WE HAVE TO LOOK AT EVERY UP
POSSIBLE OPPORTUNITY AND I THINK
THIS IS FITS SQUARELY WITHIN NOT
SO I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR BEING
A BILL FOR HAPPY TO SUPPORT DAY
AND LOOK FOR TO TALKING WITH YOU
ABOUT IT. THANK YOU MR GABRIEL.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. DO WE HAVE A
MOTION. SOME OF THE SECOND. WELL
YEAH GREAT SURE MR GABRIEL OKAY
- I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD FOR
WORKING WITH UR STAFF FOR
MAKING THIS BILL STRONG
APPRECIATE YOUR LEADERSHIP IN
THE SPACE IT'S OBVIOUSLY I THINK
TOUCH ON A CRITICAL ISSUE I'M
MORE THAN HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL
OUT OF COMMITTEE TODAY- SENSIBLY
THE MOTION SECOND AND WITH THAT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR ABBOTT
THANK YOU. GREAT THANK YOU AND
THE BILL IS THE MOTION IS. YOU
PASSAGE. DO PASSES AMENDED TO
LOCAL GOV. WICKS I MEAN I ARE
DON'T KNOW THEIR TO KNOW
CARILLO. I GABRIEL HI GABRIEL I
KALRA COLOR I KILEY QUIRK-SILVA
WARD. WHAT BY. THAT BILLS OUT
AND FEEL LIKE TO GO TO YOUR NEXT
BILL THANK YOU AB TWENTY TWO
THIRTY NINE EXACTLY CURRENT LAW
REQUIRES- THAT JURISDICTION'S
IDENTIFY AT LEAST ONE'S OWN
WITHIN THEIR HOUSING ELEMENT
WHERE EMERGENCY SHELTERS ARE
PERMITTED BY RIGHT. THE LAW
HOWEVER DOES NOT REQUIRE THE
JURISDICTION TO DEMONSTRATE
SITES WITHIN THAT ZONE ARE
SUITABLE AND AVAILABLE FOR
SHELTER DEVELOPMENT OR HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO MEET THE NEED. AND
THE RESULT IS THAT MANY
JURISDICTIONS ARE NOT ADEQUATELY
PLANNING FOR SHELTERS OR OTHER
INTERIM HOUSING AND EVEN
CREATING BARRIERS TO THE
DEVELOPMENT OF EMERGENCY
SHELTERS FOR THOSE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. IN ADDITION
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES THAT IF A
JURISDICTION FAILED TO REZONE
ENOUGH LAND TO MEET ITS RAINY AT
ALL INCOME LEVELS DURING THE
PRIOR HOUSING ELEMENT PERIOD IT
MUST MAKE UP THIS ONLY SHORTFALL
IN ITS SUBSEQUENT HOUSING
ELEMENT. THE SITE'S REZONED TO
MAKE UP THE SHORTFALL FROM THE
PRIOR HOUSING ELEMENT ARE KNOWN
AS CARRY OVER SITES. THERE IS
SOME AMBIGUITY IN THE LAW AS TO
WHETHER THE STATE'S NO NET LOSS
ZONING LAW APPLIES TO BOTH CARRY
OVER SITES AND SITES TO MEET THE
CURRENT RENO OBLIGATION. AS A
RESULT SOME LOCALITIES MAY NOT
COMPLY WITH THE OBLIGATION TO
REPLACE CARRY OVER SITES THAT
ARE DEVELOPED WITHOUT HOUSING
FOR LOWER INCOME HOUSEHOLDS.
FURTHER CONSTRAINING THE SUPPLY
BADLY NEEDED SITES FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. AB TWENTY
THREE THIRTY NINE WOULD
STRENGTHEN HOUSING ELEMENT LAW
TO ENSURE THAT ZONES IDENTIFIED
AS LOCATIONS WHERE SHELTERS AND
OTHER INTERIM HOUSING SOLUTIONS
CAN BE BUILT BY RIGHT. ARE
SUITABLE- AT AVAILABLE AND
SUFFICIENT TO ADDRESS THE NEED
FOR THOSE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. FINALLY THE BILL
WOULD CLARIFY THAT NO NET LOSS
LAW APPLIES TO BOTH CARRY OVER
SITES AND SITES IDENTIFIED TO
MEET THE CURRENT RAIN. THIS BILL
HAS NO OPPOSITION AND WITH ME
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT TODAY IS
ON THE LAWLER REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION AND THE
PUBLIC INTEREST LAW PROJECT.
GOOD MORNING MY NUMBER IS ON THE
ALERT AGAIN ON BEHALF OF THE
PUBLIC INTEREST LAW PROJECT IN
THE CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION TO THE
SPONSORS OF THE BILL- I THINK MR
BLOOM COVERED IT WELL- WE LONG
HAD A REQUIREMENT THAT. CITIES
AND COUNTIES HAVE ZONE AS A ZONE
OR ZONES WHERE MARGINS THE
SHELTERS LIBRARY NAVIGATION
SOLDIERS AND OTHER INTERIM
HAVING USES CAN LOCATE BY RIGHT-
AND FRANKLY MOST RESTRICTIONS
ACTUALLY DO A PRETTY GOOD JOB OF
COMPLYING WITH THIS LAW HOWEVER.
THERE IS A SUBSET OF- IN
JURISDICTIONS THAT HAVE
DESIGNATED SITES WHERE SOLDIERS
CAN LOCATE BY RIGHT WHERE THERE
ARE ABSOLUTELY NO SITES THAT ARE
ADEQUATE OR AVAILABLE OR
APPROPRIATE FOR LOOKING
EMERGENCY SHELTER WHICH IS NOT
REALLY COMPLYING WITH THE SPIRIT
OF THE LAW WHICH IS REALLY
INTENDED TO CREATE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR SHELTER DEVELOPMENT. FOR
EXAMPLE DESIGNATED DESIGNATING A
HEAVY INDUSTRIAL ZONE AS A PLACE
FOR A SHELTER WHICH IS NOT
APPROPRIATE- FOR HUMAN
HABITATION FRANKLY SO WE'RE
REALLY JUST TRYING TO ADD A
LITTLE BIT MORE TEETH A LOT OF
MAKE SURE WE GET ACTUAL SITES
WHERE SOLDIERS CAN LOCATE- SO
THAT WE CAN CREATE THESE IN TERM
HOUSING SOLUTIONS THAT I THINK
WE- ALL KNOW WE DESPERATELY NEED
AND WITH THAT WE ARE TRY VOTE.
THANK VERY MUCH AND THE OTHER
FOLKS IN THE ROOM LIKE TO
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT. FOR AB
TWENTY TWO THIRTY NINE. OPERATOR
COMING OUT OF THE PHONE LINES
FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY
THREE THIRTY NINE NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION. THANK
YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. MOMENT
PLEASE. TO ONCE AGAIN IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND HERE AT THIS TIME
. WE HAVE ONE PERSON ONE MOMENT. NINE ONE TWENTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN.
HAMMAMET NINE ONE TWENTY. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NINE ONE TWENTY
YOURLINE IS OPEN. AT THE ON
BEHALF OF WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY WHERE PROUD CO
SPONSOR THAT MEASURE AND- CAN I
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU NO
OTHER STE AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU KNOW ANY M. WITH THE PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IN THE
ROOM. ANYONE ELSE IN THE ROOM
WOULD LIKE TO ADD ON. IN TERMS
OF OPPOSITION. OPERATOR DO WE
HAVE ANY FOLKS ON THE PHONE FROM
THE GENERAL PUBLIC COULD LIKE TO
ADD ON IN OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY TWO THIRTY NINE NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ONLY.
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. THERE ARE NONE IN Q.
PLEASE CONTINUE GREAT WE'LL TAKE
IT BACK HERE TO COMMITTEE- ANY
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES.
OKAY DO WE HAVE A MOTION. AND A
SECOND OKAY WE DO WE ARE DID YOU
OKAY. AND THE MOTION IS THE- TO
PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN
LOCAL GOVERNMENT GREAT- WEEKS
FIVE WEEKS I SAY OCTOBER SAY ARE
NO CARILLO. CARILLO I'D GABRIEL
FIVE APRIL AYE KALRA. KILEY
RICHARD BELL QUIRK-SILVA HI
QUIRK-SILVA I WORK WORK I. FOR
THAT BILL IS OUT THANK YOU
MISTER BLOOM. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR YOU DIDN'T GIVE ME AN
OPPORTUNITY TO- I'M SORRY- TO
CLOSE AND AYE- AYE THIS MAY BE-
AFTER TEN YEARS THE LAST TIME
THAT I APPEAR IN THIS COMMITTEE-
NO I'M SO SORRY MR BILLS EVERY
YEAR FOR TEN YEARS AND WHAT I
WANTED TO DO WAS JUST EXPRESS MY
ADMIRATION FOR THE- IMPORTANT
WORK THAT'S DONE BY THIS
COMMITTEE AND PARTICULARLY. BY
YOUR STAFF. THANK YOU MISTER
BLOOM. CAN YOU GIVE ME TEARY
MISTER BLOOM. MR GABRIEL PLEASE
. HERE ARE RIGHT.
IN OF A SORRY MR EVER HAS TO GO
BECAUSE HE'S GOT A RUN TO.
SOMETHING ELSE. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES I AM PLEASED TODAY TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN
SIXTY ONE- AS WE TALKED A LOT
ABOUT THIS COMMITTEE CALIFORNIA
HAS A WELL DOCUMENTED AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CRISIS AND ONE OF THE
PARTICULARLY UNFORTUNATE RESULTS
OF THAT CRISIS IS THAT SO MANY
OF OUR LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS
FACE SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS TO
FINDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING- THAT
OFTEN MEANS A PROTECTIVE
SENTENCE MIGHT SUBMIT PAPER
APPLICATIONS FOR EACH UNIT
THEY'RE APPLYING TO EVEN WHEN
THEY ARE OWNED AND OPERATED BY
THE SAME ENTITY. AS A RESULT OF
THIS THEY CAN BE DIFFICULT AND
TIME CONSUMING AND COSTLY FOR
LOW INCOME TENANTS TO FIND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THEY OFTEN
HAVE TO FOREGO SCHOOL OR WORK AS
PART OF THAT SEARCH AND SO IT
SIMPLY BILL NINETEEN SIXTY ONE
WOULD ADDRESS THIS ISSUE BY
REQUIRING THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT HOUSING COMMITTEE
DEVELOPMENT TO CREATE AND
IMPLEMENT A STATEWIDE DATABASE
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING LISTINGS
THIS PORTER WOULD BENEFIT LOW
INCOME APPLICANTS IN PROPERTY
MANAGERS IN MATH AND IT'S
STREAMLINING LOCATIONS AND
SCREENINGS AND PROVIDING AN
UPDATED LIST OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING UNITS. THIS PORTAL WOULD
ENSURE THE TENANTS CAN VIEW
AVAILABLE PUBLICLY SUBSIDIZED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING LISTING
CEMENT RENTAL APPLICATIONS
ELECTRONICALLY ACCESS THE
DATABASE IN MULTIPLE LANGUAGES
AND ALSO STORE THEIR PERSONAL
INFORMATION FOR RE USE SO THAT
THEY CAN APPLY FOR MULTIPLE
LISTINGS IN A MUCH MORE
EFFICIENT AND STREAMLINED
FASHION WE'RE GOING TO ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS TODAY AND
I ALSO WANT TO ADD MY- THANKS
AND ECHO ALL THE COMMENTS ABOUT
THE VERY VERY THOUGHTFUL
DISTANCE OF THE STAFF- IN THE
CHAIR IN THE COMMITTEE SO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR HELP THERE- AND
WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
AYE VOTE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. AND I HAVE TWO WITNESSES
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB SIXTY ONE I IN
PERSON IS AMBERLEY LESLIE FROM
HOUSING HOUSING CALIFORNIA AND
OVER THE PHONE AS MISTER WILLIE
STEVENS FROM RESIDENTS UNITED
NETWORK THANK YOU I THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GABRIEL- FOR YOUR TIME
YOUR CONSIDERATION THIS MORNING
AT. SO MORE. MY NAME IS AMBER
LEE LESS I AM ALLEGE. ADD WITH
HOUSING CALIFORNIA- WE'RE PROUD
TO SPONSOR AB NINETEEN SIXTY ONE
AND YOU KIND OF HURT A LITTLE
BIT OF THAT EARLIER WITH SOME OF
THE- ENTHUSIASM FOR THIS BILL-
MEMBERS YOU HAVE HEARD MANY
TESTIMONIES OF THE COURSE OF
YOUR TENURE ABOUT. THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS IN
CALIFORNIA JUST HOW CHALLENGING
IT IS FOR LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS. INCLUDING PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS TO
AFFORD MODEST HOUSING. OF THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE MINISTRATION
HAVE TAKEN MEASURABLE STEPS TO
SPEED THE PRODUCTION OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. BY
INCREASING FUNDING TO STATE
PROGRAMS THAT SUPPORT
DEVELOPMENT. BY IMPROVING
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES TO
ENSURE JURISDICTIONS MEET THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING NEEDS OF
THEIR COMMUNITIES. AND BY
STREAMLINING THE PROCESS FOR
DEVELOPERS APPLYING FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FUNDING JUST
TO NAME A FEW. AND THE
STRATEGIES WILL CONTINUE TO BE
CRITICAL TO SOLVING OUR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS. AB
NINETEEN SIXTY ONE AT ITS CORE
REINFORCES THE GOOD WORK OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ADVOCATES BY MAKING IT EASIER
FOR LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS. TO
FIND THE HOUSING THAT WE ARE
WORKING SO HARD TO PRODUCE AND
KEEP AFFORDABLE. THIS BILL
PROPOSES TO REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT.
DEPARTMENT TRANSFORMATION.
DIGITAL TOOL THAT WILL ALLOW
SOMEONE LOOKING FOR DEED
RESTRICTED MULTI FAMILY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. TO CREATE A
USER PROFILE THAT CENTRALIZES
THEIR PERSONAL. YOU IN APPLY TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING OR BE PLACED
ON A WAIT LIST ENTIRELY ONLINE.
THIS BILL WAS DIRECTLY INFORMED
BY THE LIFT EXPERTISE OF THE
RESIDENTS UNITED NETWORK OF
CALIFORNIA COALITION OF
RESIDENTS AND STAFF OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. AS YOU WILL
HEAR FROM MISTER WILLIE STEVENS
IN A MOMENT. WHEN IT COMES TO
FINDING AND APPLYING FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THE STATUS
QUO IS TOO UNWIELDY AND TOO
CUMBERSOME. BY ESTABLISHING A
COORDINATED AND STREAMLINED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DATABASE THE
STATE CAN REMOVE BARRIERS FOR
HOUSEHOLDS WITH THE LEAST
RESOURCES. THEREFORE WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND JOIN BY
PHONE I BELIEVE IS- MISTER
WILLIE STEVENS IS THAT RIGHT
OPERATOR CAN YOU ALLOW MISTER
WILLIE STEVENS TO SPEAK AS A
PRIMARY WITNESS. THIS LINE IS
OPEN. YES MY NAME IS WILLIE
STEVENS I WILL BE OKAY
CALIFORNIA AND ITS SENIOR
SUBSIDIZE BILITY ANA RODRIGUEZ.
AS YOU SUPPORT AUTHORED AB
NINETEEN SIXTY ONE I RETIRED IN
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN BUT COULD NO
LONGER. AFFORD DIRECTLY SB THEN
ALL PORTABLE STUDIO IT TOOK ME A
YEAR AND I HAVE TO FIND CLOTHES
TO LIVE WHERE MOST PEOPLE WOULD
TAKES LONGER. I HAD TO STAY IN
HOTELS AND MOTELS WELL I COULD
PAY BY THE WEEK I LOOK FOR WORK
I LOOK FOR AN APARTMENT ON
CRAIG'S LIST GOAL SECTION EIGHT
BOB NONPROFIT HOUSING PROVIDERS
A LOCAL HOUSING AUTHORITIES IF I
HAD WE HAD HEAD AB NINETEEN
SIXTY ONE I WOULDN'T HAVE HAD TO
UPDATE MY APPLICATION EACH TIME
I. MOVED FROM ONE PLACE TO
ANOTHER. WHAT I LOVE MY BROUGH.
ON. THAT- OUR TRYING TO MAKE UP
AT I'LL WANT I LOST MY BROUGH.
ON THE- THEY HAD ALL MY PURSE UP
NATURAL. ABOUT I AM IT AND I
COULDN'T GET IT. IF HAD IF WE
HAD A HEAD AB. NINETY SIXTY ONE-
I COULD A PLAQUE ONLINE AT. AND
RISK ALL MY INFORMATION. ANOTHER
ON THE BUS. OUR MY ABILITY OR
PUT TRIED TO ME IT UP. WE HAD A
HAD A NINETY SIXTY ONE PEOPLE
WHO HAVE JUST. SENIOR HANDLED
DON'T ENGLISH WOULD HAVE HAD
BEER USE AND AWAY TO AND FOR OUT. I PRAY TO GOD EACH NIGHT
BEFORE I CALLED MY HIGH. YEAH I
WOULD AND HOME. I'M HERE TODAY
TO TRY TO END HOMELESSNESS AND
FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF AB. NINETEEN
SIXTY ONE THANK YOU MUCH. THANK
YOU AND FOLKS IN THE ROOM WHO
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT.
DRIVEN A CAR HOME HAVE A
CALIFORNIA BE IN SUPPORT. SHANOR
PORT WITH THE CORPORATION FOR
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AN OPERATOR ANY FOLKS
ON THE CALL FROM THE GENERAL
PUBLIC- LIKE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT
SUPPORT FOR A BI NINETEEN SIXTY
ONE PLEASE JUST NAME AFFILIATION
AND- SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THIS PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME WELL TO ALIGN
FIFTY TWO. I DON'T HELLO YES
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU HI
YES MY NAME IS DR- WHAT THE
RESIDENTS UNITED NETWORK AND I'M
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT AB
EIGHT. YEAH THANK YOU FOR NEXT
TO LINE ONE TWENTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. WELL LET LINE ONE
TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS NOT. I'M FROM THE
RESIDENTS UNITED NETWORK CALLING
ON STRONG SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN
SIXTY ONE. THANK YOU. BURGER
NEXT LINE OF THE LINE NINETY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS JOHN
BRADY WITH THE RUN NETWORK
ANALYTICS PROVIDERS AND WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS. THANK
YOU WE'LL GO NEXT TO LINE. FIFTY
FOUR. HI THIS IS DR ROBERT A
RESIDENT OF LEADER OF RESIDENT
NIGHT NETWORK- I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN SIXTY ONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WILL GO
NEXT TO LINE SIXTY SEVEN. HI MY
NAME'S ROBERT ZERO COMMENTS THE
THREATENS UNITED NETWORK CALLING
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU FOR OUR
NEXT TO LINE UP ONE THAT'S
THIRTY. GOOD MORNING MISSING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
ALAN I'D RESIDENT UNITED NETWORK
LOS ANGELES IN STRONG SUPPORT
FOR A BI NINETEEN SIXTY ONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WILL GO
NEXT TO LINE ONE TWENTY FIVE.
JORDAN BEING REGIONAL TASK FORCE
ON THE HOMELESS- VOTING IS.
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU FOR
OUR NEXT TO LINE THIRTY NINE.
YEAH GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JOE BARRETT I'M FROM RESIDENT
UNITED NETWORK QUALITY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN SIXTY ONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU OVER NEXT
LINE UP ONE SIXTEEN. HELLO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JESSICA KORDA PART OF THE UNITED
NETWORKING I'M IN SUPPORT OF
NINETEEN SIXTY ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WILL GO A LONG TIME
LINE ONE NINETEEN. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME'S RICHARD
GALA FROM SANTA CRUZ COUNTY
WOULD RESIDENTS UNITED NETWORK
CALLING ASKING FOR YOUR SUPPORT
AND- NINETEEN SIXTY ONE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WILL GO NEXT TO
LINE SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE MONEY WAS THANK YOU
PLEASANT- IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB THANK YOU SIXTY ONE PLEASE
JOIN US IN GETTING THE BILL
PASSED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WE'LL GO NEXT TO LINE UP ONE
FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS DAN BRADLEY ON WITH
RESIDENTS UNITED THAT WORK IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN
SIXTY ONE. THANK YOU WILL GO
NEXT TO LINE THIRTY STORIES
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS GARY
MCALLISTER FROM THE RESIDENTS
UNITED NETWORK CODING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN SIXTY ONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU OVERALL
NEXT TO LINE UP ONE THIRTY ONE.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. TRY AND BILLS
ARE COMING FROM SACRAMENTO I'M
WHICH RESIDENT UNITED NETWORK
COLLEEN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MEXICO TO LINE FORTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE FORTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS MARIA
HERNANDEZ- FROM SAN DIEGO COUNTY
WAS RESIDENT UNITED NETWORK THE
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN
SIXTY ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WE'LL GO NEXT TO LINE UP ONE
THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS DAMIEN WITH THE
EAST BAY HOUSING ORGANIZATIONS
THE RESIDENTS UNITED NETWORK
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
NINETEEN SIXTY ONE. THANKS SO
MUCH. THANK YOU FOR OUR NEXT TO
LINE THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND
THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NEARLY
YES. MY NAME'S HARRISON CHANNEL
THE COORDINATOR OF THE NONPROFIT
KING AND I WITHOUT REACH AN
IMAGE ON THE BORDER A. B.
NINETEEN SIXTY ONE. THANK YOU
WE'LL GO NEXT TO LINE ONE THIRTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS TORY TRUE SHANK CALLING FROM
THE RESIDENTS UNITED NETWORK IN
ON THE STOCK REPORTED EIGHTY
NINETEEN SIXTY ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE'LL GO NEXT TO LINE
SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
MY NAME IS VERY TO RAINY. AND
I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT A. B.
NINETEEN SIXTY ONE. THANK YOU.
AND WE'LL GO NEXT TO THE LINE OF
FRANCINE AND DRIVING PLEASE GO
AHEAD WITH YOUR SUPPORT. OUR OWN
PHONE NUMBER THANK YOU LARRY
THAT WORKS AND I DO SUPPORT.
NINETEEN FIFTY ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THERE ARE NO OTHER
THINGS SHE WOULD TIME THANK YOU
OPERATOR- THE BOOK NOW GO TO ANY
WITNESSES PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. SAYING ON ANY
WITNESSES IN THE ROOM IN
OPPOSITION. SAYING NINE AND
WE'VE GOTTEN A REGISTERED
OPPOSITION SO- WILL MOVE FORWARD
TO BRING IT BACK HERE TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. THANK YOU ARE
THANK YOU FOR- BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD I DEFINITELY SEE
HOW IT COULD BE HELPFUL- AS A
CENTRALIZED SOURCE OF IT REALLY
IMPORTANT INFORMATION I DO WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT- IT IS.
UNDERSCORED OR OR THAT THERE
POSSIBLY COULD YOU KNOW BE VERY
CLEAR- DEFINITION IN THE BILL
THAT. LOCAL AGENCIES OR OTHERS
THAT ARE ALREADY DOING THIS WITH
THEIR HOUSING STOCK ONE ON THAT
AND THEY ARE RECEIVING THE
FUNDING TO PROPERLY TRAIN YOUR
BECOME FAMILIAR WITH- NEW
PLATFORMS- INTO THAT THERE IS-
AN ACTIVE WAY FOR. THE COMPUTER
SYSTEMS TALK TO EACH OTHER THEY
HAVE THE RESPONSIBILITIES TODAY
TO MANAGE OR TO KNOW THEIR
HOUSING STOCK TO ACCEPT THE
APPLICATIONS IN JURISDICTIONS
LIKE MINE YOU KNOW THAT'S
ALREADY EIGHT TO TEN YEARS LONG-
WHEN YOU DO QUALIFY FOR CERTAIN
TYPES OF HOUSING AND THEN YOU'RE
YOU'RE WAITING THAT LONG TO
ACTUALLY WE FOR THAT YOU NEED TO
OPEN UP- I. WOULD HOPE THIS AYE
AYE AYE UNDERTAKEN THERE'S VALUE
HERE I HOPE THAT- WHAT WE NEED
TO BUILD MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
WE NEED THIS DATABASE CERTAINLY
TO GROW IN NUMBERS- BECAUSE I
THINK A LOT OF- YOU KNOW
POTENTIAL RESIDENTS ARE GOING TO
LOOK UP THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
SUBMIT THE APPLICATION. AND
REALIZE THAT THE NEAREST
AVAILABLE PLACE MIGHT BE ENOUGH
TO ARE MILES AWAY- BUT- YOU KNOW
TO THE EXTENT THAT THIS IS-
HELPING US REALLY LOOK AT THE
ENTIRE MAP- AND HELP AREAS AND
HELP JURISDICTIONS THAT. ARE UP
TO SPEED- LIKE MINE WITH THE-
CATALOGING AND THE- AUTOMATION-
THIS INFORMATION CAN BE REALLY
HELPFUL SO THANK YOU. YEAH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HAPPY TO WORK EITHER IT'S AN
EXCELLENT. HAVE ANY TO WORK ON
THAT AS IT WAS. OKAY THANK YOU
MISTER. THANK THAN I'M SURE NOW
WANT TO EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION
TO THE AUTHOR THIS IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT- YOU KNOW WHEN THERE'S
WHEN THERE IT'S SO COMPLICATED
TO APPLY FOR ONE- AFFORDABLE
HOUSING OPPORTUNITY AND
OFTENTIMES THOSE WITH THE MOST
URGENT NEEDS CAN BE PLACED IN
AND GO TOWARDS THE TOP LIST IF
THEY APPLY AND I THINK
OFTENTIMES ARE NOT AWARE OF ALL
THE OPPORTUNITIES ARE AVAILABLE
THIS IS COMMON SENSE AND I.
ESPECIALLY GIVEN- MY COMMUNITY
PERSON WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
INCLUDING SPANISH AND IT MEANS-
IN TERMS OF LANGUAGE ACCESS-
WHICH IS A HUGE BARRIER IN TERMS
OF- SOMEBODY THAT NEED A HOUSING
GETTING US APPRECIATE. THAT
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER. ANY
OTHER. FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
AND WITH EMOTION SOME OF AND
SECOND GRADE- I WANT TO ALSO
APPLAUD THE AUTHOR FOR THIS
BILL- AS YOU KNOW I'M A BIG FAN
OF DATA. AND WOULD LOVE TO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR. OF AND I'M
EXCITED THAT YOU'RE- YOU PUT
TOGETHER SUCH A GREAT COALITION-
AN ISSUE THAT I THINK IS A MUCH
NEEDED SO IT'S TOTALLY CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- OUT OF HER
BE HONORED TO HAVE YOU AS A CO
AUTHOR- YOU KNOW I THINK TO ME I
GUESS WHAT I WOULD SAY IS. WHAT
WHAT I APPRECIATE MOST ABOUT
THIS IS THAT IT'S DROPPED WITH A
ON THE LIVED EXPERIENCES OF
THESE RESIDENTS AND IT'S
BUILDING ON THAT AND WITHOUT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. GREAT THANK YOU AND THE
MOTION IS THAT DO PASSED AS
AMENDED TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
WICKS I WEEKS I SEYARTO HI I
CORREO. HI GABRIEL HI GABRIEL I
. COLOR KILEY QUIRK-SILVA
QUIRK-SILVA A WARD WARD BY. THE
BILL OUT. AND I JUST WHEN REMIND
FOLKS WE'VE GOT ONE TWO THREE
FOUR FIVE SIX MORE BILLS AND WE
HAVE TO BE OUT OF THIS ROOM AT
ONE O'CLOCK SO IF- BILLS HAVE
LESS CONTROVERSY LET'S MOVE
RIGHT ALONG OKAY. MYSTERY THIS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- I WANT TO START BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AS DESCRIBED ON PAGE
EIGHT OF THE ANALYSIS AB TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FIVE BUILT OFF
RECENT LEGISLATION PROMOTING
SYSTEMS INTEGRATION TO INCREASE
EFFICIENCY AND EFFECTIVENESS IN
COMBATING HOMELESSNESS. THE BILL
WILL ESTABLISH A DIRECTOR WILL
BE TASKED WITH OVERSEEING ALL
STATE HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS THAT
WILL CONTINUE TO BE MANAGED BY
EXISTING ENTITIES. ADDITIONALLY
AB TWENTY THREE TWENTY FIVE WILL
CREATE A FUNDING WORK GROUP
WHICH WILL BE TASKED WITH
ALIGNING DEFINITIONS AND
STREAMLINING PROGRAMS WHERE
POSSIBLE. CONNECTING
INDIVIDUALS- EXITING STATE
FUNDED INSTITUTIONAL SETTINGS
LIKE PRISONS HOSPITALS AND
NURSING HOMES TO HOUSING.
IMPLEMENTING A UNIVERSAL
APPLICATION FOR SERVICE AND
HOUSING PROVIDERS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. HOMELESSNESS IS ONE
OF IF NOT THE MOST PRESSING
ISSUES FACING OUR STATE TODAY
AND THAT PANDEMIC HAS
EXACERBATED EXACERBATED THE
CRISIS TO NEW DANGEROUS LEVELS.
THE L. A. O. THE LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION AND AT THE STATE
AUDITOR HAVE ALL REACHED THE
SAME CONCLUSION REGARDING THE
STATE'S RESPONSE TO HOMELESSNESS
OUR CURRENT. APPROACH IS
UNNECESSARILY FRAGMENTED SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND LOCALITIES FACE
TREMENDOUS ADMINISTRATIVE
BURDENS AND NAVIGATING AT LEAST
TEN STATE AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS ADMINISTERS
ADMINISTRATING THIRTY OR MORE
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS RELATED TO
HOMELESSNESS. THE DIFFERENT AND
OFTEN CONFLICTING HOMELESSNESS
PROGRAMS APPLICATIONS AND
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS ARE
UNNECESSARILY COMPLICATED AND
LEADS TO DELAYS RESULTING IN
INDIVIDUALS FALLING THROUGH THE
CRACKS. WE HAVE INVESTED A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF RESOURCES
INTO COMBATTING HOMELESSNESS BUT
FUNDING ALONE WILL NOT SOLVE THE
SYSTEMIC ISSUES WE NEED POLICY
SOLUTIONS THAT WILL STREAMLINE
SERVICE DELIVERY AND BREAK DOWN
THE EXISTING SILOS BETWEEN OUR
DEPARTMENTS AND AGENCIES.
FUNDING INVESTMENTS MUST BE
COUPLED WITH SOLUTIONS TO OUR
STRUCTURAL ISSUES AT THE STATE
LEVEL. TODAY I HAVE WITH ME TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY MARI KISSED
ALL THE SENIOR LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE ON HOMELESSNESS FROM
HOUSING CALIFORNIA AND SHARON
REPORT DIRECTOR OF CORPORATION
FOR SUPPORTIVE HOUSING. THANK
YOU THANK YOU MEMBERS I MARKET
STALL THE SENIOR LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE ON HOMELESSNESS IT
HOUSING CALIFORNIA NONPROFIT
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION DEDICATED
TO AND LISTEN IT'S AN ASSURING
EVERYONE HAS AN AFFORDABLE PLACE
TO LIVE- AS A FAMILY MEMBER
RIVAS MENTION HOMELESSNESS IS A-
PRESSING CRISIS IN OUR STATE AND
RECENT POLLING SHOWS THAT AS
MANY AS TWO THIRDS OF VOTERS ARE
DISSATISFIED WITH OUR STATE'S
HOMELESS RESPONSE. AND ITS STAND
ABOVE THE PUBLIC MAYBE CAN
APPRECIATE THE STATE'S STRATEGY
IT'S HARD EVEN FOR SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND LOCALITY. THE
THIRTY PLUS PROGRAMS TACKLING
HOMELESSNESS SPENDING TEN STATE
AGENCIES AND DESPITE THE
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS TOWARD
COORDINATION THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA INTERAGENCY COUNCIL
ON HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS IN
DIFFERENT AGENCIES OPERATE
INDEPENDENTLY FROM ONE ANOTHER
AND THE COUNCIL HAS LIMITED
AUTHORITY TO DIRECT AND
COORDINATE ACROSS THOSE AGENCIES
WHICH CREATES HUGE
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDENS ON
LOCALITIES TO NAVIGATE DIFFERENT
AND OFTEN CONFLICTING FUNDING
APPLICATIONS PROTOCOLS AND
REPORTING FOR. US EIGHT TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FIVE SIX TO BUILD
ON RECENT EFFORTS BY CREATING A
FUNDING WORK GROUP WITHIN THE
INTERAGENCY COUNCIL ON
HOMELESSNESS INCLUDING STAY. OF
ALL STATE FUNDED HOMELESSNESS
PROGRAMS THE WORK GROW GROUP
WOULD AS MENTIONED A LINE
PROGRAMS AROUND A CORE SET OF
EVIDENCE EVIDENCE BASED
STANDARDS CREATE PROTOCOLS TO
PREVENT PEOPLE FROM EXITING
STATE FUNDED INSTITUTIONAL
SETTINGS INTO HOMELESSNESS.
ANALYZE CURRENT PROGRAMS TO
IDENTIFY POTENTIAL AREAS OF
OVERLAP OR DUPLICATION AND WORK
TOWARD A SHARED FUNDING
APPLICATION TO LOWER THE
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN ON LOCAL
SERVICE PROVIDERS WERE GREATLY
ENCOURAGED BY THE PROGRESS MADE-
ON COORDINATING ARE HOMELESS
RESPONSE THANKS IN NO SMALL PART
TO THE TALENTED AND DEALT
DEDICATED LEADERS AT THE
INTERAGENCY COUNCIL. BUT ONE OF
FURTHER BUILD ON THIS PROGRESS
AND ENSURE FUNDING AND POLICY
AROUND HOMELESSNESS IS
COORDINATED STREAMLINED AND
EFFECTIVE SO THAT EVERY TAXPAYER
DOLLARS USED WISELY AND EVERY
PROGRAM IS ADVANCING EVIDENCE
BASED SOLUTIONS TO HOMELESSNESS.
THANKS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SHARON REPORT WITH THE
CORPORATION FOR SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING. OVER THE LAST TWENTY
PLUS YEARS INDEPENDENT BODIES
HAVE NOTED FLAWS IN THE STATE'S
RESPONSE TO HOMELESSNESS. THE
LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION
REPORTED THAT THE STATE HAS A
SILENT RESPONSE FOR EACH AGENCY
IMPLEMENTS THEIR OWN PROGRAMS
WITH LITTLE OR NO COORDINATION
OR COLLABORATION. THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
SAID THE STATE'S RESPONSE TO
HOMELESSNESS IS FRAGMENTED AND
LACKS VISION. THE STATE AUDITOR
REPORTED THAT THE STATE'S
RESPONSE TO HOMELESSNESS LACKS A
COLLABORATIVE REPORT APPROACH.
AND THE GOVERNOR'S TASK FORCE OF
REGIONAL HOMELESS ADVISERS
RECOMMENDED A SINGLE POINT OF
AUTHORITY THAT REPORTS DIRECTLY
TO THE GOVERNOR AND IS
ANSWERABLE FOR OUTCOMES. MS
BECAUSE STUDY WAS CORRECT THAT
THE CALIFORNIA INTERAGENCY
COUNCIL ON HOMELESSNESS HAS MADE
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS IN
PROVIDING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN REACHING
OUT TO OTHER AGENCIES AND
CREATING AN ACTION PLAN. LAST
YEAR'S AB TWELVE TWENTY AT VANCE
PROGRESS WITH ADDING THE
SECRETARY OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AS ONE OF THE CHAIRS.
HOWEVER MOST OF THAT WORK
pCENTERS ON STEPS THE COUNCIL
WILL DO RATHER THAN WHAT THE
OTHER STATE AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS WILL DO TOGETHER
COLLABORATIVELY. IN FACT THE
COUNSEL HAS NO AUTHORITY OF THE
OTHER AGENCIES OR DEPARTMENTS
OUTSIDE OF THE BUSINESS CONSUMER
SERVICES AND HOUSING AGENCY OR
THE COUNCIL SETS. THE SECRETARY
BCS AGE AND THE CALIFORNIA I. CH
STAFF ARE DEDICATED. TO PROGRESS
IN SOLVING HOMELESSNESS BUT THEY
SIMPLY LACK AUTHORITY BOTH THEM
BEING THE SINGLE LEAD IN THE
STATE'S RESPONSE AND THEN MOVING
OTHER AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS
TO BREAK DOWN. THE SILOS THE
FRAGMENTATION AND DUPLICATION OF
EFFORT THAT HAS EXISTED FOR
DECADES. TWENTY AB TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FIVE WOULD EMPOWER THE
CALIFORNIA I. CH BY MOVING IT TO
AN OFFICE WITH THE DIRECTOR THAT
REPORTS DIRECTLY TO THE
GOVERNOR. THE DIRECTOR IN OFFICE
WILL BE A SINGLE LEAD WITH BOTH
AUTHORITY AND RESPONSIBILITY. IN
THIS OFFICE WILL BE STAFFED BY
CURRENT I C. H. STAFF SO TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FIVE WOULD NOT
CREATE A NEW PROGRAM OR ADD A
REQUIRED TO HIRING OF ADDITIONAL
STAFF. THIS APPROACH OF CREATING
ACROSS AGENCY OFFICE HAS BEEN
SUCCESSFUL IN THE PAST LIKE WITH
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
BUSINESS ECONOMIC AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. AND THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES- THIS
APPROACH HAS ALSO WORKED WELL IN
OTHER STATES LIKE MICHIGAN
MINNESOTA NEW YORK AND ARIZONA.
WE CANNOT MOVE THE NEEDLE ON
HOMELESSNESS UNLESS THE STATE'S
RESPONSE IS COORDINATED
COLLABORATIVE AND AS EFFECTIVE
AS POSSIBLE WITH A SINGLE POINT
OF AUTHORITY NAVIGATING THE
STATE'S RESPONSE AB TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FIVE WOULD ACCOMPLISH
THESE GOALS AND AYE ARCHER AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU TO
HAVE ADDITIONAL FOLKS IN THE
ROOM WHICH TO REGISTER SUPPORT.
JANE CAN- WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
MARCH THERE IS THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OPERATOR FIVE SERVE
FOLKS FROM THE PUBLIC WHO WISH
TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FIVE CAN YOU PLEASE
LET THEM TO DO SO NOW NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION PLACE-
IT IS DOUBLE THE PUBLIC IF
ELECTIVES. EXPRESS YOUR SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. OPERATIVE GIVE ME A
LINE NUMBER WILL BE IN LINE FOR
YOUR NAME FILIATION AND
POSITION. ON ALL OF THEM SURELY
CLICK BECAUSE ONE WHICH.
JUST ONE MORE MOMENT.
FOR PERSONAL LINE NUMBER ELEVEN
ONE ELEVEN GO AHEAD PLEASE.
HELLO THIS IS KATIE NEXT
CLEANING AT THE FEINBERG
INSTITUTE IN SUPPORT. MAX IS
LINE ONE FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
DANE HUTCHINGS TESTIFYING ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY AFFECTED CITY
IN SUPPORT. LINE ONE THIRTY NINE
THINGS GOING. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS ARE MANAGER MEMBERS ALEX
ARE DESTROYED YOU SEE SIXTY ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN DIEGO HOUSING
COMMISSION APOLOGIES WE GOT A
LETTER IN LIGHT BUT WE ARE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LINE TWENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
MISS ALMA CONDEMNING PUBLIC
HEALTH ADVOCATE CALLING THE
BEFORE THANK YOU. ONE ONE THIRTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. JORDAN
BEING REGIONAL TASK FORCE ON
HOMELESSNESS SAN DIEGO CALLING
IN SUPPORT. ONCE AGAIN FOR
SUPPORT ONE ZERO BECAUSE FINE
LET'S GO TO LINE ONE TWENTY WILL
HAVE POINTS. SB ON BEHALF OF
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. WELL ANYONE IN PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. MANY FOLKS IN THE ROOM AND
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. NO
OPPOSITION ON FILE WILL BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS. AND A
MISS KOREA. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND I THINK IT TO THE
AUTHOR FOR THE WORK THAT YOU'VE
DONE ON THE DRESSING ISSUES ON
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS I THINK
WE'VE SEEN A LOT OF POSITIONS
AND BILLS THAT CLEARLY INDICATE
THAT HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS IS
THE NUMBER ONE PRIORITY THAT WE
MUST ADDRESS- IS THE SINGLE MOST
THING THAT COMES UP IN EVERY
CONVERSATION- I YOU KNOW I'D I'D
WANT TO TALK TO YOU AND THANK
YOU FOR HAVING A DISCUSSION WITH
ME- SEPARATELY ABOUT THIS- THIS
INITIATIVE THAT YOU HAVE.
SPECIFICALLY I WANNA I NEED SOME
CLARIFICATION FROM YOU ON YOUR
BILL- AB TWELVE TWENTY WHICH
CREATED A PROCESS IN WHICH CAL I
C. H. A WOULD BE THE LEAD ON
HOMELESSNESS IN FACT WE HAD A
HEARING ON MARCH EIGHTH OF THIS
YEAR ALONE- IN WHICH WE
DISCUSSED HOW HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AS WELL AS BUSINESS
CONSUMER SERVICES IN IT AND
HOUSING AGENCY SECRETARY AS-
WITH SERVICE CODE. ERRORS ON THE
COUNCIL AND HOW- BOTH
SECRETARIES WERE NOW IN
COLLABORATION TO ADDRESS ISSUES
AND HOUSING AND WRAPAROUND
SERVICES WHICH ARE OFTEN
CONVERSATIONS THAT OCCURRENCE
EYELESS. WHEN WE'RE IN BUDGET
COMMITTEE ON HOUSING AND STUFF
FOR. THERE'S ALWAYS A
CONVERSATION ABOUT WELL WHAT
ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH TAXES WHAT
ABOUT WRAPAROUND SERVICES AT
CETERA. IN CONVERSATIONS THAT
I'VE HAD WITH MEMBERS. AND
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
THERE'S ALWAYS A CONVERSATION OF
LIKE WHAT ABOUT HOUSING AND HOW
DOES IT WORK TOGETHER. SO MY
UNDERSTANDING WAS THAT IN THE
CREATION OF THIS COUNCIL IN THE
CO CHAIRS WE ARE NOW BEGINNING A
PROCESS IN WHICH- THESE TWO
ENTITIES ARE NOT WORKING AT
SILOS AND IN FACT ARE WORKING
COLLABORATION. THE FIRST TIME SO
I'M CURIOUS AS TO. IF THE IF THE
CREATION OF CAL I C. H. AND
CHANGING THE NAME OF THE ENTITY.
WAS THE INTENT TO BE THE LEAD ON
HOUSING ON ON ALMOST NIS. AND IT
ALSO CREATED A PROCESS TO STRING
THE CONNECTION BETWEEN HOUSING
AND SERVICES A CONNECTION THAT
IS MISSING WHEN THE TWO.
AGENCIES OPERATE INDEPENDENTLY.
WHY WOULD BE WHY WHEN WE JUST
ESTABLISHED THAT AND WE JUST
CODIFIED A PLAN TO MOVE THAT
FORWARD. WHY INTRODUCED
SOMETHING NOW WITHOUT ALONG THAT
PROCESS TO MOVE FORWARD INTO FOR
US TO HAVE SOME KIND SOLUTION.
AND WHAT IS THE INTENT OF
CREATING A NEW POSITION. THAT
DIRECTLY REPORTS TO THE GOVERNOR
. WITHOUT LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT
OR WHAT WOULD BE THE LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT- WITH THIS DEPOSITION.
OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU MISS
CARILLO AND- YOU KNOW I
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION THAT
WE HAD YESTERDAY AND SOME MORE
INFORMATION I SUBMITTED TO YOU
THIS MORNING- THE- ALL THAT I.
INTRODUCED IN THE WAS SIGNED
LAST YEAR AB TWELVE TWENTY THAT
YOU MENTIONED- IT RENAMED THE
COUNCIL THIS COUNCIL WAS CREATED
YEARS AGO BY A BILL BY ORMER
SENATOR HOLLY MITCHELL IT WAS
FORMALLY- NAME THE HOUSING
FINANCING AND COORDINATING
COUNCIL- AND WE RENAMED IT I'VE
YOU KNOW THE ICY H. THE
INTERAGENCY COUNCIL ON
HOMELESSNESS- AND IT'S MORE
AFTER THE FEDERAL THE- AGENCY
WHICH IS THE US INTO. A SALON
HOMELESSNESS- WHERE THERE ARE
THERE IS A CO CHAIR THE CUT THE
CHAIR OF THE U. S. INTERAGENCY
IS THE HUD SECRETARY- AND THE
VICE CHAIR IS THE VETERAN
AFFAIRS SECRETARY SO TWO CABINET
MEMBERS- ARE YOU KNOW CHAIR AND
VICE CHAIR- BUT THE DIFFERENCE
IS OF THAT THIS INTER AGENCY AT
THE LEVEL- IS AN ENTITY UNDER
THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH OUR AND HAS
AN EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR. AND THE
IN AGENTS CAO IS ON THAT RIGHT
WITH CULTURES THAT ARE STILL
CABINET MEMBERS AND
COLLABORATING ALONG WITH OTHER-
A REPRESENTATIVES FROM OTHER
FEDERAL AGENCIES- AND SO THAT'S
WHAT THIS BILL IS ATTEMPTING TO
DO TO CONTINUE RIGHT THAT
COLLABORATION AND HAVE A
DIRECTOR THAT WOULD BE. AT OUR
EXECUTIVE LEVEL. AND HOW WILL
THE DIRECTOR BE HIRED AND UNDER
WHAT AGENCY OR ENTITY WITH THE
DIRECTOR BE IN COLLABORATION
WITH THE LEGISLATURE MEANING.
WHAT THAT WHEN THE GOVERNOR WHEN
THE GOVERNOR LEAVES IS THAT AN
APPOINTED POSITION IS THAT-
HIRED POSITION IS THAT A
SECRETARY SECRETARY LEVEL
CABINET POSITION RIGHT NOW IT'S
A DIRECTOR SIMILAR TO THE
DIRECTOR OF YES RIGHT THAT. THE
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
RIGHT WHICH IS UNDER OUR EGGS
EXECUTIVE ADMINISTRATION- THE
COUNCIL DOES HAVE LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT FROM WHEN IT WAS
CREATED YEARS AGO- THE INTER
AGENCY COUNCIL. HAS TO REPORT TO
THE LEGISLATURE- IF I'M NOT SURE
HOW OFTEN BUT IT WAS LAST IT
LAST REPORTED TO US LAST YEAR.
SO THAT WAS BUILT TEN FROM THE
VERY BEGINNING FROM WHEN THIS
COUNCIL WAS CREATING CREATED
BEFORE IT WAS RENAMED. LAST YEAR
. GENERALLY I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND HOW WE WOULD OPERATE
WHETHER IT'S THE CREATION OF A
NEW AGENCY A CREATION OF A NEW
DEPARTMENT WHETHER IT'S THE
SUBMERSION OF VARIOUS DIFFERENT
AGENCIES TO REPORT TO ONE SINGLE
INDIVIDUAL- IT DONE OFFICE. THE
DIRECTOR WOULD SERVE AS A CORNER
COORDINATOR AMONGST THESE
AGENCIES THE PROGRAMS WOULD
STILL BE PART OF THOSE AGENCIES
AND ADMINISTERED BY THOSE
AGENCIES SIMILAR TO WHAT LIKE I
SAID BEFORE THAT WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT STRUCTURE IS
WHICH- WE HAVE THE SAME NAME.
AND I KNOW IT IT WAS INSPIRED BY
THE FEDERAL AGENCY LAST YEAR
FROM- YOU KNOW MY WORK ON IT
LAST YEAR AND- THE SUGGESTIONS
FROM THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. BUT
THE ONLY THING WE DIDN'T DO WAS
STRUCTURE IT THE SAME AS THE
FEDERAL- SIX AGENCY. ENDS AT UP
AND WITH THE DIRECTOR WHO
REPORTS. THE DIRECTOR OF THE
OFFICE WHO REPORTS DIRECTLY TO
THE GOVERNOR HAVE WHAT IS THEIR
ROLE WITH THE SECRETARIES OF THE
DEPARTMENTS SO DO THEY HAVE WHAT
THEY HAVE. IF THEY ARE IN CHARGE
OF CREATE A PLAN AND LET THEY
THE SECRETARY OF HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES HAS A DIFFERENT
IDEA. THAN WHO WOULD WHO HOW
WOULD THAT DECISION BE MADE WELL
THE COUNCIL IS STILL CO CHAIRED
BY THE SECRETARY OF HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AND THE SECRETARY
OF BUSINESS CONSUMER SERVICES
AND HOUSING THE WAY IT'S
STRUCTURED THE COUNCIL IS STILL
THE SAME IT'S STILL FUNCTIONS
THE SAME WAY THAT. WITH THE WAY
IT WAS CREATED RIGHT- BUT
DIRECTOR- IT AND IT'S NOT A
REPORTING STRUCTURE THE
SECRETARIES DO NOT REPORT TO
THIS DIRECTOR. RIGHT SO I'M NOT
SURE NO THE SATELLITE HERRIES
THE SECRETARIES WORKING
COLLABORATION WITH THE- BASED ON
THE R. CHAIR OF. COUNTS THAT
FALLS UNDER THIS PROPOSED OFFICE
LED BY A DIRECTOR WHAT THAT'S
WHAT MY QUESTION LIES SO MY
QUESTION IS REALLY MORE ON
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY SO
. IF THE SECRETARIES STILL
REPORTING AND YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY
WORK WITHIN THE ADMINISTRATION
ON A CABINET LEVEL. THEN WHAT IS
THE ROLE OF THE DIRECTOR AND WHO
HAS OVERSIGHT OVER THE
DIRECTOR'S PLAN OR ANY ACTION
PLANS THAT GET IMPLEMENTED SO
RIGHT NOW. THE PLAN FOR THE BILL
THAT YOU WORKED ON TWENTY EIGHT
TWELVE TWENTY IS MOVING FORWARD
AND YOU KNOW BASED ON.
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE'VE HAD
ITS- CODIFYING THE ACTION PLAN
SO I'M I'M JUST TRY I'M TRYING
TO UNDERSTAND YOUR VISION AND
I'M TRYING TO UNDERSTAND LIKE
HOW IT WOULD WORK AND WHAT WOULD
BE THE ROLE OF THE LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT UNDER WHICH- WHERE
WOULD FALL. LIKE I SAID BEFORE
THE- THE COUNCIL DOES HAVE
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT RIGHT THE
COUNCIL THE COUNCIL DOES BUT
WITH THE DIRECTOR HAVE
OVERSIGHT. BECAUSE THE DIRECTOR
NOW BASED ON WHAT YOU'VE SAID
REPORTS TO THE GOVERNOR. BUT WE
HAVE BEEN AS LEGISLATORS WE
CREATE THE POLICIES RIGHT THERE
THE STATE. DIRECTORS ARE
AGENCIES IMPLEMENT PROGRAMS THAT
WE CREATE WE DON'T RUN ANYTHING
THEY DON'T REPORT TO US RIGHT
BUT WE HAVE LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT THROUGH BUDGET THE
BUDGET PROCESS WE DECIDE HOW
MUCH. WILL BE ALLOCATED FOR
HOMELESSNESS EACH YEAR OR IF IT
WILL BE MULTIPLE YEARS LIKE A
LOT OF US HAVE ADVOCATED FOR-
THAT IS HOW THE LEGISLATURE HAS
OVERSIGHT. OVER ANY STATE
AGENCY. RIGHT THEY DON'T REPORT
TO US. BUT THEY DO IN TERMS OF
REPORTING TO THE LEGISLATURE IF
THE REQUIRED TO PLAY. IN SOME
WAY. I GUESS I'M I GUESS I'M ARE
YOU SAYING THAT IF THEY REPORT
TO US LIKE. WELL WHEN A PLAN IS
CREATED BY THE DIRECTOR IF THE
GOAL IS TO HAVE THE DIRECTOR B.
LIKE THE MAIN INDIVIDUAL-
WORKING ON ISSUES RELATED TO
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS ACROSS
THE STATE. BUT YET WE HAVE
INDIVIDUAL EIGHT SEATS AND
START. TO DO THAT SAME WORK I'M
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND HOW IT ALL
COMES TOGETHER WHO CREATES THE
PLAN WHO'S RESPONSIBLE. AT THE
DIRECTOR REPORTS. THE CONVERSE
WITHIN THE LEGISLATURE. AND THEN
WHAT IS THE ROLE OF THE
LEGISLATURE IN. I'M NOT HEARING
LIKE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CREATE THE PLAN
BECAUSE THAT WOULDN'T BE THE
ROLE OF. THE LEGISLATURE IF
YOU'RE CREATING A POSITION FOR A
DIRECTOR TO DO THAT. SO I'M I'M
I'M TRYING TO UNDERSTAND HOW IT
WOULD FUNCTION HOW IT WOULD WORK
AND WHERE THE LEGISLATURE WHAT
ULTIMATELY HAVE ACCOUNTABILITY
AND OVERSIGHT SO I YOU KNOW I
UNDERSTAND LIKE. THE INCREDIBLE
MAGNITUDE OF THE ISSUE THAT
WE'RE ALL TRYING TO WORK
TOGETHER TO RESOLVE. MY GOAL IN
THE IN THE QUESTIONS BASED ON
THE BASED ON THE WORK THAT WE'VE
DONE AND BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
FOUR ON STATE ADMINISTRATION
ASSEMBLY WHERE DOES THE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND OVERSIGHT OF
THE LEGISLATURE FALL. AND
ULTIMATELY LIKE WHAT IS THAT
FRAMEWORK LOOK LIKE. SO IF IT'S
SOMETHING THAT STILL LIKE IN
DEVELOPMENT THAT'S OKAY TOO- I'M
JUST TRYING TO UNDERSTAND THIS
AGENCY I MEAN THAT THE COUNCIL
THE INTERAGENCY COUNCIL. IT'S
ALREADY PART OF THE FRAMEWORK ON
HOLD LEGISLATIVE OVER YOU KNOW
THE LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT THAT
THEY HAVE. RIGHT SO IT'S ALREADY
PART OF THIS COUNCIL. BUT THE
DIRECTOR ISN'T YOU'RE CREATING A
NEW POSITION THE DIRECTOR THE
REPORTS TO THE GOVERNOR IS A
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT ENTITY. SO
THAT'S THAT'S WHERE IT'S
DIFFERENT THAN THE COUNCIL. BUT
THE DIRECTOR WOULD HAVE MORE OF
POWER RIGHT TO COORDINATE
BECAUSE CURRENTLY THERE'S A
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF HOMELESSNESS
WITHIN THE- BUSINESS CONSUMER
SERVICES AND HOUSING THAT
REPORTS THE SECRETARY- AND THIS
DIRECTOR WOULD HAVE ACCESS TO
MORE OF THE OTHER AGENCIES RIGHT
TO HELP COORDINATE. THE STATE IN
TERMS OF OUR PROCESS PROGRAMS
SERVE THE DIRECTOR THEN HAS
ACCESS TO MORE AGENCIES THAT MAY
BE FALL WITHIN VARIOUS DIFFERENT
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
SUBCOMMITTEES. THEN THE
CONVERSATIONS CAN POTENTIALLY BE
STILL IN SILOS IF YOU'RE WORKING
WITH AND HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES OR IF YOU'RE WORKING
WITHIN. A STATE ADMINISTRATION
ON HOUSING AND MAYBE. KEEP AND
HAVE DOLLARS OR PROJECT ROOM KEY
HOME KEY SOME I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND AGAIN JUST SIMPLY
WHERE THE ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD BE IF THIS ONE
INDIVIDUAL WOULD HAVE VARIOUS
DIFFERENT ACCESS POINTS. SO
AGAIN IT'S A GOOD. I'LL BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY
BECAUSE I BELIEVE THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT TO CREATE A FRAMEWORK
IN WHICH THERE'S ACCOUNTABILITY
AND TRANSPARENCY AND I HOPE THAT
WITHIN THE POLICY DISCUSSIONS
THAT CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD.
THERE'S A BETTER UNDERSTANDING
AS TO THE FRAMEWORK AS WELL AS
WHAT WILL ULTIMATELY ULTIMATELY
BE. THE LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT TO
A NEW DIRECTOR WITHIN THE
ADMINISTRATION. THANK YOU THANK
YOU- SOUNDS LIKE. REALLY FOR
THEIR CONVERSATIONS NEED TO TAKE
PLACE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. WITH EMOTION
SECOND APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR
BRING THE BILL FORWARD- HAVE YOU
MOVED OUT OF COMMITTEE TODAY
WITH SOUNDS LIKE MORE WORK NEEDS
TO BE DONE. WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANKS TO
MY COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR
QUESTIONS TODAY- YOU KNOW WE
WERE ALL ELECTED TO COME TO
SACRAMENTO AND ADDRESS. ISSUES
THAT ARE CRITICAL TO ALL OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS. AND HOMELESSNESS-
AS MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
HAVE EXPRESSED AND I'M SURE ALL
OF US AGREE IS THE NUMBER ONE
ISSUE. THAT IS ON THE TOP OF THE
MIND OF ALL OF OUR CONSTITUENTS
IN CALIFORNIA- THIS IS ONE OF
THE MAIN REASONS I COME HERE
EVERY WEEK AND LEAVE HOME- IS
WHAT. CAN THE STATE DO WHAT IS
OUR ROLE IN SOLVING HOMELESSNESS
IF WE ARE NOT STRUCTURED IF WITH
TO SOLVE THIS ISSUE AT THE STATE
LEVEL TO. COLLABORATE WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO WORK WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THAT WE'RE NOT DOING
OUR JOB AND- YOU KNOW WE HAVE AN
OBLIGATION. TO CONTINUE TO PUSH
IN THESE AREAS THAT MIGHT MAKE
OTHERS UNCOMFORTABLE INCLUDING
ADMINISTRATION. BUT THAT IS OUR
JOB WE ARE THE LEGISLATIVE
BRANCH WE HAVE A SAY TO AND HOW
PROBLEMS ARE SOLVED IN
CALIFORNIA AND THIS IS OUR
OPPORTUNITY. TO DO THAT THROUGH
THIS BILL AND I WELCOME MORE
CONVERSATIONS ON THIS AND MORE-
IDEAS BUT WE'RE NOT DOING ENOUGH
RIGHT NOW. HOMELESSNESS THE TOP
POLICY THE TOP PROBLEM IN
CALIFORNIA IS BEING LED BY A
COUNCIL. A COUNCIL THAT'S CO
CHAIRED. BY TWO INDIVIDUALS THAT
HAVE FULL TIME JOBS AND THAT DO
A GREAT JOB RUNNING THEIR
pTHE MAGNITUDE OF THE PROBLEM
WE'RE NOT PUTTING THE RESOURCES
THAT IT NEEDS TO SOLVE IT AT THE
STATE LEVEL. I'M AND THAT'S WHY-
I BELIEVE THAT WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO PUSH TOWARDS
CHANGING ON THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
OUR STATE GOVERNMENT TO SOLVE
THIS PROBLEM AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE TODAY THANK
YOU IN THE MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE COMMUTE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTED APPROPRIATIONS. WICKS
HI WICKS HI SEYARTO SEYARTO I
CARILLO. I GABRIEL CHOLERA
CHOLERA HI KILEY QUIRK-SILVA
WARD WARD I THOUGHT GREAT THAT
BILLS OUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
BELIEVE MISS WHEN IS NEXT AND IF
WE CAN KEEP PRESENTATION IS AS
QUICK AS POSSIBLE JUST IN TERMS
OF- WE HAVE TO BE OUT HERE BY
ONE AND WE HAVE- I THINK FIVE
MORE BILLS. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR A. B. TWO FIVE SIX NINE
SIX TO CREATE A WORKING GROUP TO
STUDY THE ISSUE ESTABLISHING THE
DEPARTMENT HOMELESSNESS.
PREVENTION OUR REGION SUPPORT TO
BETTER ADDRESS THE CURRENT
HOMELESSNESS PROBLEMS. STOP IT
FROM GETTING WORSE. I A- YOU
READY HEARD THAT WE ARE AT THE
POINT OF CRISIS IN OUR STATE-
STEPPING OUTSIDE THIS BUILDING.
WE CAN SEE FELLOW CALIFORNIA
SLEEPING ON SIDEWALKS PARK
BENCHES BEGGING ON STREET
CORNERS. EXAGGERATES UNFORTUNATE
THIS HAS BECOME AN ALL TOO
COMMON SIGHT THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. S. CALIFORNIA LEADERS WE
PROBABLY DECLARE THAT WE LIVE IN
THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WAR. BUT WHAT A WEALTHY STATE
LIKE OURS ALLOW FOR SUCH
CONDITIONS TO PERSIST OVER THE
YEARS. ACCORDING TO A TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY. ACCORDING TO A
TWENTY TWENTY ONE STAY AUTRES
REPORT EXISTING HOMELESSNESS.
SPENDING IS SPREAD ACROSS NINE
DIFFERENT STATE AGENCY
ADMINISTERING AT LEAST FORTY ONE
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS AND TOTAL
AROUND THIRTEEN POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS. THAT AMOUNT
DOES NOT ACCOUNT FOR. OR INCLUDE
COUNTY OR LOCAL FUNDS AVAILABLE
FOR COMBATING HOMELESSNESS. OVER
THE PAST THREE YEARS
CALIFORNIA'S PROVIDED ROUGHLY
SEVENTEEN BILLION DOLLARS TO
STOP AND PREVENT THE RAMPANT
HOMELESSNESS PROBLEMS. BUT
WITHOUT PROPER OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY WE DON'T KNOW IF
THE PROGRAMS ARE WORKING OR THE
RESOURCES ARE GETTING TO THOSE
WHO NEED IT THE MOST. OUR THIS
JOINT EFFORTS TEND TO TACKLE THE
ISSUE HAS COST MORE MONEY. TIME
AND LIVES. OF THIS WOULD CREATE
THE DEPARTMENT HOMELESSNESS
PREVENTION. I WHICH IN SUPPORT
AND CONSOLIDATE STATE FUNDING
PROGRAMS AND RESOURCES UNDER ONE
ROOF WOULD ALLOW WOULD PROVIDE
BETTER STEWART SAID. OF MY OF
TAXPAYERS MONEY AND RESOURCES
FOR HOMELESSNESS OUTREACH AND
PREVENTION EFFORTS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. THANK YOU YOUR PRIMARY WITNESS
IN SUPPORT OF WE DON'T HATE NO
NO WITNESSES ANYONE IN THE ROOM
WHICH EXPRESSED SUPPORT.
OPERATOR OF PHONE LINES- FOR
SUPPORT FOR A BI TWENTY FIVE
SIXTY NINE NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION ONLY PLAYS. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR TO VOICE SUPPORT FOR
TWENTY FIVE SIXTY NINE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. VENTURE
WITH A PROMPT WE HAVE NOBODY IN
IT GREAT AND WE'LL TAKE IT BACK
TO THE ROOM ANY OPPOSITION IN
THE ROOM. AND THERE IS NO-
REGISTERED OPPOSITION SO WE'LL
BRING IT BACK HERE TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. WE HAVE A SECOND-
MOTION SORRY. TO THE SECOND A
SECOND BY MISS CARILLO ANY
QUESTIONS. WELL WE'RE HAPPY TO
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK IN THE
SPACE I'M HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL
OUT OF COMMITTEE TODAY WITH THAT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YES
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE- THE SUPPORT
TODAY AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUE WORK WITH YOUR STAFF
AND- OF OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AS WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
WITH THAT THE MOTION IS A-
DEPRESSED HUMAN SERVICES TO PASS
HIM SERVICES. WICKS FIVE WEEKS I
SEYARTO SATELLITE CARILLO. KOREA
ICE GABRIEL KALRA KILEY.
QUIRK-SILVA WORD. CENTRAL YEAH
WHAT THAT'S OPEN FOR NOW THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER KING IS
NEXT. AGAIN WE APPRECIATE
REVERIE. FIRST OF ALL OF THEM
AND LET ME JUST TAKE THE
COMMITTEE- FOR THEIR HELP ON THE
BILL- THIS BILL IS CLARIFYING
THE HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY ACT
WHICH WAS. LEAVE ARE USED TO-
PROTECT BOB PROJECTS THAT WERE
BEING BUILT A PARTICULAR
JURISDICTION- PUT SIMPLY THIS
BILL CLARIFIES AB TWENTY SIX
FIFTY SIX CLARIFIES THAT.
WRONGFUL DENIAL OR WITHHOLDING
OF A SECRET CLEARANCE. TO WHICH
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS LEGALLY
ENTITLED TO. VIOLATES THE
HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY ACT BUT
THIS DOES NOT INCREASE- THE NEC
FOR EXEMPTIONS ANDIT ALSO. DOES
NOT CONSTITUTE. A DISAPPROVAL OF
THE PROJECT EXPAND WHAT CUTS TO
DISAPPROVAL PROJECTS THAT
WITHOUT RESPECT YES RIGHT BUT-
MOTION SECOND GRADE AND- OR YOUR
FIRST PRIMARY WITNESS. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIRMAN WILL BE BRIEF
MICHAEL AND WHISPER PUBLIC
POLICY THINK TANK IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA. AS MR TANG
HAS NOTED AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY
EIGHT DOES NOT TOUCH SEQUIN
ANYWAY NOR DOES IT ALTER ANY
EXISTING RIGHTS OR
RESPONSIBILITIES EXISTING
CURRENT LAW WITH REGARD TO THAT
STATUTE THIS BILL IN NO WAY A
LITTLE LEMONADES OR LIMITS
LAWFUL AND LEGITIMATE
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW. FINDINGS
AND DECLARATIONS WERE RECENTLY
AMENDED INTO THE BILL TO
EXPLICITLY CONVEY ITS INTENT TO
CLARIFY EXISTING LINE CODE IF I
H. CD'S INTERPRETATION OF THE
HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY ACT AND-ITS INTERACTION WITH SEQUINS.
BILL DOES NOT EXPAND THE
DEFINITION OF DISAPPROVAL UNDER
THE HHA WHICH BOTH THE
LEGISLATURE ASTOUNDING COURTS
HAVE RECOGNIZED ALREADY BROUGHT
INCLUDES ANY REQUIRED LAND USE
APPROVALS OR ENTITLEMENTS
NECESSARY FOR THE ISSUANCE OF A
BUILDING PERMIT. WHILE THE HA
DOES NOT EXEMPT PRODUCTS FROM
SAKE WHAT ALSO DOES NOT
AUTHORIZE CITIES TO DENY A
SECRET CLEARANCE TO WHICH A
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS LEGALLY
ENTITLED. THIS BILL MURPHYREQUIRES A SEQUEL GENTRAN
ALREADY ON THE BOOKS AND THE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS LEGALLY
ENTITLED TO BASED ON THE RECORD
BEFORE TE AGENCY BE GRANTED OR
THAT AN E. I. R. OR NECK DECK
WITH A LEGALLY SUFFICIENT BASIS
IN THE RECORD BE ADOPTED. THE
FACT IS AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY SIX
ONLY SIX UNFORCED THE LAWS
AROUND ENVIRONMENT REVIEW IF
THEY'RE ALREADY IN THAT YOU CAN
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE. GOOD AFTERNOON
CORNELIUS BURKE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION WE ARE THE
HOMEBUILDING INDUSTRY. WE ARE
PROUD TO SUPPORT AB TWENTY SIX
FIFTY SIX. IN FACT WE HAVE
LABELED THIS BILL AS A HOUSING
CAREER FOR THE YEAR. THIS BILL
SIMPLY CLOSE A LOOPHOLE IN THE
COWS AND ACCOUNTABILITY AT.
RECENTLY CREATED BY SOME TO ADD
ADDITIONAL STEPS TO CALIFORNIANS
ALREADY LENGTHY. AND COMPLICATED
HOUSING APPROVAL PROCESS- WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. FOR THIS HOUSING CREATOR
BILL THANK YOU SO MUCH ON BEHALF
OF CBI. GREAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND FOR FOLKS IN THE ROOM
THAT WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT PLEASE NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION. RAVENNA KARAMBA HAVE
CALIFORNIA B. IS SUPPORT.
STIVERS THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
PARTNERSHIP IN SUPPORT- YOU KNOW
MINE WITH THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
CONSORTIUM IN SUPPORT. ADRIN
MOHAMMED ON BEHALF OF- CIVIC
WELL HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
CALIFORNIAN SAND HILL PROPERTY'S
IN SUPPORT. TODD DAVID ON THE
HAVE THE HOUSING ACTION
COALITION IN SUPPORT. GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'LL BRING
IT BACK- SORRY- OPERATOR OF
FOLKS ON THE CALL WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY
SIX FIFTY SIX NAME ORGANIZATION
AND POSITION ONLY IF YOU COULD
OPEN UP THE LINES THAT BE GREAT
. BUT FOR FOLKS ON THE PHONE
STUDENTS FOR EXPRESSED SUPPORT
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I'M JOURNAL CALLERS A FEUD UP
OKAY WE'LL BRING IT BACK HERE-
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
. TO AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY SIX ANY
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON TEREX- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS TANYA
CHOLESBURY NUMBER HALF THE STATE
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA AND I'M
HERE IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWO SIX
FIVE SIX THE BILL AS AN ATTEMPT
BY HOUSING DEVELOPERS INTEREST
GROUPS TO EXPAND THE REACH OF
RIGHTS THE PUBLIC AND THE DUTIES
AFFORDED TO PUBLIC AGENCIES
UNDERSEA QUEST. TO ADDRESS THE
ENVIRONMENTAL AND PUBLIC HEALTH
ISSUES- BEFORE PROJECTS ARE
APPROVED THE BILL WOULD REDEFINE
BASIC LAND USE LAWS BY CREATING
A NEW DEFINITION OF PROJECT
DISAPPROVAL THAT PROHIBITS
AGENCY DECISION MAKERS FROM
REQUIRING ADDITIONAL
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW WHEN THEY
REASONABLY BELIEVE BASED ON THE
RECORD BEFORE THEN THE PROJECT
IS NOT EXEMPT OR IT REQUIRES
FURTHER ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW IN
MITIGATION. I'M EVEN THOUGH
THESE ANALYSIS ARE NOT EVEN
COMPLETE YET THIS BILL REDEFINES
THOSE ACTIONS AS DISAPPROVAL-
THIS IS CONTRARY TO SEE QUEST
AND IT WOULD REQUIRE. AGENCY
DECISION MAKERS TO WHICH WOULD
REQUIRE AGENCY DECISION MAKER
SMITH DO AN INDEPENDENT JUDGMENT
ABOUT SEA QUEST- COMPLIANCE. THE
BILL WOULD INTERRUPT THE SIGNAL
PROCESSING PRESSURE LOCAL
AGENCIES TO LIMIT THEIR REVIEW
FOR HOUSING PROJECTS OR RISK
COSTLY AND PUNITIVE LAWSUITS.
THIS TO BE PREMATURELY
CHALLENGING A SEQUEL EVALUATION
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE PROCESS
UNDER A DIFFERENT STATUTE THE
HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY ACT
INSTEAD OF UNDERSEA QUEST. AB
TWO SIX FIVE SIX WOULD INCREASE
LITIGATION IT WOULD OPEN A NEW
DOOR TO AGENCY IS BEING
THREATENED BY DEVELOPERS A TURN
TO PAY ATTORNEY'S FEES AND PAY
FINES- SIMPLY FOR BEING IN THE
MIDDLE OF A PROCESS OF
IDENTIFYING MITIGATION FOR OUR
COMMUNITY AS- IT WOULD. CAUSE A
LONGER STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS
THAT WILL ALLOW DEVELOPERS TO
CHALLENGE AGENCY DECISIONS.
ULTIMATELY IT IS JUST
INCONSISTENT WITH SEQUINS
MANDATES AND INCONSISTENT WITH
THE HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY ACT
OWN MANDATES THAT THE LOCAL
AGENCY MUST COMPLY WITH C. QUOTE
BEFORE INCURRING ANY LIABILITY
FOR DENYING A- STUDIES HAVE. A
SEAT IS NOT A MAJOR OBSTACLE TO
NEW HOUSING. CONSTRUCTION IN THE
STATE AND IS CRITICAL TO
ADDRESSING ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
PUBLIC HEALTH AND CLIMATE CHANGE
WE URGE YOU TO VOTE NO ON AB TWO
SIX FIVE SIX THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER FOLKS IN
THE ROOM IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. I WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES OPERATOR IF YOU CAN OPEN
UP THE LINES FOR THE GENERAL
PUBLIC OPPOSITION AB TWENTY SIX
FIFTY SIX. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
TO VOICE OPPOSITION TO. TWENTY
SIX FIFTY SIX PLUS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. MADAM JOURNAL COLLEGE
IF YOU UP. OKAY THANK YOU BRING
BACK HERE TO COMMITTEE-
QUESTIONS FROM ANY COLLEAGUES IN
COMMITTEE. OKAY DO WE HAVE A
MOTION. AND WE'VE GOT A MOTION
WE GOT A SECOND GREAT- IT IS TO
PASS TO THAT RESEARCH NATURAL
RESOURCES- WHAT I THINK THE
OTHER FOR MOVING THE BILL
FORWARD- HAVE BEEN WITH THE BILL
OUT OF. A WOULD ALSO URGE
CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS WITH
OPPOSITION OF COURSE- AND WITH
THAT ELLIPTICAL. WICKS FIVE
WEEKS I SEYARTO I SEE ART BY
CORREO. AEREO I GABRIEL CHOLERA.
KALRA AYE KILEY QUIRK-SILVA
BOARD. THAT THAT'S ON CALL.
PRESIDENT.
RIGHT MADAM CHAIR AGAIN FLOOR
THANK YOU. I HAVE A SIMPLE BILL
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION TODAY
EVERY YEAR IN APRIL FOR CITIES
AND COUNTIES ARE REQUIRED TO
SUBMIT THE STATE AND SUBMIT TO
THE STATE AN ANNUAL PROGRESS
REPORT FOR THEIR GENERAL PLAN
THE PROGRESS REPORTS R. A. P.
R.'S ARE EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
THEY HELP MEASURE. TO HELP
MEASURE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
PROGRESS RIGHT FOR FILLING THEIR
HOUSING ELEMENT THEY HIGHLIGHT
IMPLEMENTATION CHALLENGES THAT
MAY REQUIRE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
OR OTHER SUPPORT FROM EACH CITY
. AND THEY INFORMED POLICY
MAKING. AS THE DATA FROM THE
STATE'S FIVE THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY NINE CITIES AND
COUNTIES FORM THE BASIS OF
UNDERSTANDING OF HOUSING NEEDS
ACROSS THE STATE. IN RECENT
YEARS THE CITIES AND COUNTIES
HAVE GOTTEN VERY DIFFERENT SORRY
VERY DILIGENT ABOUT. IN RECENT
YEARS CITIES AND COUNTIES HAVE.
GOTTEN VERY DILIGENT ABOUT
SUBMITTING THEIR APR IS ON TIME
HOWEVER THE QUALITY OF THESE IF
YOURS. CAN VARY SIGNIFICANTLY AS
CURRENTLY THERE ARE NO
REQUIREMENTS THEY P. OURS BE
COMPLETE OR ACCURATE ONLY THAT
THEY ARE SUBMITTED ON TIME. THIS
BILL WOULD EMPOWER EACH TEACHER
REJECT ANY PR IF IT WASN'T
SUBSTANTIALLY COMPLIANT. WITH
THE REPORTING REQUIREMENTS IN
THE LAW WE RECENTLY TOOK
AMENDMENTS AT THE REQUEST OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES THAT CLARIFY. THAT HUD
HAS THIRTY DAYS TO REVIEW. AND
REJECT NON COMPLAIN A PR'S AND
WHEN THEY DO SO THEY HAVE TO
PROVIDE CLEAR GUIDANCE TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND GOVERNMENTS ON
HOW. THEY FIX THE PROBLEM. AB
TWENTY SIX FIFTY THREE WILL HELP
ENSURE THAT CITIES AND COUNTIES
COMPLY. AND SURE THE MISSIONARY
TRACK THEIR PROGRESS IN
IMPLEMENTING THEIR HOUSING
ELEMENT AND THE STATE NEEDS TO
HELP. UNDERSTAND HOUSING TRENDS
THIS BILL IS AUTHOR SPONSORED
HAS NO OPPOSITION AND THERE ARE
NO WITNESSES TESTIFY STAY. MARIO
MOTION BY A SECOND BY A KALRA.
SO THERE BEING NONE- NO
WITNESSES- ANYBODY IN THE ROOM
WANNA OFFER THEIR SUPPORT. THE
LINE UP. NAME YOU KNOW I AM WITH
THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
CONSORTIUM IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OKAY IS THERE ANYBODY
ON THE LINE WHO WISHES TO OFFER
SUPPORT FOR THIS. THIS IS BOTH
ON THE PHONE TO VOICE YOUR
SUPPORT THAT'S ONE ZERO. AB. TWO
SIX FIVE THREE. TO GET ON THE
PHONE PRESS ONE ZERO. BUT THAT
PUMP THERE ARE NO COLLARS
KEEPING UP ALL RIGHT WE'LL BRING
HIM BACK TO THE ROOM ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM. NOBODY
IN THE ROOM ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINES.
PROPOSITIONAL PHONE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN
WITH A PROMPT- CALLER SHOULD
KEEP UP OKAY WE'LL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMEDIAN QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. BUT THAT MEANS WHICH
YOU MAY CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. PLEASE TAKE THE
ROLE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WICKS HI ICY ARCTIC.
HERE TO KNOW CARILLO. I GABRIEL.
KALRA COLOR I KILEY QUIRK-SILVA
WARD.
WE'RE WE'RE OPEN THE CALL FOR.
EARLY SORRY LOOKING COVER ONE.
TWENTY FIVE SIXTY NINE THAT'S
HOW I AM NUMBER THIRTEEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA. KALRA AYE KILEY
QUIRK-SILVA WARD. IT'S FOR THE
LOCAL. OKAY YEAH EARNINGS ARE IS
THAT RIGHT.
ONE OF. EXACTLY IF RELATED STUFF.
ONE
FIVE. YEAH YEAH. SO- OKAY AB
THREE. THE SAME THING. YEAH YEAH
RIGHT YEAH. IF.
CLOSE THIS OUT. OKAY WE HAVE
MISTER MCCARTY HERE. THANK YOU
MR MCCARTY FOR THE SPRINT INTO
THE BUILDING- UP IS AB. TWENTY
EIGHT SIXTY THREE. OKAY I'M
GETTING SECOND THAT BILL. OKAY
SO THIS IS A MEASURE THAT WOULD-
INCREASE OUR AIR QUALITY AND
FRANKLY OUR PUBLIC HEALTH BY
FOCUSING ON BICYCLE USE AN
ALTERNATE MODES OF
TRANSPORTATION WITH OUR HOUSING-
STOCK IN CALIFORNIA AND THANK
YOU FOR MOVING THE BILL HAVING
MORE BIKE INFRASTRUCTURE REDUCES
EMISSIONS HELPS US ACHIEVE OUR
CLIMATE GOALS AS WELL AS
IMPROVED PUBLIC HEALTH. WITH ME
TODAY ARE ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA
IN THE CALIFORNIA BY COALITION
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU RIGHT THANK
YOU FOR. GOOD AFTERNOON. THE ON
THE GLOBAL WARMING SOLUTIONS
ASSOCIATE WITH ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA STATEWIDE ADVOCACY
GROUP THAT WORKS FOR CLEAN AIR
CLEAN WATER AND OPEN SPACES.
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA AND
FRONTIER GROUP'S DESTINATION
ZERO CARBON REPORT REPORT FOUND
THAT CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF ONLY
THREE STATES IN THE U. S. THAT
HAS TRANSPORTATION EMISSIONS OF
MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED MILLION.
METRIC TONS OF CARBON DIOXIDE
THE OTHER TWO STATES ARE TEXAS
AND FLORIDA. THE ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY AB TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY
THREE WILL REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AND ALSO URBAN SPRAWL
BY REQUIRING THAT. SORRY BUT BY
REQUIRING THAT- THIRTEEN NINETY.
CALIFORNIA'S TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR ACCOUNTS FOR ABOUT 50% OF
CALIFORNIA'S GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS 80% OF CALIFORNIA'S
NITROGEN OXIDE POLLUTION IN 90%
OF CALIFORNIA'S DIESEL
PARTICULATE MATTER POLLUTION.
THESE PARTICULATES ARE DAMAGING
TO OUR HEALTH AIR POLLUTION
INCREASES THE RISK OF CANCER
ASTHMA ATTACKS AND OTHER ADVERSE
HEALTH IMPACTS AND CAUSES THIRTY
FOUR THOUSAND DEATHS ON AVERAGE
EVERY YEAR IN CALIFORNIA. AB
TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY THREE WILL
REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
AND URBAN SPRAWL BY REQUIRING
THAT THERE IS NO NEED TO TIE
BICYCLE PERMITTING WITH A VIN
NUMBER OF VEHICLE PARKING
SPACES. AND ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA'S IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOUR
TESTIMONY. GOOD DAY MY NAME IS
DAVE SNYDER I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
BICYCLE COALITION. RESIDENTIAL
BICYCLE PARKING REQUIREMENTS
HAVE LONG BEEN A GOOD IDEA IN
CALIFORNIA SOME CITIES IN
CALIFORNIA ALREADY HAVE THEM- IN
EARLIER ATTEMPTS BY THE
LEGISLATURE TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE WE REALIZED THE VALUE OF
NOT TRYING TO DO THIS
LEGISLATIVELY- THROUGH THROUGH
SPECIFIC MANDATES BUT RATHER BY
ASKING THE DEPARTMENT HOUSING
COMMITTEE DEVELOPMENT TO COME UP
WITH STANDARDS. SO THIS IS THE
RIGHT WAY TO DO IT WE WE'RE
REALLY GRATEFUL TO THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR- DOING THIS THEY COME
UP WITH APPROPRIATE STANDARDS
THAT ARE FLEXIBLE DEPENDING ON
THE LOCATION. AND IT'S- YOU'RE
GONNA MAKE A HUGE DIFFERENCE FOR
CALIFORNIANS WHO WANT TO RELY ON
THEIR BIKES FOR TRANSPORTATION
ESPECIALLY WITH THE STATE
INVESTING IN THE THAT YOU
BIPARTISAN SENATORS AND THE
GROWTH OF. UTILITY BIKES I DON'T
KNOW HOW MANY OF Y'ALL OF SEEING
PEOPLE CARRY THEIR CHILDREN ON
BIG BIKES THAT WON'T FIT IN THE
ELEVATOR. YOU CAN'T CARRY UP THE
STAIRS YOU REALLY NEED TO HAVE-
BICYCLE PARKING IN YOUR BUILDING
. BY MANDATE SO- WE ARE GMO. YES
ON THIS BILL AND THANK THE SEVEN
MEMBER FOR ADVANCING. GREAT
THANK YOU AND OTHER FOLKS IN THE
ROOM WISH TO EXPRESS SUPPORT.
OPERATOR COMMITTEE GIVE THE
PHONE LINES- FOR THE GENERAL
PUBLIC TO EXPRESS SUPPORT IN AB
TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY THREE NAME
ORGANIZATION. AND POSITION ONLY
. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR TO VOICE
SUPPORT OF THE PHONE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I'M SURE WE
DO HAVE ONE QUEUING UP IT'LL BE
JUST ALONG WITH THAT LINE NUMBER.
WE'RE GOING ON A LINE NUMBER.
ONE FORTY THREE ONE FORTY THREE
LINES OPEN GOING TO PLEASE. MY
NAME IS JEREMIAH ROAR FROM THE
SACRAMENTO AREA BICYCLE
ADVOCATES AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. AND NOW I'M
TRYING TO RUN OVER THE
RESPONDENTS IN Q. OKAY LET'S
BRING IT BACK HERE- FOR PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO BE
HAVE ANY PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. ANY OTHER FOLKS- IN
THE ROOM WHICH TO EXPRESSED
OPPOSITION. I SEE NO OPPOSITION
ON FILE LET'S BRING ABOUT HERE
TOO- COMMITTEE MEMBERS- MISTER
COLOR IS A QUESTION- I DON'T
THINK THERE'S BEEN IN MOTION. OF
YEAH ALL RIGHT NO SORRY MISS
CREO- MOVED IT AND I SECOND IT.
HER DEALING WITH HERE- OKAY WITH
THAT ANY QUESTIONS. OKAY WELL I
APPRECIATE- THE AUTHORS COULD
WORK HERE ON THIS BILL HAPPY TO
MOVE THE BILL FORWARD OUT OF
THIS COMMITTEE TODAY- IN THE FOR
DISSING WORK GOES AND WITH THAT
THE MOTION IS. TO PASS TO THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON PREPARATIONS
. WICKS HI HI SEYARTO THEY ARE
NO CARILLO. CARILLO I GABRIEL
CHOLERA. KALRA AYE KILEY KILEY
NO QUIRK-SILVA. I QUIRK-SILVA I
WORK WARD I. CITY FOUR FIVE AND
NINE BILLS OUT AND I KNOW WE ARE
WAITING IN MISTER JONES SAWYER
BUT MAYBE WE SHOULD. TAKE YEP GO
THROUGH THE BILL'S ANNA FOLKS
CAN ADD ON. I AM NUMBER ONE AB
TWENTY THREE OH FIVE- KILEY.
KILEY I. EIGHT ZERO THAT BILLS
OUT I'M ITEM NUMBER TWO EIGHTEEN
FIFTY CARILLO. CORREO I KILEY.
B. SIX NINE NO NOT VOTING. YEAH
MORNING IS NOT MISTER KELLY'S
NOT VOTING RIGHT. ON THAT BILL
YEAH- ITEM NUMBER THREE EIGHTEEN
OF FIFTY EIGHT R. C. R. O. C. A.
R. NO KILEY. IN ORDER. SHOULD
STOP AFTER THIS OKAY WELL.
RELATED ARE- YEAH I KNOW LET'S
TAKE A THAT ARE NOT YEAH LET'S
TAKE A THAT ARE NOT ON WINTER.
AND THEN WILL GO TO HIS THE ONES
THAT ARE NOW WITH AS WELL OF.
RIGHT NUMBER ITEM NUMBER TWELVE
TWENTY SIX FIFTY THREE- GABRIEL
KILEY. TWENTY SIX FIFTY THREE.
NO KILEY NO QUIRK-SILVA. HI
QUIRK-SILVA I WARD. WARD I WANT
TO TODAY FOUR FIVE OKAY THAT
BILLS OUT- THE- TEAM NUMBER
FOURTEEN. RIGHT ITEM NUMBER
FOURTEEN AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY SIX
GABRIEL KILEY. KILEY I
QUIRK-SILVA QUIRK-SILVA I WARD
WARD I. SEP SEVENTEENTH AT BILLS
OUT. AND NOT A B. FIFTEEN THAT
FILL THIS OUT SO WE ARE GOOD
WITH THOSE BILLS MA'AM. THANK
YOU WE WILL NOW GO TO MISTER
JONES SAWYER THANK YOU HAVE BEEN
THE BEST FOR LAST. GOT A MOTION
A SECOND THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY SEVENTY THREE THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SUPPLIER
DIVERSITY ACT I WOULD LIKE TO
START BY THANKING THIS
COMMITTEE'S STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH MY OFFICE. ON THIS ISSUE
AND LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
DISCUSSIONS WITH RELEVANT
STAKEHOLDERS AS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD. I WILL BE ACCEPTING TO
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS AS OUTLINED
IN THE ANALYSIS IN THE NEXT
POLICY COMMITTEE. CALIFORNIANS
MAY SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS INTO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
IN RECENT YEARS UNFORTUNATELY
THESE RESOURCES HAVE BEEN
HISTORICALLY LIMITED TO
DEVELOPERS THAT DO NOT REFLECT
OUR STATE'S RICH RACIAL AND
ETHNIC DIVERSITY. AS IT STANDS
THE INDUSTRY BY AND LARGE HAS
NOT MADE A CONSCIOUS EFFORT TO
ENSURE THAT MORE DIVERSE AND
WOMEN OWNED FIRMS HAVE ACCESS TO
DEVELOPMENT RELATED CONTRACTS.
ACCORDING TO A TWENTY TWENTY ONE
SURVEY CONDUCTED BY THIS ON THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION NONPROFIT
HOUSING THE MAJORITY NONPROFIT
HOUSING DEVELOPERS DO NOT HAVE
PROCUREMENT POLICIES IN PLACE TO
ADDRESS SUPPLIER DIVERSITY. AB
TWENTY SEVENTY THREE IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MOVE CALIFORNIA
TOWARD GREATER DIVERSITY BY
REQUIRING HOUSING SPONSORS THAT
RECEIVE AN ALLOCATION OF LOW
INCOME TAX CREDITS. FROM
CALIFORNIA TAX CREDIT ALLOCATION
COMMITTEE REPORT ON THE USE OF
WOMEN MINORITIES DISABLED
VETERAN AND LGBT.
REPRESENTATIVES THIS BILL ALSO
REQUIRES THAT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPERS GREAT AND SHARE
DETAILED AND- VERIFIABLE PLANT
INCREASED DIVERSE PROCUREMENT
THROUGH AN ANNUAL REPORT.
MEMBERS IN ORDER TO ADVANCE
RACIAL AND ECONOMIC JUSTICE THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
INDUSTRY MOST INTENTIONALLY
UPLIFT INVESTING FIRMS. LED BY
PEOPLE OF COLOR. WOMEN DISABLED
VETERANS IN LGBTQ PLUS
INDIVIDUALS. THIS BILL IS ABOUT
CREATING AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR
UNDER REPRESENTED COMMUNITIES
WHO NEED IT MOST BY DIVERSE
FIRMS THAT. MORE LIKELY- WE MORE
LIKELY TO TAKE A PEOPLE CENTERED
APPROACH THAT IS MY FOR HOW
PROJECTS CAN. BENEFIT AND UPLIFT
THE SURROUNDING COMMUNITY I'M
JOINED BY CO SPONSORS ADAM
BRIANNA'S WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY BUILDERS. AND
CONSTANTINE HATCHER WITH
CALIFORNIA YIMBY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. I THANK YOU
OUR GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE MY
NAME IS ADAM BRIANNA'S AND I'M
CEO OF CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
BUILDERS A NONPROFIT PUBLIC
POLICY ORGANIZATION WORKING TO
CLOSE THE RACIAL WEALTH GAP
THROUGH HOUSING HOMEOWNERSHIP
AND SMALL BUSINESS
ENTREPRENEURSHIP. I'M HERE TODAY
IS A BILL SPONSORED EXPRESSED MY
STRONG SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY
EIGHT SEVENTY THREE BEFORE I
BEGIN MY REMARKS I WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO CHAIR WICKS AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND STAFF FOR BRINGING
FOR THIS VERY IMPORTANT BILL. AS
WELL AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES
SAWYER FOR BEING THIS
LEGISLATIVE CHAMPION ON THIS
BILL. AB TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY
THREE WILL BRING TRANSPARENCY
INCREASED ENHANCE DATA TO
SUPPORT DIVERSE SMALL BUSINESSES
IN THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING FIELD.
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY BUILDERS I
SPENT A DECADE IN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FINANCE DEVELOPMENT
MOSTLY IN NEW YORK. WHILE THERE
I HAD DIRECT INTERACTION WITH A
SIMILAR PROGRAM TO WHAT AB
TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY THREE IS
PROPOSING. CALLED THE BUILDING-
BUILDING OPPORTUNITY INITIATIVE.
AS A PROJECT MANAGER FOR THE
CITY OF NEW YORK AND IS A VICE
PRESIDENT REAL ESTATE
DEVELOPMENT AT AN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPER. I WAS THE ONE
RESPONSIBLE FOR ENSURING THAT
PAPERWORK RELATED TO WORKFORCE
TRANSPARENCY WAS SUBMITTED FOR
MY PROJECTS. THE IMPACT OF
PROGRAMS LIKE THESE OF IT
DEVELOPERS WHO ARE ALL WORKING
ON TAXPAYER FINANCED PROJECTS.
HAVE TO THINK JUST A LITTLE
HARDER ABOUT WHO THEY INVITE TO
BID FOR THEIR PROJECTS AND OFTEN
CAST A WIDER BITNET BECAUSE OF
IT. INTERN THESE PROGRAMS ALLOW
DIVERSE CONTRACTORS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD A TRACK
RECORD IN THE MOST STABLE FIELD
IN THE REAL ESTATE SECTOR. IT
HAS BEEN MY EXPERIENCE THAT WHEN
MORE SUPPLIERS CONTRACTORS AND
SUBCONTRACTORS ARE GIVEN AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BID ON WORK HE
CREATES COMPETITION AND IMPROVE
SERVICE DELIVERY FOR THE-INDUSTRY. I ALSO AGREE WITH THE
ASSOCIATED GENERAL CONTRACTORS
OF AMERICA WHO STATED THAT.
MINORITY BUSINESSES ARE MORE
LIKELY TO CREATE JOBS AND EMPLOY
WORKERS AND MINORITY
COMMUNITIES. SO THIS LEGISLATION
COULD POTENTIALLY HAVE A WIDE
RANGING AND POSITIVE IMPACT ON
DIVERSE COMMUNITIES AT NO
MATERIAL COSTS TO THE TAXPAYER.
IN CLOSING LIKE TO SAY THAT THIS
IS A SUNSHINE BILL THAT DOES NOT
ESTABLISH QUOTAS TO REQUIRE ANY
AFFORDABLE DEVELOPER. TO WORK
WITH A FIRM THAT DOES NOT MEET
THEIR STANDARDS. BASED ON
EXAMPLE SET BY NEW YORK AS WELL
AS OUR OWN CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITY COMMISSION SUPPLIER
DIVERSITY PROGRAM. I BELIEVE
THAT THIS COMMONSENSE BILL WILL
CREATE THE INFORMATION NEEDED TO
HAVE BETTER. DATA DRIVEN
CONVERSATIONS RELATED TO
SUPPORTING HARD WORKING SMALL
BUSINESSES THROUGHOUT OUR STATE.
THANK YOU- GOOD. THANK YOU
ESTEEMED CHAIR WICKS AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND THANK YOU
SEE MEMBERS- JONES SAWYER PEER
LEADERSHIP IN OFFERING THIS
IMPORTANT BILL. ROSS SELECTED
THANK BILL SPONSOR ALASKA FOR
THE ADVOCACY A SCHOLARSHIP TO
MAKE THIS POSSIBLE. HI MY NAME
IS CONSTANTIN HATCHER SENIOR
DIRECTOR OF COMMUNITY IMPACT FOR
CALIFORNIA YIMBY A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION DEDICATED TO MAKING
OUR STATE AND AFFORDABLE PLACE
TO LIVE WORK AND RAISE A FAMILY-
TO ALLEVIATE OUR CURRENT HOUSING
CRISIS CALIFORNIA'S DELOYING AN
UNPRECEDENTED AMOUNT OF
INVESTMENT HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
IN FACT DEVELOPER SPEND FIFTY
TWO BILLION AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT BETWEEN TWENTY
FIFTEEN AND TWENTY TWENTY WE
ALSO KNOW CALIFORNIA NEEDS ABOUT
THREE TIMES THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
IN THE CONSTRUCTION WORK FORCE
THAT HAS NOW CURRENTLY HOWEVER
BUSINESSES OWNED BY PEOPLE OF
COLOR AND OTHER MINORITIES HAVE
NOT SHARED IN THESE DEVELOPMENT
RESOURCES AT A RATE EQUIVALENT
TO OUR STATE'S RICH DIVERSITY.
OVER THE YEARS THIS IS LET EVERS
FIRMS LOSING BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN POTENTIAL CONTRACTS WHICH
MEANS OUR DIVERSE COMMUNITIES
MISSED OUT ON THE OPPORTUNITY TO
EARN BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
WEALTH IN THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS OF LIFE CHANGING IF
THE CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY WAS AS
DIVERSE AS CALIFORNIA'S
POPULATION COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
COULD EXPECT APPROXIMATELY
THIRTY TWO POINT FOUR BILLION IN
PAYROLL INVESTMENTS ALONE
IMAGINE THE IMPACT THESE
RESOURCE COULD HAVE ON SOME OF
OUR MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
BUT JUST INCENTIVIZING MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BUILDERS TO
BE MORE INTENTIONAL ABOUT WHO
THEY'RE HIRING. AB TWENTY EIGHT
SEVENTY THREE IS A FIRST STEP IN
ADDRESSING THIS TRAGIC INEQUITY
AND GIVES THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DRIVE FOR RACIAL AND ECONOMIC
JUSTICE AND PROMOTE TRANSPARENCY
AROUND RACIAL INEQUITIES WITHIN
THE INDUSTRY BY TRACKING
SUPPLIER DIVERSITY BY
DIVERSIFYING THE PIPELINE OF
PEOPLE WHO SHARED THE REVENUE
RESULTING FROM THE VITAL PUBLIC
INVESTMENTS WE CAN INCREASE
WEALTH THE MOST COMMUNITIES
TYPICALLY EXCLUDED FROM SUCH A
VALUABLE OPPORTUNITIES
SIMULTANEOUSLY NURTURING TO
BURSTYN'S CONSTRUCTION AND
DEVELOPMENT SUPPLY FIRMS WILL
HELP INCREASE THE VOLUME UP
THAT'S PRETTY NEAT CONSTRUCTION
DESIGN ENGINEERING AND OTHER
RELATED FIRMS OPERATING
SUCCESSFULLY ACROSS THE STATE.
IF THE DIVERSE FIRMS AND WORKING
WILL HELP INCREASE THE ANNUAL
NUMBER OF HOMES BUILT IN
CALIFORNIA AND HELP FINANCIALLY
EMPOWER COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
THAT HAVE LONG BEEN SHUT OUT OF
PASS. TO UPWARD MOBILITY AND
PROSPERITY. THIS HELPS GROW THE
WORKFORCE IN A WAY THAT
ENCOURAGES RACE EQUITY. HELPING
SOLVE OVERALL SUPPLY SHORTAGE IN
WITH ALSO ADVANCES GOOD JOBS FOR
PEOPLE OF COLOR WOMEN AND THOSE
FROM DIVERSE BACKGROUNDS. THIS
IS WHY ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
YIMBY IN OUR TENS OF THOUSAND
MEMBERS AND AFFILIATED
ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS THE STATE.
I HUMBLY REQUEST YOUR BILL IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY EIGHT
SEVENTY THREE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND- ANY OTHER
FOLKS IN THE ROOM OF LIKE TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL.
OPERATOR WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINE- SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY
EIGHT SEVENTY THREE NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ONLY
FOR THE GENERAL PUBLIC CAN YOU
OPEN THE LINES. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR TO USE FOR ALL OVER THE
PHONE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME WE DID HAVE ONE QUEUE
UP A FEW MOMENTS AGO. A BIT
EARLY RENEWAL LINES WERE ONE
FORTY SIX POINT ONE FORTY SIX
ONE IS OPEN GO AHEAD PLEASE. ARE
THERE. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
ROBERT STRUGGLING ON WE CAN'T
YOU CAN YOU CAN BE AN ACT. A. B.
TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY. THANK YOU
. THANK YOU AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE NUMBER. ONE FORTY FIVE ONE
ONE FORTY FIVE ONE. OKAY CALLING
FOR SENATE THREE THE M. EIGHT.
PAPER OF THE BILL. M. S. WILL GO
TO ALIGNMENT NUMBER ONE FORTY
TWO. ONE ONE FORTY TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THERE COULD NOT BE
DHALIWAL ON BEHALF OF TECH-EQUITY COLLABORATIVE IN SUPPORT
SYSTEM. NEXT UP WE HAVE LINE ONE
FORTY EIGHT WHO'S GONNA. HI THIS
IS ADAM BOOKBINDER POLICY WE'VE
SOUTH BAY YOU'D BE TRANSPORT AB
TWO EIGHT SEVEN THREE THANK YOU. WE DO HAVE ONE MORE WE JUST
SOMEONE WILL GATHER THAT LINE
NUMBER. ONE ONE FORTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD PLEASE. HI
THIS IS HELPING OUT WITH BUT FOR
EVERYONE IN SUPPORT. THE MANAGER
WE HAVE NO ADDITIONAL CALLERS IN
Q. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL
BRING IT BACK HERE ANY PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. ANY
ADDITIONAL FOLKS AND OPPOSITION
IN THE ROOM THAT WISH TO
REGISTER THEIR OPPOSITION. AND
SEE NO POSITION ON FILE LET'S
BRING BACK HERE TO OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WE'VE HAD WE HAVE A
MOTION A SECOND ANY QUESTIONS
FOR OUR AUTHOR. OKAY WE'RE AT
THE TAIL END OF THIS HEARING MY
FRIEND- APPRECIATE YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN THE SPACE YOUR
COMMITMENT TO- AS- EQUITY ISSUES
ON EVERYTHING INCLUDING AND
HOUSING. VERY HAPPY TO MOVE THE
BILL FORWARD- AND SEE IT THROUGH
AND ANYTHING I CAN DO TO HELP IT
MOVE FORWARD AND THE OTHER
COMMITTEES AS WELL I WOULD LENDS
SUPPORT. AND WITH THAT THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO JOBS
ECONOMY DEVELOPMENT ECONOMY-
WITH THAT PLEASE CIRCLE. WICKS
HI. HI SEYARTO. HERE THE
FOURTEENTH. CARILLO I GAVE.
KALRA CALL HI. KILEY OFF I
MORNING I'M SORRY MORE.
QUIRK-SILVA QUIRK-SILVA I WORK
WORK I. THREE FOUR FIVE WITH.
EVERYTHING YEAH THE BILL THAT
THE BILLS OUT. GOING BACK TO
WHEN THANK YOU. SO WHAT ITEM WE
HAVE ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN AB
TWENTY FIVE SIXTY NINE GABRIEL.
KILEY KILEY I QUIRK-SILVA CLOSE
TO BY WARD WORK NO. I OUT OKAY
SHOULD WE START AT THE BEGINNING
. ORDER WE NEED TO GO- ITEM
NUMBER FOUR TO ADD. NOT AT ITEM
NUMBER FOUR AB TWENTY TWO THIRTY
THREE. SEYARTO I'M SORRY WHICH
ONE ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB TWENTY
TWO THIRTY THREE. NUMBER K.
FOURTEEN OUR KALRA KILEY KILEY I. ONE SEVEN EIGHT SIX THREE ZERO
SAN WE ARE NINE ITEM NUMBER FIVE
KILEY. I ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB
NINETEEN SIXTY ONE. I. FIGURE
ITEM NUMBER SIX AB TWO ZERO FIVE
THREE KILEY. NO. ITEM NUMBER.
SEVEN TWENTY ONE THIRTY NINE
KILEY. KILEY I QUIRK-SILVA HI
QUIRK-SILVA I. THE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT TWENTY TWO NINETY FIVE
KILEY. QUIRK-SILVA. ITEM EIGHT
TWENTY TWO NINETY FOUR- MISTER
BLOOM ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOMS I.
ONE AND WE HAVE I BELIEVE THE
ONE MORE ITEM- TWO MORE. ITEM
NUMBER NINE- KALRA. KILEY. AN
ITEM NUMBER TEN OUR LAST REALLY
BELIEVED WHAT CONCAVE GRILLE
KILEY. KILEY I QUIRK-SILVA. HE
SAID QUIRK-SILVA I. AND. RIGHT.
ONE TWO THREE FOUR FIVE. HE'S
LET'S TAKE HIM ALL TWENTY ONE
NOT HERE. NINE HERE. THE KILEY
I'M SO SORRY TO HEAR THAT YOU
CAN KILEY. ITEM NUMBER TEN- THAT
IS TWENTY THREE TWENTY FIVE.
FIVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL I.
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE- TWENTY SIX
FIFTY THREE. HI NUMBER GABRIEL I. I'M ITEM NUMBER. THIRTEEN
TWENTY FIVE SIXTY NINE. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GABRIEL IS I OUR ITEM
NUMBER. ON THIRTEEN I DO SIR AS
AN I. YEAH. THANK YOU I'M I ITEM
NUMBER FOURTEEN- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL I. I DID NUMBER FIFTEEN
HI I. AND I REMEMBER- SIXTEEN
TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY THREE I. A
NINE- LET ME DOUBLE CHECK. YOU
ARE HERE I DO HAVE YOU AS A NINE
OKAY WONDERFUL THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU ALL OF OUR MEETING OUR
BILLS ARE OUT OF. OUR MEETING IS
ADJOURNED.